ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
ओके लेट्स सी ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबडी इफ यू आर एबल टू
सी एंड एबल टू लिसन ऑडियो एंड विजिबिलिटी
बिल्कुल सही है एक बार सभी लोग बता दीजिए
फटाफट
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू नमस्ते
नमस्ते टू ऑल ऑफ यू
अह वेरी वेरी गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी। थोड़ा आज डिले हो गया सेशन आपका।
7:00 pm की जगह 7:30 PM पे स्टार्ट हो रही
है। कुछ नेटवर्क कंजेशंस आ चुके थे जिसकी
वजह से थोड़ा डिले करना पड़ा। बट फाइनली
सेशन जो है वो हो पा रही है। अदरवाइज मुझे
लगा था कि सेशन ही नहीं हो पाएगी। अ जिस
तरह की प्रॉब्लम्स हो रही थी बार-बार बट
वी आर हियर एंड एवरीथिंग सीम्स फाइन। सो
मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए क्योंकि नेटवर्क का
इशू था तो मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कीजिए सभी
लोग कि ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल ही सही है
ना? किसी तरह का कोई ऐसा कुछ तो ग्लिच या
कुछ ऐसा इशू तो नहीं आप फेस कर रहे हैं
ऑडियो या वीडियो में? कोई ट्रिपिंग या
लाइक व्हाटएवर एनीथिंग
नहीं है।
एवरीथिंग इज़ गुड। सब क्लियर है? बहुत
बढ़िया।
वेरी गुड। एवरीथिंग इज़ क्लियर।
ठीक है।
हम
ओके ओके चलिए सो क्लियर
नेक्स्ट बैच ऑफ़ डीसीएपीडी ग्रुप में जॉइन
कर लीजिए। आपको पता चल जाएगा। सो यहां पे
40 प्लस पीपल हैव ऑलरेडी जॉइ नाउ। नाउ वी
विल बी स्टार्टिंग हियर। एंड आज की टॉपिक
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है। काफी काफी काफी
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है आज की
टॉपिक। आपको मजा आएगा। काफी ज्यादा मजा
आएगा।
ओके ओके ओके चलिए सो गाइस देखो आज का जो
टॉपिक होने वाला है वो बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट बहुत ही ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
एसओसी के पर्सपेक्टिव से अ अगर बात करें
एज एन एसओसी एल1 अगर मैं बात करूं अ तो
आप में से हर एक बंदे को जानकारी तो होनी
ही चाहिए। इसके अलावा इवन इफ यू आर फ्रॉम
साइबर सिक्योरिटी बैकग्राउंड मतलब साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के आप किसी और डोमेन से भी
हैं। बेसिकली साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए ही
यह टोटली बहुत ज्यादा यूज़फुल है। एंड अ
ऐसी जो टॉपिक्स हैं वो हर टाइप के
ट्रेनिंग के अंदर भी अगर हो इंक्लूडेड तो
वो गलत नहीं है। क्योंकि ये जो टॉपिक्स
हैं ये जो आज का पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक है यह
एक एडवांस थ्रेट डिटेक्शन
प्लेटफार्म है। एक तरह का एक एडवांस थ्रेट
डिटेक्शन टूल है प्लेटफार्म जिसका यूज
करके हम थ्रेट्स को या पॉसिबल थ्रेट्स को
डिटेक्ट करते हैं। ठीक है? सिंपल मिटिगेट
भी करते हैं। बहुत सारी चीजें करते हैं।
अभी मैं आपको आज जितना सिंपल बताऊंगा आपको
होपफुली समझ में आने वाला है। क्योंकि यह
टॉपिक यह जो टॉपिक है यूजुअली बहुत लोगों
को काफी टफ लगता है। लोगों को लगता है अरे
यार इट्स नॉट गेटिंग इंटू माय माइंड। बट
आज मैं जैसे मैं आपको बताऊंगा यह काफी
आसान लगेगा आपको और आपके दिमाग में पूरा
फिट बैठ जाएगा। दिमाग में पूरा सेट हो
जाएगा। ठीक है? तो बिल्कुल भी टेंशन नहीं
लेना है। आज जो टॉपिक हम स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं वो है हमारा अ
ईडीआर।
दिस विल बी द टॉपिक। इसका फुल फॉर्म होता
है एंड पॉइंट एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
एंड रिस्पांस एंड रिस्पांस। ये इसका फुल
फॉर्म होता है एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड
रिस्पांस। अब यहां हम इस पे डिटेल में
आएंगे सब कुछ करेंगे। एंड पॉइंट का मतलब
देखो इसमें डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस का मतलब
सबको समझ में आ रहा होगा। एवरीवन माइट हैव
बीन गेटिंग कि डिटेक्शन क्या होता है?
रिस्पांस क्या होता है? ये सबको पता होगा
जनरली कि हां भाई डिटेक्ट कोई चीज को
डिटेक्ट करना डिटेक्शन होती है। एंड अगर
रिस्पॉन्ड उसका कुछ रिस्पांस दें या कुछ
रिसोंड करें तो उसका वो रिस्पांस होता है।
बट यहां पे एंड पॉइंट का मतलब हो सकता है
आप में से कई लोगों को समझ ना आ रहा हो या
या नहीं पता हो। देखो मैं बहुत ही सिंपल
तरीके से बताऊंगा। जो भी बताऊंगा तब आपके
दिमाग में पूरी तरीके से फिट बैठ जाएगा।
टेक्निकली भी थ्योरेटिकली भी,
कॉनसेप्चुअली भी हर तरीके से। एंड पॉइंट
का मतलब एंड यूजर से है। यहां पे जो एंड
यूजर जो चीज यूज करता है जैसे मैं एक यूजर
हूं। मैं एक मशीन यूज कर रहा हूं। एक
लैपटॉप ये मेरा एंड पॉइंट डिवाइस है। मैं
एक प्रिंटर यूज़ कर रहा हूं। एंड पॉइंट
डिवाइस है। मैं एक मॉनिटर यूज़ कर रहा हूं।
एंड पॉइंट डिवाइस है। तो जो भी आप एक
तरीके से एज अ ह्यूमन एज अ लाइक नेटवर्क
के अंदर कोई डिवाइस जो आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं,
वह एक तरह का एंड पॉइंट डिवाइस है। एंड
दैट इज़ एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस।
यानी एंड पॉइंट के ऊपर अगर किसी तरह का
अटैक होता है जैसे आपके लैपटॉप, आपके
सर्वर, आपके प्रिंटर या नेटवर्क में कोई
भी डिवाइसेस है राउटर, स्विचेस व्हाटएवर
डिवाइसेस आर देयर अगर उस पे कोई अटैक होता
है तो उसके उस अटैक को डिटेक्ट करना और उस
अटैक को डिटेक्ट करने के बाद उसके
अकॉर्डिंग रिस्पॉन्ड करना यह काम होता है
ईडीआर का। मैंने बहुत ही सरल और बहुत ही
सीधा भाषा में आपको यह इसका डेफिनेशन
बताया। बहुत सरल और बहुत ही क्लीन क्लीन
एंड क्लियर भाषा में आपको इसका मतलब बताया
हुआ है। ठीक है? अब हम इस पे डिटेल में
जाएंगे। बट उसके पहले मैं आपको अगेन फिर
से क्लियर कर देना चाहता हूं। सबसे पहला
जो आपका काम होता है वो है YouTube पे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च कीजिएगा। डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी आपको YouTube चैनल आपको मिल जाएगी।
इस चैनल को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। लाइव सेक्शन
में आप आइएगा तो आपको सारे एसओसी के
वीडियोस मिलेंगे। इसमें कोई भी प्रीवियस
एसओसी के वीडियो को सीधा कर लीजिएगा। एंड
इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइएगा।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाके आपको दो लिंक्स
मिलेंगे। ठीक है? एक WhatsApp चैनल का और
एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का। चैनल वाले जो है
इसको आके चैनल वाले लिंक पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी नाम से चैनल होगा। इसको आप फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। इसको फॉलो करके बिल्कुल फ्री है।
या तो आप WhatsApp पे जाके एक्सप्लोर
चैनल्स पे जाके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे
तो भी आपको मिल जाएगा। लगभग 13,000 लोग
हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं इस चैनल के थ्रू। यहां
पे जितनी भी अपडेट्स होती हैं आपको हमारे
साइड से जो भी ओवरऑल हर चीज से रिलेटेड वो
सबसे पहले इसी चैनल पे आती है। कहीं भी
नहीं आएगी आपको इस चैनल पे आ जाएगी। तो आप
इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। दूसरा एक ग्रुप
होगा जो कि एसओसी स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है। एंड
इन पूरे एसओसी के ग्रुप्स में लगभग 5000
लोग हमारे से जुड़े हुए हैं जो एसओसी को
रेगुलरली सीरीज को फॉलो करते हैं या एसओसी
के लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टेड थे। आप
इनको ग्रुप जॉइ कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि इस
ग्रुप में एसओसी से रिलेटेड जितने भी
रिसोर्सेज हैं, जितने भी नोट्स हैं
व्हाटएवर डिटेल्स आर देयर या अपकमिंग जो
भी इंटर्नशिप या आपके सर्टिफिकेशन या आपके
एसओसी के रिगार्डिंग जॉब इंटरव्यू के
रिगार्डिंग प्रिपरेशन के रिगार्डिंग ठीक
है वो सब कुछ इसी में आने वाला है तो इसको
ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा उसके बाद ये Lindin
प्रोफाइल है जो कि मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल
है ये यूआरएल है इसका टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
करके ऐसे आप इस पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं फॉलो कर सकते हैं यहां पे यहां
भी लगभग 13000 लोग मुझसे जुड़े हुए हैं आप
भी वन ऑफ़ देम हो सकते हैं एंड मुझसे
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं ठीक है साथ ही यहीं पे
आप अगर Lindin पे ही डिफ़्रॉनिक्स अगर सर्च
करते हैं आप सिर्फ तो हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
साइबर सिक्योरिटी जो हमारी कंपनी है उसकी
Lindin पेज आपको मिल जाएगी। इस पे जरूर
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि ये मैं इसलिए बोल
रहा हूं क्योंकि इसी पेज के ऊपर में आपको
हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग हमारा किस
तरीके से हम आगे प्रोसीड कर रहे हैं। किस
तरीके से हम कंपनी को आगे लेकर जा रहे
हैं, क्या-क्या चीजें कर रहे हैं वो सारी
इनेशन आपको इसी पेज पे मिलेगी। तो आप इस
पेज पर आ जाइएगा। आपको सारी जो भी गिव अवे
है, कोर्स के रिगार्डिंग अपडेट है या कोई
नई चीज स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं वो सब कुछ आपको
इसी पे मिले। तो इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। ये
हमारा एक्स का पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्सic साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। तो इसको आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ है।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ ये
Instagram का पेज है जहां पे लगभग 48,000
लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल
रील कंटेंट्स के लिए आप इसको फॉलो जरूर
कीजिएगा। यह मेरी खुद की पर्सनल Instagram
पेज है। आप इसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं डे टू
डे लाइफ मुझसे कनेक्ट करने के लिए, अपडेट
करने के लिए खुद को। एंड यह रही हमारी
वेबसाइट एंड दिस यू कैन ब्राउज़ फॉर
वेरियस पर्पस इनेशन एंड ऑल। यहां हमारा
नंबर है जिस पे आप हमसे कांटेक्ट करके और
हमसे किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी क्वेश्चंस
वगैरह पूछ सकते हैं। साथ में एकडमी पे
जाके हमारे कोर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं एंड
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं। तो ये पूरी इनेशन
थी जो आपको यहां पे मिल चुकी है। नाउ
लेट्स स्टार्ट टुडेज़ द मोस्ट इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक एंड इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है क्योंकि
मैंने इस इसको इंटरेस्टिंग आपके लिए बनाया
है एंड आपको काफी मजा आने वाला है। ठीक
है? चलिए तो हम आज स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं
ईडीआर से। ईडीआर एग्जजेक्टली क्या होता
है? क्यों ये इंपॉर्टेंट है? एज एन एसोसी
एल1 आपके लिए कितना इंपॉर्टेंट हो सकता
है? एज अ साइबर सिक्योरिटी गाय आपके लिए
कितना
इंपॉर्टेंट हो सकता है? यह सब कुछ हम
जानने वाले हैं। ईडीआर वगैरह के जो ऊपर है
वो काम करते हैं। एंटरप्राइज लेवल पे काम
होता है। ईडीआर के ऊपर में काम होता है।
एंड नॉर्मल छोटी-मोटी कंपनीज़ में ईडीआर का
कोई यूज़ नहीं होता है। ठीक है? यह बात याद
रखिएगा।
गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। अभी तक जो कर रहे
हैं। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते सभी को।
छोटे-मोटे कंपनीज़ में ईडीआर का कोई रोल
नहीं होता है। एंड वहां पे एंटीवासेस काम
करती हैं। ठीक है? जो काम एंटीवायरस करता
है ना वही सेम काम ईडीआर का होता है। बट
दोनों में बहुत बड़ा डिफरेंस है। मैंने
क्यों बोला कि ईडीआर जो काम जो एंटीवायरस
करता है वही ईडीआर करता है। मैंने ऐसा
क्यों बोला? ऐसा इसलिए बोला कि एंटीवायरस
का भी काम है थ्रेट्स को या यू कैन से कि
कोई अटैक है किसी तरह का कोई मलिशियस
थ्रेट है कोई मलशियस पेलोड है उसको रोकना
एडीआर का भी काम होता है वही सेम काम करना
थ्रेट्स को रोकना ठीक है एडीआर और
एंटीवायरस बोथ आर सेम वायरसेस वर्म्स
मैलवेयरस थ्रेट्स को रोकना एंटीवायरस का
काम इसका भी काम ऑलमोस्ट वही है बट ये अलग
कैसे है एंटीवायरस से ये भी हम आज के
वीडियो में आज की क्लासेस में समझेंगे
क्योंकि ये दोनों के बीच का डिफरेंस जानना
आपके लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। कई
लोग ईडीआर और एंटीवायरस में अंतर ही नहीं
समझ पाते हैं। उनको लगता है दोनों सेम है।
दोनों चीज़ सेम है। ईडीआर एंटरप्राइज में
बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनीज़ में यूज़ होती है। तो देखो
दोनों का काम भी अलग है। दोनों में
डिफरेंसेस भी है। वो भी मैं आपको बताने
वाला हूं। ठीक है?
अब देखिए ईडीआर एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
रिस्पांस जैसा कि मैंने पहले ही बताया।
एंड पॉइंट के डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस में
काम आता है। आल्सो रेफर्ड टू ऐज़ एंड पॉइंट
डिटेक्शन एंड थ्रेट रिस्पांस ईडीटीआर।
इसको हम ईडीटीआर भी बोलते हैं। तो अगर कोई
आपसे पूछे ईडीआर क्या है? ईडीटीआर क्या
है? तो दोनों ही ऑलमोस्ट सेम चीजें हैं।
ईडीआर एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन रिस्पांस
ईडीटीआर एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड थ्रेट
रिस्पांस। ठीक है? इज एन एंड पॉइंट
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन दैट कंटीन्यूसली
मॉनिटर्स एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस टू डिटेक्ट
एंड रिसोंड टू साइबर थ्रेट्स लाइक
मैलवेयर्स रसवेयर्स
एक्सट्रा वर्म्स एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा तो यह
एक 24 * 7 चलने वाला कंटीन्यूअस मॉनिटर
करने वाला एक सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन है
जिसमें एंड पॉइंट को जो है वो सिक्योर
किया जाता है। एंड पॉइंट के ऊपर जो भी
थ्रेट्स आने वाले हैं, जो भी अटैक हो रहे
हैं, उसको डिटेक्ट करना और उसको रिस्पॉन्ड
करना उसके अकॉर्डिंग काम होता है। अब मुझे
आप सब में से सभी लोगों से पूछ रहा हूं।
एक तो पहले लाइक ठोक देना और सबसे पूछ रहा
हूं कि एंड पॉइंट डिवाइसेस जो जिसकी मैं
बात कर रहा हूं, उसके कुछ एग्जांपल आप लोग
चैट में बताइए। सभी लोग बताइए। चाहे आपका
आंसर गलत हो या सही हो। मैंने ऑलरेडी
स्टार्टिंग में ही इस लाइव क्लास के बोल
दिया है। बट स्टिल आप लोग बताइए कि कुछ
एंड पॉइंट्स के नाम बताइए जो आप समझते हैं
कि वह एंड पॉइंट होता है। सो लेट मी नो।
अलबरूनी यस ब्रदर यू कैन यू कैन कंटिन्यू
द डे 26 अल्बनी क्योंकि ये बिल्कुल फ्रेश
टॉपिक है। पहले कोई भी यहां पे आज के
टॉपिक को कंटिन्यू कर सकता है क्योंकि ये
बिल्कुल फ्रेश टॉपिक है एंड यू डोंट ऐसा
कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है कि पिछली क्लास
आपको करनी ही पड़ेगी इस क्लास के लिए। तो
ये बिल्कुल ही फ्रेश है। तो आप एकदम से आज
की क्लास अलग से कर सकते हो।
ओके पीसी लैपटॉप सर्वर ईटीसी लैपटॉप सर्वर
मोबाइल फोन पेनड्राइव ठीक है मोबाइल फोन
ठीक है क्राउड स्ट्राइक
क्राउड स्ट्राइक कहां से आ गया
क्राउड स्ट्राइक इज नॉट द आंसर क्राउड
स्ट्राइक इज अ कंपनी जो एंड पॉइंट
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन प्रोवाइड करता है ना
कि एंड पॉइंट है
डेस्कटॉप फोंस ठीक है सर्वर प्रिंटर
मोबाइल ठीक है बिल्कुल सही सो मोस्ट ऑफ यू
हैव अ आंसर्ड करेक्टली। तो जो डिवाइसेस आप
यूज़ करते हैं एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में जैसे
लैपटॉप हो गया, आपका, कंप्यूटर हो गया,
आपका, प्रिंटर हो गया, आपका लाइक सर्वर हो
गया। ये सारे एंड पॉइंट्स हैं। इनको
सिक्योर करने वाला एंड पॉइंट्स डिटेक्शन
एंड रिस्पांस ईडीआर कहलाता है। अब एन
इडीआर ऑपरेट्स ऑन अ सिंपल हब एंड स्पोक
मॉडल। हब एंड स्पोक मॉडल पे ये काम करता
है। स्पोक का आपने स्पोक देखा होगा। राइट?
स्पोक का आपने वो देखा होगा कि एक सेंट्रल
स्पोक में क्या होता है? आपने जो अ
साइकिल साइकिल के अंदर स्पोक होती हैं या
कई ऐसे बाइक्स आते हैं जो स्पोक व्हील्स
के साथ आते हैं। अलॉय व्हील्स एंड स्पोक
व्हील्स। तो स्पोक व्हील्स वाले वो कैसे
होते हैं? एक सेंटर में एक राउंड कलर का
कुछ होता है और उससे चारों तरफ स्पोक्स
निकले होते हैं। राइट? उसी तरीके से ईडीआर
भी काम करती है। सेंटर में एक ईडीआर कंसोल
होता है। उसको हम ईडीआर कंसोल बोलते हैं।
और चारों तरफ जो है उसके एजेंट्स होते हैं
जिनको हम एजेंट्स बोलते हैं। ठीक है?
इडीआर कंस जो कंसोल के चारों तरफ होते हैं
उनको हम एजेंट्स बोलते हैं। कई केसेस में
उनको सेंसर्स भी बोला जाता है। सेंसर्स।
तो बहुत सारे ईडीआर एजेंट्स होते हैं और
बीच में एक कंसोल होता है जहां से वो सारे
एजेंट्स को कंट्रोल किया जाता है। बस ये
चीज है। अभी मैं आपको सारा कुछ दिखाऊंगा।
ठीक है?
नो इशूज़ एल्बोनी कोई बात नहीं है। अब
देखिए
डायरेक्टली एंड पॉइंट लाइट एजेंट्स सीट
डायरेक्टली ऑन एंड पॉइंट्स। एजेंट्स जो है
एंड पॉइंट्स पे रहते हैं। एंड पॉइंट्स का
मतलब वही है लैपटॉप, सर्वर, क्लाउड,
वर्चुअल मशीनंस ये सब चीज़। क्लाउड में भी
जो वीएम है मान लो कोई वीएम है जो क्लाउड
में है वो भी एंड पॉइंट ही कहलाता है। याद
रखिएगा तो क्लाउड बेस्ड भी मशीनंस जो हैं
या आपका जो बेसिकली इंट्रा नेटवर्क में
कोई लाइक मशीन है चाहे वर्चुअल मशीन है
चाहे लैपटॉप्स है चाहे सर्वर्स है प्रिंट
वो सारे एंड पॉइंट्स ही कहलाते हैं। एंड
स्ट्रीम टेलीमेट्री बैक टू अ सेंट्रलाइज्ड
क्लाउड इंजन फॉर हैवी ड्यूटी एनालिसिस। अब
इसका मैं आपको एक एक ओवरव्यू थोड़ा सा
बताता हूं। आई डोंट नो मेरे पास इमेज है
कि अभी नहीं होगा शायद। मैं आपको एक
ओवरव्यू बता देता हूं। ठीक है?
कुछ इस तरीके से होती है।
लेट मी
ड्रॉ इट फॉर यू ताकि आपको थोड़ी क्लेरिटी
मिल जाएगी। मैं डॉ कर दूंगा ना तो आपको
बहुत ज्यादा क्लेरिटी मिल जाएगा।
ठीक है? ये रहा। तो कुछ इस तरीके से यह
काम करता है।
यह आपका जो होता है वह होता है एडीआर
कंसोल।
यह आपका एडीआर कंसोल होता है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे जो है ये एक हो गया।
यह हो गया।
ये हो गया।
इस तरीके से यह हो गया।
यह हो गया।
यह हो गया। अब यह जो सारे हैं ये सारे जो
हैं ये आपके अभी के लिए मान लो ये
आपके क्या है? ये आपके
एंड
पॉइंट्स हैं। एंड पॉइंट्स हैं या एंड
पॉइंट्स एंड एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस हैं। राइट?
यह आपके एंड पॉइंट्स हैं।
ठीक है? मैं इसको यहां पे पेस्ट कर देता
हूं। ये आपके एंड पॉइंट्स हैं।
अब इन्हीं एंड पॉइंट्स के ऊपर में बैठे
होते हैं। कौन से? क्या बैठे होते हैं? वह
बैठे होते हैं
ईडीआर
एजेंट्स।
तो हर एक एंड पॉइंट पे एक एजेंट जो है वो
बैठा होता है। कुछ इस तरीके से।
कुछ इस तरीके से हर एक इडीआर एंड पॉइंट पर
एक इडीआर एजेंट
अपना ठिकाना जमाए हुए बैठा रहता है। सिंपल
बस कुछ इस तरीके से विजुअलाइज होती है।
ठीक है? अब यह जो सारे
इडीआर एजेंट्स हैं, यह इस एंड पॉइंट से
डेटा कलेक्ट करते हैं। लॉग्स
लॉग्स को कलेक्ट करते हैं। डेटा को कलेक्ट
करते हैं। एंड इन डेटा को ये ईडीआर कंसोल
में भेजते हैं।
इन डाटा को यह
ईडीआर कंसोल में सारे जो ईडीआर एजेंट्स
हैं वो भेजते हैं। कुछ इस तरीके से
ये इस तरीके से यह भेजते हैं। ठीक है?
इस तरीके से ये पूरा इडीआर एजेंट और ये
एंड पॉइंट्स के ऊपर इस तरीके से ये काम
करते हैं और इडीआर कंसोल के लिए डेटा
भेजने का काम करते हैं। सो एक बीच में
सेंट्रलाइज्ड कंसोल है। सारे एंड पॉइंट्स
आपके मशीनंस वगैरह लगे। हर मशीन पे एक
इडीआर एजेंट बैठा हुआ है और वो एडीआर
एजेंट उस मशीन से लॉग्स और इनेशन निकालता
है और एडीआर कंसोल के फीड कर देता है।
इडीआर कंसोल की तरफ भेज देता है। ठीक है?
जब वो भेजता है। क्यों? क्योंकि उस पे
फर्दर और भी इन डेप्थ एनालिसिस और
इन्वेस्टिगेशन हो सके कि एग्जैक्टली यह जो
पर्टिकुलर थ्रेट है वो किस लेवल का थ्रेट
है? क्या करना चाहिए इसके साथ? किस तरीके
के आगे की पोस्ट प्रोसेसिंग होनी चाहिए।
दैट्स इट। समझ में आ गया? आर यू गेटिंग
हियर?
अ प्लीज गाइस फोकस इधर कीजिए। अ एवरीवन
प्लीज फोकस हियर एंड प्लीज डोंट पोस्ट
अनरिलेटेड स्टफ इन द चेक। ठीक है सर।
प्रोटीन
प्रोटीन ई गवर्नमेंट व्हिच वर्क्स फॉर पैन
कार्ड डाटा। ठीक है। इसमें मेरा एसओसी एल1
में हो गया। कैसी कंपनी है? एनी आईडिया। अ
ओके विपिन सबसे पहले तो कांग्रेचुलेशंस
विपिन। दिस इज़ अ गवर्नमेंट बैक्ड कंपनी
प्रोटीन जो ई गवर्नमेंट करके आप बोल रहे
हैं। मतलब गवर्नमेंट के टेंडर्स वगैरह
इनके पास है काफी सारे अभी के टाइम में।
एंड इट इज़ अ गुड कंपनी फॉर नाउ। इनका शेयर
भी है शेयर मार्केट में। ठीक-ठाक वह अभी
वह कर रहे हैं। एंड इट्स अ गुड कंपनी। यू
शुड कंटिन्यू इन दिस एंड एसओसी एल1 के तौर
पे हुआ है। दैट्स अ बिग थिंग। दैट्स अ
वेरी गुड थिंग। एंड आई रियली कांग्रेचुलेट
यू फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर जॉब। एंड मजे करो।
आपकी जॉब लग गई। क्या बात है। अच्छी बात
है। हमारे बीच से किसी एक बंदे की जॉब लगी
है। दैट्स अ वेरी गुड थिंग। सो ह्यूज
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू।
ठीक है? बैक टू द टॉपिक। तो इस तरीके से
ये पूरा एडीआर काम करता है। अब यहां पे
मैं आपको जो बता रहा था यहां पे इसके अंदर
में ये सेम चीज आपको बता रहा था
थ्योरेटिकली जब मैंने अभी पॉइंट वाइज
थोड़ा आपको समझाया तो आपको शायद ये चीज
पॉइंट जो है वो समझ में आ गई होगी। राइट
ये वाली पॉइंट कि ये क्या करता है कि
एनडिआयआर ऑपरेट्स ऑन अ सिंपल हवेन स्पोक
मॉडल लाइट एजेंट्स सीट डायरेक्टली ऑन एंड
पॉइंट्स। एंड पॉइंट्स पे बैठे रहते हैं।
एंड स्ट्रीम टेलीमेट्री बैक टू अ
सेंट्रलाइज़्ड क्लाउड इंजन फॉर हैवी ड्यूटी
एनालिसिस। तो वो क्लाउड इंजन जो कह रहा है
ये ये उसी ईडीआर कंसोल एक तरह से उसकी बात
कर रहा है। मतलब वो ईडीआर कंसोल कहीं भी
हो सकती है। क्लाउड में हो सकती है। ऐसे
किसी मशीन पे हो सकती है। कहीं ना कहीं वो
रखा हुआ है। तो इडी तो ये अब एक चीज इसमें
और है। इस पूरे जो ये लाइन मैंने आपको
बताया इस लाइन में ऐसी कोई वर्ड है जो
आपको नहीं समझ में आपको लग रहा हो कि ये
नया कुछ वर्ड है? बताइए आप में से कोई भी
ऐसा बताइए। इस पूरे लाइन में अभी जो मैंने
ये पूरा बताया ये वाली लाइन। इसमें से कोई
ऐसा वर्ड है जो आपको समझ में ऐसा लगा हो
कि ये थोड़ा नया वर्ड है या समझ नहीं आया।
सो बताइए या वेलकम विपिन
देखते हैं किसको कौन सा वर्ड किसी को वर्ड
कोई दिख रहा है कि नहीं वो वाला
या एक बंदे ने तो पकड़ लिया वर्ड
टेलीमेट्री एक बंदे ने टेलीमेट्री वर्ड
पकड़ा है। एंड दिस इज एन राइट। यह वर्ड जो
है टेलीमेट्री यह नया वर्ड है। एंड एवरीवन
शुड इंक्वायर एवरीवन शुड आस्क कि सर ये
क्या है टेलीमेट्री? बट आप में से कोई
पूछता नहीं है तो मैं खुद ही बता देता
हूं। राइट? वैसे तो आपको पूछना चाहिए। बट
अगर नहीं कोई पूछ रहा है तो मैं खुद आपसे
पूछ के आप ही को बता देता हूं। टेलीमेट्री
सिंपल सा है। टेलीमेट्री का मतलब डेटा है।
जो डेटा वो कलेक्ट कर रहा है। इंफॉर्मेशन
जो वो कलेक्ट कर रहा है। जो डेटा वो
कलेक्ट करके भेज रहा है एडीआर कंसोल को
उसी को टेलीमेट्री बोलते हैं। बस इतना ही
समझ जाओ। वो डेटा को ही टेलीमेट्री बोलते
हैं। वो जो पॉइंट्स हैं जो चीजें हैं वो
टेलीमेट्री है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे कुछ
एडीआर सॉलशंस है जो मार्केट में
एंटरप्राइज लेवल पर काम में लिए जाते हैं।
आप जब भी कोई बड़ी कंपनी में किसी भी बड़ी
कोई ऑब्वियस सी बात है एसओसी एल1 पोजीशन
पे जब आप जाएंगे एसओसी रोल के लिए तो एक
बड़ी कंपनी ही होगी जिसमें कि ईडीआर का
यूज़ जरूर हो रहा होगा बिना उसके तो क्या
ही होगा वो तो उस कंपनी में जब आप जाएंगे
तो इडीआर सॉलशंस यूज़ किए जाते हैं। एंड
उन एडीआर सॉल्यूशन में कुछ प्रॉमिनेंट कुछ
पॉपुलर एडीआर सॉलशंस हैं जो कंपनीज़ ऑफर
करती हैं। जैसे एक क्राउड स्ट्राइक का आता
है फेलकन। क्राउड स्ट्राइक का फेल्कन। ये
काफी ज्यादा कंपनीज़ यूज़ करती हैं। मोस्ट
पॉपुलर वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट पॉपुलर ईडीआर सिस्टम
है ये। एक आता है Sinil वन एक्टिव एडीआर।
आपका सेंटिनल जो है वो बेसिकली Microsoft
का ही है। Microsoft डिफेंडर फॉर एंड
पॉइंट। यह भी एक आता है। ओपन एडीआर भी एक
आती है। एक सिमेंटिक एडीआर भी आता है। तो
ये सारे एडीआर्स हैं जो काफी ज्यादा
पॉपुलर है। इसमें सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर
सेंटिनल और क्राउड स्ट्राइक का फाल्कन है
जो काफी ज्यादा यूज़ होता है। क्राउड
स्ट्राइक फाल्कन जो है वो तो खैर कुछ
ज्यादा ही यूज़ होता है। सो आपको जो है मैं
आपको आगे जो चीज कुछ एक ओवरव्यू दूंगा
एडीआर का वो क्राउड स्ट्राइक फाल्कन का ही
आपको प्रोवाइड होगा करूंगा। एंड यू विल बी
सरप्राइज्ड कि कितना इंटरेस्टिंग होता है
ये सॉफ्टवेयर। ऊपर से दूसरी चीज कि अगर
आपको क्राउड स्ट्राइक फाल्कन यूज करना है,
ट्राई करना है तो आप उसका 15 दिन का
ट्रायल आता है। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट यूज़
कर सकते हैं क्योंकि खरीद तो आप वैसे भी
नहीं पाएंगे इंडिविजुअली क्योंकि वो
एंटरप्राइज लेवल पे उनकी कॉस्टिंग काफी
होती है। तो आप 15 दिन के ट्रायल पे आराम
से यूज़ कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? सेवरल अदर
इडिया सलूशंस आर अवेलेबल इन द मार्केट। दे
आर अंडरलाइन आर्किटेक्चर इज़ मोस्टली
सिमिलर। मतलब एक आर्किटेक्चर जो है वह
ऑलमोस्ट सेम होता है। बट फीचर्स जो है वह
थोड़े डिफरेंट हो सकते हैं। सो बेसिकली
ईडीआर का मतलब समझिए कि जैसे आप एंटीवायरस
सॉफ्टवेयर जैसे चलाते हैं ना आप Microsoft
डिफेंडर चलाते हैं CSpus sky चलाते हैं।
राइट नॉटन चलाते हैं तो उसी तरीके से ये
ईडीआर सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोवाइडर कंपनीज़ हैं।
क्राउड स्ट्राइक Microsoft sattic यह सब
प्रोवाइड करते हैं। ठीक है? गॉट इट।
भाई मैंने फर्स्ट टाइम आपका लाइव ज्वाइन
करा है बट मैंने आपका हर वीडियो देखा है।
थैंक यू। यू आर वेलकम ग्लैड। चलिए तो ये
आपकी एंड पॉइंट की कहानी है। ये एंड पॉइंट
होता है। अब एंड पॉइंट में कुछ चीजें होती
हैं। उस पे हम डिस्कस करेंगे। तीन तीन
इसके कोर फीचर्स होते हैं। उस पे हम
डिस्कस करेंगे। एक आपका विजिबिलिटी, एक
आपका डिटेक्शन और एक आपका रिस्पांस। ये
तीन फीचर्स होते हैं। ठीक है? इन पे हम
बातें करेंगे। देखो एंड पॉइंट जो है तीन
तरह के काम करता है। विजिबिलिटी, डिटेक्शन
एंड रिस्पांस। तीनों इसका काम है।
विजिबिलिटी का मतलब होता है रिकॉर्ड्स अ
पीडीएफ ओपनिंग एंड लॉन्चिंग अ हिडन
बैकग्राउंड स्क्रिप्ट। ठीक है? रिकॉर्ड्स
अ पीडीएफ ओपनिंग एंड लॉन्चिंग अ हिडन
बैकग्राउंड स्क्रिप्ट। मतलब ये क्या करता
है? एक मान लो कोई पीडीएफ है। पीडीएफ आपने
ओपन किया। ठीक है? नॉर्मली आपने कोई
पीडीएफ ओपन किया। अब जैसे ही ओपन किया यह
ल्च हुआ और बैकग्राउंड में कोई चीज चल गई
मलेशियस तो यह हर उस पर्टिकुलर इवेंट को
रिकॉर्ड करता है। दिखाता है आपको कि एक
पीडीएफ जो है वो एग्जीक्यूट हुई है।
एग्जीक्यूट होने के बाद वो लॉन्च हो गई
है। उसने अगर कोई सब प्रोसेस चालू किया है
वो बताएगा। कोई बैकग्राउंड में कोई
स्क्रिप्ट चालू की है या कोई फाइल ओपन की
है वो बताएगा। ये विज़िबिलिटी होती है।
उसके बाद होता है डिटेक्शन। एनालाइज़ज़ द
स्क्रिप्ट बिहेवियर। बैकग्राउंड में कोई
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट स्टार्ट हुई है। जब
पीडीएफ आपने चलाया तो बैकग्राउंड में कोई
एक स्क्रिप्ट भी चल गई है पीडीएफ के
साथ-साथ। हो सकता है मलेशियस हो। उस
स्क्रिप्ट के बिहेवियर को एनालाइज़ करता
है। रिकॉग्नाइज़ इट एज अ क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट
फायर्स एंड अलर्ट। एंड जैसे ही वह उसको
बिहेवियर स्क्रिप्ट के बिहेवियर को
एनालाइज करता है, उसको लगता है कि अरे यार
यह तो कुछ मलिशियस है, कुछ खतरनाक है,
डेंजरस है। वैसे ही यह समझ जाता है कि यह
एक अटैक है। यह एक थ्रेट है। मान लो कि
क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट के लिए हो। एंड उसके बाद
यह एक अलर्ट को फायर करता है। एक अलर्ट
देता है। अलर्ट किसको देता है भैया? यह
इडीआर कंसोल को भेज देता है। रिस्पांस में
क्या होता है भैया? आइसोलेट द लैपटॉप
फ्रॉम द नेटवर्क एंड किल्स द स्क्रिप्ट
ऑटोमेटिकली। अब ईडीआर जो है वह रिस्पांस
में क्या करती है? एडीआर एज अ रिस्पॉनडेंट
कैसे करती है कि वो उस लैपटॉप को ही
नेटवर्क से आइसोलेट कर देती है और उस
स्क्रिप्ट को डिलीट कर देती है, किल कर
देती है। उसका एग्जीक्यूशन खत्म कर देती
है। वह एग्जीक्यूशन उसका बंद हो जाता है।
खत्म। दैट्स इट। यह आपका होता है इडीआर का
काम। एंटीवायरस जो है वो इस तरीके से काम
नहीं करती है। एंटीवायरस आपके लैपटॉप में
जब होती है तो आपके लैपटॉप को किसी
नेटवर्क से नहीं डिटच कर देती है। आपके
लैपटॉप के ऊपर बस वो परफॉर्म करती है। वो
भी एंटीवायरसेस एकदम से 24 * 7 मॉनिटरिंग
नहीं करते हैं। पहली बात एंड जब वो आप
किसी चीज को स्कैन करते हो या वो कभी चीज
को बिहेवियरल लाइक स्कैन अगर कोई किसी तरह
का कोई सिग्नेचर बेस्ड स्कैन करता है एंड
उसको जब मिलता है तो वो उसको क्वारेंटाइन
करता है या डिलीट आप कर सकते हो। तो उस
लैपटॉप से आप हटा सकते हो। वापस से वो
थ्रेट आपके पास आ जाएगा। वो कोई लैपटॉप को
नेटवर्क से डिटचै ही नहीं करता है। बट
ईडीआर क्या करता है कि इस इट हैज़ द पावर
टू आइसोलेट द लैपटॉप फ्रॉम द नेटवर्क एंड
अदर डिवाइसेस ताकि ये दूसरे डिवाइसेस और
नेटवर्क के अदर जो आपके एंड पॉइंट
डिवाइसेस हैं उसको वो पर्टिकुलर अटैक या
थ्रेड जो है वो इंपैक्ट ना कर सके और बाकी
चीज़ आपकी सेफ रहे। दैट्स इट। समझ में आ
गया?
ओके।
करेक्ट। सो ईडीआर इज द जस्ट एन एंटीवायरस
बट मोर एडवांस वर्जन एंड कैपेबल ऑफ़ डूइंग
अ लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स। हां, यू कैन से इट। यू
कैन से इट कि ईडीआर एक हाइली एडवांस्ड
एंटीवायरस है। आप ऐसा बोल सकते हो जिसमें
एंटीवायरसेस से कई गुना ज्यादा फीचर्स
होते हैं। कई ज्यादा गुना ज्यादा
फंक्शनैलिटीज होती हैं। और वो एक
छोटी-मोटी कंपनीज़ या एक होम नेटवर्क में
यूज़ नहीं होता। एक एंटप्राइज नेटवर्क में
एक बड़ी कंपनी के अंदर में जहां पे एक
पूरा नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है उस कंपनी
का। बहुत सारे नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस एक साथ
यूज़ हो रहे हैं। बहुत बड़ी नेटवर्किंग
यूज़ हो रही है। उसके अंदर में उन
डिवाइसेस को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए यूज़
में लिया जाता है। एडवांस थ्रेट्स को।
बेसिकली आप ऐसा बोल सकते हैं कि
एंटीवायरसेस थ्रेट्स को डिटेक्ट करने के
लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है और इडीआर्स
एडवांस थ्रेट्स को
डिटेक्ट करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। जहां पे मशीन लर्निंग के एल्गोरिदम्स
का यूज़ किया जाता है ताकि थ्रेट्स को उनके
पैटर्न्स को उनके इनफेक्ट करने से पहले ही
डिटेक्ट किया जा सके और उसको टर्मिनेट या
एलिमिनेट किया जा सके। यह इसका काम होता
है। राइट?
करेक्ट लाइक एपीटी यू कैन से
हां एडीआर बड़ी कंपनी का एंटीवायरस है।
बिल्कुल सही बोला। एडीआर बड़ी कंपनी का
एंटीवायरस है। एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। अब इस
विजिबिलिटी वाली चीज को हम थोड़ा सा डिटेल
में ट्राईकमी के इस वाले पार्ट से
समझेंगे। एडीआर वाले पार्ट से यहां पे। तो
ये तीन चीजें जो होती हैं विजिबिलिटी
डिटेक्शन रिस्पांस। ये तीन तरह के इसके
कोर फीचर्स हैं आपके एडीआर के। अब यहां पे
अगर मैं विजिबिलिटी की बात करूं थोड़ा डीप
एक्सप्लेनेशन कर रहा हूं। वैसे मैंने आपको
मोटा-मोटी इजी वे में सब बता दिया। मैंने
आपको कंसेप्चुअल बता दिया। आपको उतना
नॉलेज है आप मोर दैन इनफ है। बट स्टिल
थोड़ा सा डिटेल में जाते हैं। अ गुड
एनालिसिस ऑफेन डिपेंड्स ऑन द अवेलेबल लेवल
ऑफ़ विज़िबिलिटी विज़िबिलिटी ऑफ़ द एक्टिविटी।
ठीक है? सही बात है। दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द फीचर
ऑफ़ ईडीआर दैट मेक्स इट यूनिक फ्रॉम अदर
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन। द लेवल ऑफ़
विज़िबिलिटी ईडीआर प्रोवाइड्स इज़
इंप्रेसिव। इडीआर एक अलग ही लेवल का
विज़िबिलिटी प्रोवाइड करता है जो आपको
एंटीवायरस कभी भी प्रोवाइड नहीं करता है।
इट कलेक्ट्स डिटेल डेटा फ्रॉम एंड
पॉइंट्स। जैसा मैंने पहले बताया कि एंड
पॉइंट से डिटेल डेटा जो है वो इडीआर
कलेक्ट करती है। कौन करता है उसके थ्रू?
ईडीआर एजेंट्स के थ्रू वो कलेक्ट होता है।
व्हिच इंक्लूड्स प्रोसेस मॉडिफिकेशन,
रजिस्ट्री मॉडिफिकेशंस, फाइल एंड फोल्डर
मॉडिफिकेशंस, यूजर एक्शंस एंड बिहेवियर्स
एंड मच मोर। तो ईडीआर किस तरह के डेटा को
कलेक्ट करती है ये भी बात है। तो अगर किसी
तरह के मॉड प्रोसेस जो प्रोसेससेस चल रहे
हैं आपके सिस्टम में अलग-अलग प्रोसेस चल
रहा है। उसमें किसी तरह का मॉडिफिकेशन यह
नोटिस करता है। या कोई रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
कोई एंट्री हुई रहती है जो डिफ़ॉल्ट
एंट्रीज है। उसमें कोई मॉडिफिकेशन यह
नोटिस करता है या अनअथराइज़्ड मॉडिफिकेशन
ये सेंस करेगा। अगर किसी फाइल या फोल्डर
में कोई मॉडिफिकेशन उनके किसी पर उसे उनके
परमिशन में किसी तरह का मॉडिफिकेशन इसको
सेंस होता है। यूज़र्स के एक्शन में यूजर
किस तरीके से बिहेव कर रहा है? नॉर्मली
यूजर कैसे बिहेव करता था? अभी कैसे बिहेव
कर रहा है? अब मान लो नॉर्मली यूजर इस
पर्टिकुलर एक पर्टिकुलर फोल्डर को ओपन
करता है। उसमें अपना काम करता चला जाता
है। छोड़ दे। अब वही यूजर जो है उस फोल्डर
की परमिशन को चेंज करने की कोशिश कर रहा
है। वो यूजर भी सस्िशियस कैटेगरी में आ
जाएगा। तो यूजर का बिहेवियर, यूजर का
एक्शन ये सब कुछ ट्रैक करता है आपका
इडीआर। इट देन प्रेजेंट्स दिस इंफॉर्मेशन
इन अ वेरी स्ट्रक्चरर्ड फॉर्मेट टू द
एनालिस्ट। अब यही इंफॉर्मेशन इसको एक
स्ट्रक्चर फॉर्मेट में जो एसओसी एनालिस्ट
होते हैं उनको यह प्रेजेंट करता है। बोलता
है कि भैया ये लो हमने पूरा एक डिटेल
ब्यरा बनाया हुआ है। आप इसको जो है वो
देखो। द एनालिस्ट कैन सी द होल प्रोसेस
ट्री विद अ कंप्लीट एक्टिविटी टाइमलाइन ऑफ
द सीक्वेंस ऑफ द एक्शन और यह जो पर्टिकुलर
आपको स्ट्रक्चर होता है यह एक प्रोसेस
ट्री के थ्रू बताया जाता है एनालिस्ट को
प्रोसेस ट्री प्रोसेस ट्री का मतलब यहां
पे आप सबको शायद पता होगा प्रोसेस ट्री
कैसे होता है जैसे एक एक्शन इस तरीके से
कुछ ऐसे होती है ना प्रोसेस ट्री मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं
कुछ इस तरीके से राइट जैसे एक एक चीज से
दूसरी चीज निकली उससे तीसरी चीज निकली
उससे चौथा चीज उससे पांचवा चीज कनेक्टेड
है तो मतलब एक दूसरे से कनेक्टेड जो तरीके
जो चीजें होती हैं उसको हम प्रोसेस टी के
थ्रू वो नोटेशन होता है आपका ठीक है तो
प्रोसेस टी के थ्रू बताता है अब द
एनालिस्ट कैन आल्सो एक्सेस द हिस्टोरिकल
डाटा ऑफ एनी एंड पॉइंट फॉर थ्रेट हंटिंग
और एनी अदर पर्संस तो अब जो एनालिस्ट है
वो ईडीआर से हिस्टोरिकल डाटा भी ले सकता
है पहले के डाटा थ्रेट हंटिंग करने के
लिए। तो थ्रेट हंटिंग के बारे में आप बारे
में आप लोगों ने कई कई बार सुना भी होगा।
आप लोगों में से कई लोग थ्रेट हंटिंग का
नाम सुनते होंगे कि यार यार थ्रेट हंटिंग
नाम की भी एक पोजीशन होती है। एक जॉब रोल
होता है। तो थ्रेट हंटिंग में बेसिकली
क्या होता है? जैसे ऑलरेडी कोई एंड पॉइंट
को इन इनफेक्ट कर दिया। किसी थ्रेट ने
इनफेक्ट करके रखा हुआ है और उसको अब जो एक
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट है वो उसको खोज रहा
है। अलग-अलग तरीके से हिस्टोरिकल डाटा
निकाला, लॉग्स निकाला, ढूंढ रहा है कि
कहां है, कहां हो सकता है, क्या हो सकता
है। उसको हंट करता है। उसको इलिमिनेट करता
है उस सिस्टम सेम। उसी को थ्रेट हंटिंग
बोलते हैं। और कुछ भी नहीं होता थ्रेड
हंटिंग। ठीक है?
तो क्या होता है? ये सारी चीजें प्रोसेस
मॉडिफिकेशन, रजिस्ट्री मॉडिफिकेशन, फाइल
एंड फोल्डर मॉडिफिकेशन, यूजर एक्शन इन
सबको ये क्या करता है? मॉनिटर करता है। अब
देखो अब यह सामने नीचे जो स्क्रीन है यह
एक प्रोसेस ट्री को रिप्रेजेंट करता है।
जो सामने आपको फोटो दिख रही है एंड आपको
ये बताता है हर एक नोड जो है वो प्रोसेस
ट्री को डिनोट करता है यहां पे। एंड जो
लाइंस आपकी हैं ये जो लाइंस हैं ये उनके
बीच का रिलेशनशिप बताता है। तो अब देखो तो
ये एक एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन एक
सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर का ये प्रोसेस ट्री है।
इस तरीके से जैसे टॉरex ये प्रोसेस है
आपका। ठीक है? एक प्रोसेस है। अब ये जो
प्लस साइन होती है इंडिया सॉफ्टवेयर के
अंदर में इस पे क्लिक करने पे इसके बारे
में आपको सारा डिटेल मिलेगा। हां बहुत सर
कि ये बेसिकली ये डिटेल किस तरीके से
डिटेल आपको मिलेंगे लाइक कि एग्जैक्टली
इसने क्या-क्या एक्शन किया, क्या-क्या
चीजें करी हैं, किस तरीके की परमिशंस या
किस तरीके की मॉडिफिकेशन या किस तरीके की
चीज़ सब कुछ आपको यहां पे मिलेगा। तो Tor
जो है इस प्रोसेस से एक जो प्रोसेस स्पॉन
हुआ है वो क्या है? वो स्पॉन प्रोसेस है
ra.exc ये एक प्रोसेस स्पॉन हुआ है। उसी
तरीके से tor.exc है। इससे दो प्रोसेस
स्पॉन हुए हैं। एक sy.exc एक net.exec अब
swy.exc ने cmd.exc को स्पॉन किया। स्पॉन
का मतलब सिंपल आप मानिए कि उसको लॉन्च
किया है। एक प्रोसेस से दूसरा प्रोसेस को
लॉन्च करना। तो अब texc है। इसने sy.exc
एक फाइल को इस अहम एक प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट
किया। उसने cmd.exec को करा और cmd.exec
ने sc.exee नाम के एक प्रोसेस को मतलब एक
सॉफ्ट एक प्रोग्राम को स्टार्ट कर दिया।
उसी तरीके से net.exe स्टार्ट हुआ टॉर से
ही और उसने एक netwन.exc को भी स्टार्ट कर
दिया। तो इस तरीके से एक प्रोसेस दूसरे
प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट कर रहा है। मतलब इसका
मतलब सिंपल है। जैसा इसका ऐसे एग्जांपल
समझ लीजिए कि जैसे आपने एक वर्ड की फाइल
कहीं से
डाउनलोड की है। डॉटdoc याdocx फाइल जो
होती है। वर्ड की फाइल डाउनलोड की। आपने
उसको डबल क्लिक किया। एग्जीक्यूट किया।
अभी जैसे ही एग्जीक्यूट किया एक माइक्रो
एग्जीक्यूशन हुआ मतलब जो माइक्रो
वनेबिलिटी वर्ड के थ्रू आती है एंड वहां
पे वेबीएस एक स्क्रिप्ट चली और उसके थ्रू
क्या हुआ एक पावर शेल जो है वो ओपन हो
जाता है बैकग्राउंड पे पावर शेल विंडो ओपन
हो जाती है तो अब वहां पे एक वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट ने एक पावर शेल को स्टार्ट कर
दिया यानी एक वर्ड डॉट विनर्ड exc का
प्रोसेस जो था उसने पावर शेल पीएस जो एक
प्रोसेस है उसको स्टार्ट कर दिया तो एक
प्रोसेस ने दूसरे को स्टार्ट किया यही चीज
होती है एक प्रोसेस से दूसरे प्रोसेस को
लिंक करना उसी को हम प्रोसेस ट्री बोलते
हैं। वो ट्री के फॉर्म में होता है कि एक
प्रोसेस दूसरा लिंक अप दिखेगा तो बहुत ईजी
टू अंडरस्टैंड हो जाता है कि इस की बटन अब
देखो किसी कोई पूछेगा कोई पूछेगा कि scac
को किसने स्टार्ट किया? तो cmd.exe ने
स्टार्ट किया। cmd.exc के कारण ये स्टार्ट
हुआ है। इसने किया। बस दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
ये चीज होती है। अब देखिए
ओके।
अब इसमें आपने ये तो विज़िबिलिटी देख ली।
अब इसमें आते हैं डिटेक्शन। विज़िबिलिटी के
बाद आते हैं डिटेक्शन वाला। द डिटेक्शन
फीचर ऑफ़ इडिया विंस ओवर ट्रेडिशनल
डिटेक्शन कैपेबिलिटीज़। इट इनकरपोरेट्स
सिग्नेचर बेस्ड डिटेक्शन एज़ वेल ऐज़
बिहेवियर बेस्ड डिटेक्शंस। सो
देखो नॉर्मल एंटीवायरसेस में
बेसिकली सिग्नेचर बेस्ड डिटेक्शंस होते
हैं। ठीक है? नॉर्मली जो भी एंटीवायरस
हैं। हालांकि आजकल के जो एंटीवायरसेस हैं
वो काफी एडवांस्ड हो चुके हैं। काफी काफी
एडवांस हो चुके हैं। बट स्टिल जो ईडीआर है
वो उससे आगे है। और जनरली सिग्नेचर बेस्ड
डिटेक्शंस होते हैं। बट इडीआर जो है उनमें
सिग्नेचर बेस्ड डिटेक्शंस के साथ-साथ
बिहेवियर जो बेस्ड डिटेक्शन है, बिहेवल
डिटेक्शंस वो भी है। एक तरह का
ह्यूरिस्टिक डिटेक्शंस होता है। तो
सिग्नेचर बेस्ड और बिहेवियर बेस्ड दोनों
ही डिटेक्शंस होते हैं ईडीआर की तरफ से।
ठीक है? यह दोनों में डिफरेंस है। सच एज
अनएक्सेक्टेड यूजर एक्टिविटी। कोई
अनएक्सेक्टेड यूजर एक्टिविटी है वो भी
डिटेक्ट होता है। एंटीवायरस में ऐसा नहीं
होगा। अब जैसे मान लो लेट्स सपोज कि मैं
एक यूजर हूं। ठीक है? मैं लाइव एग्जांपल
आपको लाइव एक बताता हूं आपको। मैं एक एक
यूजर हूं। ठीक है? अब मैं मैंने दिस पीसी
ओपन कर लिया। ठीक है? हां। बिहेवियरल का
मतलब यहां पे जब बिहेवियरल होगा तो वो
मशीन लर्निंग के थ्रू होता है। एडीआर के
अंदर में मशीन लर्निंग एल्गोरििदम का यूज़
में लिया जाता है। अब मैं यहां पे हूं। अब
मैं यहां पे सी ड्राइव ये ड्राइव है। मैं
इस पे राइट क्लिक करता हूं। अब मैं इस पे
प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाता हूं। ठीक है?
प्रॉपर्टीज पे गया और यहां पे मैं मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं? सिक्योरिटी में जाता
हूं। और यहां पे इसके परमिशंस आपको दिख
रहे होंगे। राइट? तो टू टू चेंज परमिशन।
यहां पे एडिट का ऑप्शन है। इसको अगर
परमिशन आपको चेंज करनी है तो आप एडिट कर
सकते हो। एडिट करके आप यहां से परमिशंस जो
हैं सबके परमिशंस अलग-अलग जो भी ग्रुप्स
या यूज़र्स हैं उनके अगेंस्ट आप परमिशंस को
चेंज कर सकते हो। राइट? आप इसमें से चेंज
कर दोगे, अप्लाई करोगे एंड आप बाहर आ
जाओगे। राइट? अब इतना जो आपने काम किया एक
नॉर्मल यूजर के तौर पे आपने मान लो
Windows मशीन पे काम कर लिया। राइट? ये
एंटीवायरस डिटेक्ट नहीं करता। एंटीवायरस
इज़ नेवर गोइंग टू डिटेक्ट इट। एंटीवायरस
को लगेगा ये क्या है? यूजर है भाई अपना
काम कर रहा है। करने दो क्या दिक्कत है?
बट ईडीआर विल फ्लैग इट। ईडीआर विल थ्रो
अलर्ट। वो एक अलर्ट थ्रो कर देगा इसी चीज
के लिए। अगर आप यह काम जनरली नहीं करते हो
यू आर नॉट ऑथराइज्ड। एंड अगर आप यह काम
करने लग रहे हो तो ईडीआर को यहां पे डाउट
होगा। एंड ईडीआर जो है वो अलर्ट थ्रो
करेगा कि भैया यहां कुछ तो गड़बड़ है इस
यूजर के साथ। यह इसकी परमिशन चेंज करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है इस सी ड्राइव की। जनरली
यह करता ही नहीं है। अभी क्यों कर रहा है?
तो एल अब उसके बाद होगी इन्वेस्टिगेशन जो
कि एसओसी एनालिस्ट जो है वह करेंगे इसकी
इन्वेस्टिगेशन।
यह पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस होता है। समझ में
आ गया? ये आपकी ये आपको समझ में आ रही है?
आपको गाइज़ समझ में तो आ रहा है ना? ऐसा तो
नहीं कि मैं बोलता जा रहा हूं। आप सुनते
जा रहे हो। समझ में आ नहीं रहा हो। कुछ भी
हो रहा है। सो मुझे एक बार कंफर्म करो यार
थोड़ा। अभी तक जितनी भी चीजें बताई है
मैंने स्टार्टिंग से। समझ आ रहा है आपको?
एक्सैक्टली हो क्या रहा है ये सारी चीजें?
देखो यार ऐसे क्वेश्चन का आंसर मैं नहीं
करूंगा। व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन थ्रेट
हंटर एंड बग हंटर? Google कर लो यार। चैट
डीपीटी कर लो। तुरंत मिल जाएगी। दोनों अलग
चीज़ हैं। हां। थ्रेट हंटर्स आर डिफरेंट।
बग हंटर्स आर डिफरेंट। थ्रेट हंटर्स जो
थ्रेट ऑलरेडी इनफेक्ट कर चुके हैं सिस्टम
को उसको हंट करते हैं। बग हंटर्स
वनेबिलिटी पॉसिबल जो वनेबिलिटीज हैं
जिन्होंने सिस्टम को अभी तक इंपैक्ट नहीं
किया हो शायद उनको फाइंड करते हैं। बग
बंटी तो खैर अलग ही है। पेटेस्टिंग पूछते
तो फिर भी मैं कुछ बताता। बग बंटी में तो
फिर आप
रिवॉर्ड स्वैग्स एंड उसके लिए करते हो।
बग्स ढूंढते हो। ठीक है? क्लियर है।
ओके। ठीक है। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
सॉरी संदेश गेमिंग मैं अभी आपको बग बंटी
से रिलेटेड कोई हेल्प नहीं कर सकता
क्योंकि अभी एसओसी की क्लासेस चल रही हैं।
राइट बग बंटी की क्लासेस जब स्टार्ट जल्दी
होंगी फिर अपन करेंगे।
प्लीज डोंट रिपीट सेंड रिपीटेड मैसेज।
ठीक है
ओके
सर ईडीआर ऑटोमेटिकली अलर्ट रिस्पांस भी
करता है क्या मैनुअल होता है एक्शन हां
ईडीआर में ऑटोमेटिकली मैनुअली सब होता है
ईडीआर ऑटोमेटिकली रिसोंड भी करता है जी
हां ईडीआर जो है वो थ्रेट्स को रिसोंड भी
करता है। अब आपके मन में यह सवाल हो सकता
है कि सर जब ईडीआर ही रिसोंड कर देती है
तो यह एसआईएम और एसओसी
मतलब एसओसी टीम की क्या जरूरत है? जब
ईडीआर ऑटोमेटिक रेस्पोंड ही कर देती है
थ्रेट्स को। ये मन में सवाल आएगा ना। आप
लोगों के मन में आना चाहिए। नहीं आ रहा है
तो आपके मन में आना चाहिए ऐसे क्वेश्चंस
क्योंकि तभी आपको तभी लगेगा कि यू आर वेरी
एक्साइटेड अबाउट थिंग्स एंड आपके दिमाग
में कुछ ना कुछ चलता रहता है। ईडीआर
ऑटोमेटिकली रेस्पोंड करती है थ्रेट को।
अपने अकॉर्डिंग तो रेस्पोंड भी मार देती
है। सोचो उसको हटा भी देती है। डिलीट उसको
सिस्टम से उसको नेटवर्क से बाहर निकाल के
फेंक देती है। जैसे एंटीवायरस होता है ना
डिलीट मार देता है। क्वारेंटाइन कर देता
है। वैसे ही इडीआर भी करता है। तो सोचो जब
फिर एसओसी के अह की जरूरत क्यों होती है?
एसओसी की जरूरत क्यों होती है? ऑटोमेटिकली
जब हो ही जाता है तो ये क्वेश्चन होना
चाहिए। राइट? वो मैं बताऊंगा कि क्यों
जरूरत होती है। क्या एग्जैक्टली क्या होता
है।
ठीक है सर। कितने परसेंटेज ऑफ़ सिलेबस खत्म
हुआ है अब तक? अभी तक आपका सिलेबस जो है
वो
75% कंप्लीट हो चुकी है। 25% बची हुई है।
कंफर्मेशन के लिए नहीं कंफर्मेशन की बात
नहीं है यहां पे। बात कुछ और है। अभी हम
जानेंगे उसके बारे में। अब डिटेक्शन में
और हम आगे की तरफ पढ़ते हैं। विथ मॉडर्न
मशीन लर्निंग कैपेबिलिटीज़ इट आइडेंटिफाईज़
एनी डेविएशन फ्रॉम द बेसलाइन बिहेवियर एंड
इंस्टेंटली फ्लैग इज़। मतलब बेसलाइन अगर
कोई यूजर का एक बेसलाइन बिहेवियर है कि ये
इस तरीके का बिहेवियर ही करता है। उससे
थोड़ा भी डेविएटेड बिहेवियर लगा तो तुरंत
उसको फ्लैग करेगा और अलर्ट देगा।
इट कैन आल्सो डिटेक्ट फाइललेस मैलवेयर दैट
रिसाइड्स इन मेमोरी। इट इज़ इट आल्सो अलाउ
अस टू फीड कस्टम आईओसीज़ फॉर थ्रेड
डिटेक्शन। तो इडीआर्स जो है वो फाइललिस
मैलवेस जिसके बारे में आपने पिछले क्लासेस
में बहुत
काफी दिन हो गए फाइलिलेस मैलवेयर के बारे
में मैंने बताया था वो आपने पढ़ा होगा जो
मेमोरी में जो मैलवेयर्स अपने आप को
मेमोरी के अंदर एग्जीक्यूट कर लेते हैं।
कहीं और स्टोर करके नहीं रखते हैं। मेमोरी
के अंदर एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। मेमोरी के
अंदर उसे वो ऑपरेट करते हैं। वैसे मालवेस
को भी ये डिटेक्ट करता है। साथ ही में आप
एडीएस को कस्टम आईओसीस जो है वो प्रोवाइड
कर सकते हो। जैसे इंडिकेटर ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज जो होते हैं इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज मतलब कौन ऐसे-ऐसे इंडिकेटर्स
जिससे कि एक सिस्टम कॉम्प्रोमाइज होने का
आईडिया हमें मिलता है कि भैया ये अगर
इंडिकेटर होगा तो समझो कि ये चीज
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुई है। इस लेवल की
कॉम्प्रोमाइजेशन हुई तो आप कस्टम लिस्ट
प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो जिससे कि वो उसके
थ्रू क्या होगा? थ्रेट्स को डिटेक्ट
करेगा। आप अपना खुद का एक लिस्ट तैयार
कीजिए। एक आईओसी आईओसी बनाइए। इंडिकेटर्स
ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज एंड उसको फीड कर दीजिए कि
भैया इस तरीके का अगर कुछ हो तो ऐसा ऐसा
हो तो ऐसा ऐसा हो तो ऐसा इस तरीके से
कंडीशन बेस्ड जो आईओसीस है वो आप प्रोवाइड
कर सकते हैं। उस पे ये काम करता है। अब
देखो द फॉलोइंग स्क्रीनशॉट शोज़ अ डैशबोर्ड
ऑफ़ ऑल डिटेक्शंस हैपनिंग ऑन डिफरेंट एंड
पॉइंट्स। एक नीचे आपको स्क्रीनशॉट दिखेगा
जो कि आपको क्या दिखाएगा? जितने भी
डिटेक्शन जो है हो रहे हैं सारे एंड
पॉइंट्स पे वो आपको दिखाएगा। ईच डिटेक्शन
इज रिप्रेजेंटेड बाय अ रो विद डिफरेंट
फील्ड्स। हर एक डिटेक्शन एक रो से दिखाया
जा रहा है जिसमें अलग-अलग फील्ड्स हैं।
कैसे-कैसे फील्ड्स हैं? सीवियरिटी ऑफ़
डिटेक्शन। डिटेक्शन का सीिवियरिटी क्या
है? टाइम क्या है? फाइल जो ट्रिगर हुई है
वो होस्ट नेम, यूजरनेम एंड बहुत सारी
चीजें होती है। ठीक है? द टैक्टिक वाया
टेक्निक फील्ड मैप्स द डिटेक्शन विद
मथ्रे। तो यहां पे एक फील्ड और आपको
दिखेगा टैक्टिक वायर टेक्निक। तो टैक्टिक
वाया टेक्निक जो है यह बेसिकली क्या करते
हैं कि यह
m्रे को जो फॉलो करते हो m्रे फ्रेमवर्क
को फॉलो करते हुए जो डिटेक्शंस होती हैं
उनको यह दिखाता है तो m्रे भी एक तरह एक
सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क है जिसको फॉलो करते
जैसे आप देखो जैसे एनआईएसटी है आपका जैसे
ओवसप है राइट वेब सिक्योरिटी वलेबिलिटीज
के लिए एक फ्रेमवर्क है बना हुआ ओस्प
मोबाइल सिक्योरिटी के लिए ओsp का ही
मोबाइल ओएस मोबाइल बना बना हुआ है। तो
वैसे ही यह एक मत्री फ्रेमवर्क भी होते
हैं जो कि सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क होता है।
एक एनआईएसटी नेस्ट फ्रेमवर्क भी होता है।
सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क होता है। तो उसमें
मत्री जो है सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क में
जैसे ओएस में कैसे टॉप 10 होते हैं?
अलग-अलग वलेबिलिटीज़ को क्लासिफाई किया गया
है। उनकी सीवियरिटी डिसाइड की गई है।
उनमें क्या-क्या चीजें होती हैं? टॉप पे
कौन रहेगा? सेकंड पे कौन, थर्ड पे कौन? ये
हर बार डिसाइड होता है। राइट? उसी तरीके
से मैथ्री फ्रेमवर्क भी है। इसके अंदर भी
थ्रेट्स जो है उसको क्लासिफाई किए।
अलग-अलग थ्रेट्स को उसकी सीिवियरिटी दी गई
है। तो उन थ्रेट्स
के क्लासिफिकेशन के ऊपर यह मैप करता है
आपका टैक्टिक्स वाया टेक्निक फील्ड जो ये
स्क्रीनशॉट में आपको यहां पे टैक्टिक्स
वाया टेक्निक दिख रही है ये वाली। ठीक है?
अब देखिए एनी डिटेक्शन व्हेन क्लिक विल शो
अस रिच डिटेल व्हिच हेल्प्स अ एसोसिए
एनालिस ड्यूरिंग द एनालिसिस। अब कोई सा भी
आप जो यहां पे डिटेक्शन हुई है उस पे जब
आप क्लिक कीजिएगा तो उसकी पूरी डिटेल वो
आपको बताता है। ठीक है? जिससे कि एसओसी
एनालिस्ट को हेल्प मिलती है। अब यहां जो
आपको यह एंड यह स्क्रीनशॉट आपको दिख रहा
है यह क्राउड स्ट्राइक का ही स्क्रीनशॉट
है क्राउड स्ट्राइक फाल्कन का यहां पे एंड
आपको दिख रहा है कुछ इस तरीके से दिखती
है। तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे एंड पॉइंट से
डिटेक्शन में ये डिटेक्शन एंड पॉइंट
डिटेक्शन वाले यहां पे अभी फिलहाल पेज पे
हैं हम। एंड इसमें आप देखेंगे जैसे
डिटेक्शंस हुई हैं। तो 12 अगस्त की
डिटेक्शन है। 10 अगस्त की डिटेक्शन है
यहां पे। राइट? तो 10 अगस्त को तीन
डिटेक्शंस हैं जिसमें दो लो है। एक हाई
सीवियरिटी के 12 को एक हाई सीवियरिटी का
है। डिटेक्शन का टाइम आपको यहां पे दिया
हुआ है। व्हाट इज द टाइम एट डिटेक्शन जो
डिटेक्शन हुई है टाइम प्रोसेस ऑन होस्ट
कौन से प्रोसेस जैसे यहां पे लिखा हुआ है
ना डिटेक्शन टाइम के बाद ट्रिगरिंग फाइल
किस फाइल को ट्रिगर किया गया है? कौन से
एक एग्जैक्टली कौन से प्रोसेस को ट्रिगर
किया गया है? तो यहां पे पावरेल को ट्रिगर
किया गया है। यहां सेटअप exc को ट्रिगर
किया गया है। cmd.exec को ट्रिगर किया गया
है। एपीp बंडल.exc को ट्रिगर किया है।
उसके बाद होस्ट नेम मतलब कौन से कंप्यूटर
पे कौन से एंड पॉइंट पे ये ट्रिगर हुआ है।
व्हिच एंड पॉइंट हैज़ बीन ट्रिगरर्ड। ठीक
है? करेक्ट। तो वो एंड पॉइंट का नाम तो
जैसे एसआरवी01 या एलपीटी12 ये एंड पॉइंट
का नाम। उसके बाद यूजरनेम तो किसके द्वारा
ये ट्रिगर हुआ है? तो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के
द्वारा या जे एडमम्स के द्वारा या के
स्मिथ के द्वारा ये यूज़र्स के नाम होते
हैं। और फिर टैक्टिक्स वाया टेक्निक्स तो
मथ्रे फ्रेमवर्क के ऊपर मैप होता है ये
मथ्रे सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क जो है जैसे
डिफेंस इवेज इसमें क्या हुआ डिफेंस इवेज़
जैसे आपका ओएस पे वनेबिलिटी वाला होता है
ना वेब वनेबिलिटी जैसे एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग उसी तरीके से
थ्रेट्स के लिए ये एमआई आपका है तो डिफेंस
डिफेंस इवेज़ का यहां पे यहां पे कोशिश हुई
है यहां पे डिफेंस इवज़न लग रहा है यहां पे
यहां पे मशीन लर्निंग टेक्निक्स से कुछ हो
रहा है यहां पे मैलवेयर वाया एडवेयर यहां
एडवेयर के थ्रू मैलवेयर फैलाया जा रहा है
एडवेयर मैलवेयर वाया एडवेयर इस तरीके से
हो रहा है और फिर कमांड लाइन मतलब कौन सी
कमांड एग्जैक्टली एग्जीक्यूट हुई है क्या
कमांड एग्जीक्यूट हुई है वो कमांड के बारे
में यहां ऑप्शंस जो हैं यहां पे आपको होते
हैं। ठीक है? उसी तरीके से ट्रिगरिंग यहां
पे आपका देख रहे हो ये प्रोसेस कौन सा
हुआ? है? ट्रिगरिंग फाइल कौन सी हुई है?
तो भैया जो प्रोसेस है उसी की फाइल होती
है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। ऐ बंडल तो प्रोसेस
ये स्टार्ट हुआ। होता है बंडलxe होस्ट नेम
आपका यहां पे रह गया और यूजरनेम ऐसे ही
कुछ इस तरीके से यहां पे ये काम करती है।
तो ये पूरी डिटेल्स होती हैं थ्रेट
डिटेक्शन के अंदर में आपको शो होती हैं।
एंड ये ईडीआर का ही ये पूरा स्क्रीनशॉट है
जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है। सो दिस आर
बीइंग शोन आफ्टर डिटेक्शन। डिटेक्शन के
बाद ये शोन हुई है। ठीक है? हां फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव एंड ट्रू पॉजिटिव का भी कांसेप्ट
है। सो दैट विल आल्सो बी देयर। कि फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव और ट्रू पॉजिटिव भी होते हैं।
इडीआर्स में ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि वह
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव भी हो। तो यह एनालिस्ट
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट का रोल वहीं पे होता
है। एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट का वहां पे रोल है
कि उसको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव ट्रू पॉजिटिव
क्लासिफाई करें। ट्रू पॉजिटिव्स के ऊपर
आगे प्रोसेस होगा। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव को वहीं
पे खत्म उसको इग्नोर छोड़ो। उसका रिपोर्ट
बनाओ और आगे बढ़ो। ये चीज आपका काम होता
है। ठीक है?
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल राइट। इडीआर इज़ नेवर 100%
कोई भी देखो यार कोई भी देखो मैं आपको एक
क्लियर क्लियर क्लियर थिंग बताता हूं। एक
कांसेप्ट बताता हूं। दिमाग में डाल लेना।
देयर इज़ नो सॉफ्टवेयर इन दिस वर्ल्ड दैट
इज़ बीइंग मेड बाय अ ह्यूमन एंड इट्स 100%
एक्यूरेट और 100% वर्किंग।
100% एक्यूरेट कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर नहीं
होता। इवन Windows डिफेंडर जैसे सॉफ्टवेयर
या कोई भी यह भी 100% ओके नहीं होते। कई
बार Windows डिफेंडर ही आपका देखोगे कि एक
लेजिटमेट फाइल को भी फ्लैग कर देगा। कई
बार उसको लगता है कि ये वायरस है बट ऐसा
होता नहीं है। कई बार काली लinक्स के अंदर
की आईएसओ के अंदर की फाइल्स को डिटेक्ट कर
लेता है जूटमड का उसको भी फ्लैग कर देता
है। तो देयर आर अ इशज़ एंड इसलिए अभी भी
ह्यूमंस की रिक्वायरमेंट है। बट आगे चलके
फ्यूचर में अगर मशीनंस ने ही सॉफ्टवेयर
बनाना शुरू कर दिया कंप्लीटली स्क्रैच से।
एंड मशीनंस ने उसको डेवलप करना शुरू किया।
उसको अपग्रेड करना शुरू किया। अपडेट करना
शुरू किया उसको रेगुलरली पैच कर रहे हैं
तो यह बातें शायद इनवैलिड हो जाए जहां मैं
बोल रहा हूं कि 100% एक्यूरेट नहीं होती
शायद वो 100% एक्यूरेट हो जाए एंड दिस विल
बी अ ट्रैजिक थिंग दिस विल बी वेरी डेंजरस
थिंग एंड अभी आपने देखा है रिसेंटली क्लॉड
माइथ्स और ये सब चीजें जो आ रही हैं ये
बहुत बुरी चीजें हैं नॉट अ गुड थिंग पीपल
आर थिंकिंग कि सर हम टेक्नोलॉजी में
एडवांस नहीं होंगे क्या सर हम टेक्नोलॉजी
को आगे नहीं लेकर जाएं क्या सर क्यों हम
इसको इग्नोर
हमने क्या फोन यूज़ करना छोड़ दिया?
स्मार्टफोन यूज़ करना छोड़ दिया।
टेक्नोलॉजी जब स्मार्टफोन फोन अभी तक की
जो टेक थी वो सब वो सब यार डिफरेंट लेवल
के टेक है। उससे आपका जीना दुबर नहीं
होगा। वो आपको कंट्रोल नहीं कर सकता। इट
इज़ बीइंग कंट्रोल बाय अस। जो आर्टिफिशियल
इंटेलिजेंस है उसके अंदर कैपेबिलिटीज है
टू गेट आउट ऑफ कंट्रोल।
टू कंट्रोल यू टू कंट्रोल ह्यूमंस। टू
कंट्रोल अदर मशीनंस विदाउट योर कंसेंट
विदाउट द ह्यूमंस कंसेंट विदाउट द
इनवॉल्वमेंट ऑफ ह्यूमन ये कैपेबिलिटीज है
एआईएमएल की वो अलग बात है यह बहुत दूर है
अभी चीज हो सकता है या ऐसा भी हो सकता है
10 साल के अंदर सब चीजें हो जाए तो नोबडी
नोस एग्जैक्टली किसी को कुछ नहीं पता है
अभी तक किसी को भी कुछ नहीं पता इवन जो
एआई फील्ड में काम कर रहे हैं उनको भी
नहीं पता है क्योंकि अभी तो रिसर्च वर्क
से ये सारी चीजें चल रही है बट डर हर किसी
को लग रहा है और डरना भी चाहिए इस चीज को
लेके तो अभी आपको शायद ना पता हो करंट जॉब
मार्केट सिनेरियो इतना बुरा है। इतना गंदा
हो चुका है। चाहे वो साइबर सिक्योरिटी
डोमेन का हो या किसी भी आईटी डोमेन का हो।
सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपमेंट की बात करूं मैं।
एप्सक की बात करूं मैं किसी भी
हायरिंग्स जो हो रही हैं उसमें उतने
कैंडिडेट्स को हायर नहीं किए जा रहे हैं।
जरूरत नहीं पड़ रही है। और जो कैंडिडेट्स
ऑलरेडी काम कर रहे हैं उनको निकाला जा रहा
है कंपनी से। बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनीज जो है ले
ऑफ कर रही हैं। बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनीज़ आप
इंडिया की ही बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनीज की बात कर
लो। जितनी भी बिग फाइव है सब ले ऑफ कर रही
हैं। और जो लोग चार-चार पांच-प साल की
एक्सपीरियंस होल्डर है उनको भी जॉब से
निकाल दिया जा रहा है और उनको कहीं और जॉब
मिल नहीं पा रही है। सो यह हाल है अभी का
क्योंकि हर कंपनी जो है
वो एक एंटप्राइज लेवल का एआई सिस्टम लेके
बैठ चुका है। जहां पे वह 50 एंप्लाइजज़ को
काम करवाता था। दो एक दो एंप्लई को बैठा
रखा है। अब उसी से वह काम करवा रहा है।
बाकी लोगों को ज़रूरत नहीं है। एंटरप्राइज़
जो सॉफ्टवेयर ले रखा है उसका सब्सक्रिप्शन
पे कर रहा है हर साल। बस अब वो
सब्सक्रिप्शन भी पे करें। एंप्लई को सैलरी
भी दे। क्यों करेगा कोई भी कंपनी वो निकाल
दे रहा है। उसका काम वैसे ही हो रहा है।
सो इट्स अ वेरी डेंजरस थिंग टू गो अ स्टेप
इनसाइड दिस पर्टिकुलर एआई एंड ऑल। बट पता
नहीं कब समझ में आएगा लोगों को। एंड शायद
जब तक समझ आए तब तक काफी देर हो चुकी
होगी। शायद। सो लेट्स सी।
ठीक है।
करेक्ट। करेक्ट। करेक्ट। चलिए अब आगे की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं। ये तो आपने डिटेक्शन का देख
लिया है।
हां। अब एक चीज़ नहीं। नहीं नहीं। आप पढ़ना
नहीं छोड़ सकते। पढ़ना आप बिल्कुल भी नहीं
छोड़ सकते। कई लोगों को लगता है हां कई
लोगों को ये लगता है कि सर क्या हमें अब
पढ़ना ही छोड़ देना चाहिए या हमें किसी भी
डोमेन में कोई चीज सीखनी है। अब ये बताओ
मुझे कि कितनी भी एडवांस टेक्नोलॉजी हो
जाए या एआई आती हो तो आपको सीखना तो
पड़ेगा ना। कोर आप एआई को अप्लाई करोगे उस
पे। अब आपको अगर बेसिक ही नहीं पता है। आप
एआई को इंप्लीमेंट कहां से करोगे? पहले
क्या था कि सिर्फ एक पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक
सीखना है। अब है टॉपिक प्लस एआई को फ्यूज
करना है और उसकी जानकारी लेनी है। यह हो
चुका है। सीखना तो बिल्कुल ही है। लर्निंग
इज शुड बी ऑन गोइंग। लर्निंग आपकी रुकनी
नहीं चाहिए। जिस दिन लर्निंग रुक गई उस
दिन तो फिर आप किसी भी काम फिर तो आप
बिल्कुल ही काम के नहीं रहेंगे। किसी भी
काम के नहीं रहेंगे। सो यू शुड कंटिन्यू
लर्निंग। जितनी सीख सकते हो सीखते जाओ।
जॉब अभी भी मिल रहा है।
जॉब अभी भी मिल रहा है। जॉब अभी भी मिल
रहा है। बट द पॉइंट इज कि जॉब कम लोगों को
मिल रहा है। और जिनको मिल रहे हैं वो कुछ
अलग कर रहे हैं। उनको एक डिफरेंट लेवल की
नॉलेज है। अलग लेवल की नॉलेज है। अब आप
एसओसी पढ़ रहे हो। आपने एसओसी पूरी पढ़
ली। आपको एसओसी की पूरी नॉलेज हो गई। आपने
अब एआई का भी थोड़ा नॉलेज ले लिया।
आपको एआई की भी नॉलेज हो गई और आप काम
करने लगे। अब दिक्कत यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं।
दिक्कत प्रॉब्लम ये है कि आपने सेम
कांसेप्ट को अब एआई के थ्रू डिलीवर करना
है। मतलब सेम कांसेप्ट आपको एआई के थ्रू
अब समझना है। तो आपने समझ लिया पूरा
कांसेप्ट। उसके बाद एआई की थोड़ी नॉलेज ले
ली और उसी चीज को आप अप्लाई कर रहे हो
कंपनी के अंदर में एंटरप्राइज के अंदर में
एंड यू आर यूजिंग अ मान लो एडीआर यूज़ कर
रहे हो। अब एडीआर्स जो है वो एआई कंपैटिबल
मतलब एआई इनफ्यूज्ड आ रहे हैं। सारे
एडीआर्स जो हैं वो मशीन लर्निंग पे काम कर
रहे हैं। एआई वगैरह सब कुछ इंक्लूडेड है।
अब एसओसी जो आपका एसआईएम टूल्स वगैरह जो
होते हैं वो सब एआई से लैश हैं। सारे एआई
इनफ्यूज्ड हैं। तो अब वहां पे भी बेसिकली
वो काम हो रहा है। अब आपको पता होना चाहिए
कि एआई के थ्रू कैसे मतलब कुछ नहीं है। बस
एक यह है कि हां
एक ऑटोमेटिक डिटेक्शन हो रही है। एक
बिहेवियरल डि डिटेक्शन हो रहा है। तो आपको
समझ में आना चाहिए एक्सैक्टली हो क्या रहा
है। वह समझ आपको तभी आएगा जब आपका बेस
स्ट्रांग होगा। अगर आपको बेस आपका स्टंग
नहीं होगा तो यू विल नेवर गोइंग टू
अंडरस्टैंड। दैट्स व्हाई मैं इतना बोल-बोल
के चिल्ला-चिल्ला के बोलता हूं। हमेशा
बोलता हूं कि भैया
भैया बेस को स्ट्रांग करो। कांसेप्ट कोर
को स्ट्रांग करो। ऊपर की चीजें तो तुम कभी
भी सीख लोगे। कैसे भी सीख लोगे? बहुत आसान
है। कोर अगर स्ट्रांग नहीं होगा तो कुछ
नहीं कर पाएंगे। सिंपल।
दैट्स इट। चलिए अब आते हैं रिस्पांस के
ऊपर में। मैं तो तुम्हें जो सच्चाई है, जो
फैक्ट है वो बता रहा हूं। जितने लोग
समझदार हैं समझ जाए, समझ जाएंगे। कोर को
कांसेप्ट कोर को स्ट्रांग करने में लगेंगे
और हर चीज को बहुत डीपली सीखेंगे। दैट्स
इट। रिस्पांस। इडीआर आल्सो एमावर्स
एनालिस्ट्स टू टेक एक्शन ऑन डिटेक्टेड
थ्रेट्स। जो थ्रेट्स डिटेक्ट हुए हैं उनके
ऊपर एक्शन लेने का भी काम ईडीआर का है। दी
एकशंस कैन बी टेकन एट एनी एंड पॉइंट विद
इन द सेंट्रल ईडीआर कंसोल। एक सेंट्रल
एडीआर कंसोल के रेंज में जितने भी एंड
पॉइंट्स हैं उन सब पे एक्शन लिया जा सकता
है रिस्पांस का। इमेजिन गेटिंग अ डिटेक्शन
ऑन ईडीआर विथ फुल फ्लज़ेड डिटेल्स ऑन व्हेन
वेयर एंड व्हाट हैपेंड। ठीक है? एंड यू
हैव टू ऑप्ट आउट फॉर द बेस्ट पॉसिबल एक्शन
फॉर दैट डिटेक्शन। तो आप इमेजिन करो कि एक
एडीआर जो है ठीक है
आपने एक डिटेक्शन डिटेक्शन आपको मिला
एडीआर टीडीआर के थ्रू जिसमें कि सारी
डिटेल्स है जैसे कब कहां क्या हुआ
एग्जैक्टली एंड आपके पास ऑप्शन है कि आप
इसको बेस्ट पॉसिबल रिप्लाई दे सको बेस्ट
पॉसिबल रिस्पांस आप इसका दे सको रिसोंड कर
सको एज एन एनालिस्ट यू मे डिसाइड टू
आइसोलेट अ कंप्लीट एंड पॉइंट टर्मिनेट डेट
अ प्रोसेस क्वारेंटाइन सम फाइल्स एटीसी तो
एज एन एनालिस्ट ये आपकी अपनी कैपेबिलिटीज
के ऊपर डिपेंड करता है। एज एन एनालिस्ट
आपकी अपनी इंटेलिजेंस के ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है। यहीं पे एसोसिएशन अब देखो ये एआई नहीं
करेगा। अभी ये एआई नहीं करेगा। जो चीजें
मैं यहां पे जैसे बता रहा हूं ना एज एन
एनालिस्ट अब ये आपको आपका आपका जो अपना
लॉजिकल माइंडसेट है वो आपका रिसोंड तैयार
करेगा। अब आपको यहां पर सोचना है। इसीलिए
हायरिंग होती है कि एआई तो आपका डिटेक्ट
कर लेगा, बता देगा सबको। लेकिन उसको
रिसोंड किस तरीके से करना है वो ह्यूमन ही
बताएगा। तो कांसेप्ट क्लियर होना चाहिए।
तो आप डिसाइड करोगे कि उस कंप्यूटर एंड
पॉइंट को आइसोलेट कर देना है या एक
पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस को सिर्फ टर्मिनेट करने
से हो जाएगा या कुछ फाइल्स को क्वारंटाइन
करने से बस हो जाएगा। अब ये एआई के हाथ
में दे दोगे। मान लो एआई को आपने यह चीज
दे दी। एक यह डिटेक्शन जो हुई है एi को
उसको फ़ीड कर दिया। एi क्या करेगा? उस
लैपटॉप को उस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क से
आइसोलेट कर देगा। उसको लगेगा कि हां यही
सबसे तरीका है। यही सबसे बेस्ट और सबसे
बड़ा तरीका है कि हां भाई नेटवर्क से ही
हटा दो और खेल ही खत्म हो जाएगा। लेकिन
ह्यूमन उस पे सोचेगा। उसको उसको एनालाइज
देखेगा कि अगर मैं इस लैपटॉप को ही पूरा
हटा दूं। हो सकता है कि यह लैपटॉप के कारण
यह जो पर्टिकुलर मशीन है उसके कारण और
डिवाइसेस सपोर्टिंग डिवाइसेस हैं जो इससे
कनेक्टेड है। अगर मैं इसको हटाऊंगा तो
बाकी सारे डिवाइसेस भी अफेक्ट होंगे। तो
इसको हटाने से अच्छा है कि इसके अंदर एक
प्रोसेस चल रही है। उसको बस टर्मिनेट कर
दो। सारा मैटर खत्म हो जाएगा। तो ह्यूमन
जो है वो काम करेगा। द डिफरेंस बिटवीन द
एआईए एंड ह्यूमंस। अभी तक तो ह्यूमंस सोच
पाते हैं, लॉजिक्स लगा पाते हैं। एआई अभी
तक थोड़ा पीछे है इन चीजों में। आने वाले
टाइम में पता नहीं क्या होगा। बट अभी के
लिए आप थोड़े सेफ हैं इन चीजों से। ठीक
है? तो ये डिसीजंस आप लेते हैं।
राइट? अब देखिए यू कैन आल्सो कनेक्ट द हो
टू द रिमोट होस्ट एंड एग्जीक्यूट टू
कनेक्ट द होस्ट रिमोटली एंड एग्जीक्यूट
एक्शंस इंडिपेंडेंटली। आप रिमोट आप होस्ट
से रिमोटली भी कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं और अपने
एक्शनंस को जो एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? यू कैन डू ऑल दिस फ्रॉम द ईडीआर
कंसोल। आप इडीआर कंसोल से कर सकते हैं। अब
बात यह है कि एक ईडीआर कंसोल से सिर्फ एक
ही एरिया के मशीनंस नहीं कनेक्ट होते हैं।
डिफरेंट एरिया के मशीनंस भी कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। जैसे पटना में एक ईडीआर एंड
पॉइंट डिवाइसेस हैं। कुछ दिल्ली में एंड
पॉइंट डिवाइसेस हैं। कुछ आपके नोएडा में
कुछ एंड पॉइंट डिवाइसेस हैं। उन सबको एक
सेंट्रलाइज़ ईडीआर कंसोल से कनेक्ट किया जो
कि गाजियाबाद में पड़ा हुआ है। ऐसा भी हो
सकता है। तो क्लाउड्स के थ्रू ये सारी
चीजें मैनेज हो सकती है। तो इस तरीके का
यह इसका बेनिफिट है। एंटीवायरस में ऐसा
नहीं होता। एंटीवायरस तो भाई जिस मशीन में
डाले उसी के लिए काम करेगा। ऐसा तो नहीं
मेरे मशीन में एंटीवायरस डालिए आपके मशीन
के लिए काम करे आपके लैपटॉप के लिए। बट
ईडीआर इज़ अ सेंट्रलाइज्ड एंड क्लाउड बेस्ड
एंड सब जगह से ऑपरेट होता है। ठीक है? ये
समझ में आ गया होगा। अब इसी तरीके से ये
क्राउड स्ट्राइक फाल्कन जो इंडिया
सॉल्यूशन प्रोवाइड करता है उसका ही एक पेज
आपको यहां पे देखने को मिलेगा जो कि
बेसिकली रियल टाइम रिस्पांस का पेज है यह।
देखो
यह रियल टाइम रिस्पांस है। यहां पे आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा होगा। यहां पे
कुछ इस तरीके से ये
द फॉलोइंग स्क्रीनशॉट शोज़ द एक्शंस
अवेलेबल दैट कैन बी टेकन ऑन द होस्ट आफ्टर
कनेक्टिंग टू इट। तो बेसिकली आपको यहां पे
एक्शंस देख रहे दिख रहे होंगे जो कि आप
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं होस्ट से कनेक्ट करने
के बाद। जैसे कैट है यहां पे रीड अ फाइल
फ्रॉम डिस्कस् एंड डिस्प्ले एंड आई एन
आस्की
सीडी है चेंज द करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
क्लियर है क्लियर द स्क्रीन कॉपी अ फाइल
इंक्रिप्ट अ फाइल प्रिंट आउट द एनवायरमेंट
ये सारे एकशंस आप परफॉर्म यहां पे बेसिकली
कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? यहां पे आप कमांड से
रन कर सकते हैं। यहां पे कुछ एडिट एंड रन
स्क्रिप्ट करके यहां पे गैब कमांड का यूज़
करके यहां पे एंड बेसिकली कुछ चीजों को
यहां पे सर्च किया गया है। यहां पे किसके
अंदर में? वायरडw hटीml के अंदर में आपके
ये जो कीवर्ड्स है वो सर्च किए गए हैं। तो
इस तरीके से जो है आप रिस्पांस जो है
एक्शंस ले सकते हैं। अब देखो देयर आर
सेवरल अदर एक्शंस दैट एनालिस्ट कैन टेक
ड्यूरिंग द इन्वेस्टिगेशन। इसको हम और भी
डिटेल में पढ़ेंगे। यहां पे विद एडवांस
विजिबिलिटी डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस ईडीआर
बिकम्स अ वेरी पावरफुल टूल। हाउएवर इट इज़
आल्सोेंट टू रिमेंबर दैट ईडीआर इज़ अ होस्ट
ओनली सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन एंड डज़ नॉट
डिटेक्ट नेटवर्क लेवल थ्रेट्स। तो ये बात
एकदम से ध्यान रखना है कि ये एक होस्ट
ओनली सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन है। ये बात
हमेशा याद रखना है। ये होस्ट पे इंडिया
एजेंट्स होस्ट पे बैठे होते हैं। नेटवर्क
के डिटेक्शंस नहीं करते हैं। ये मतलब एक
नेटवर्क के अंदर कुछ हो रहा है। उसको
डिटेक्ट नहीं करते। ये होस्ट पे बैठे रहते
हैं। पर्टिकुलर जैसे प्रिंटर है आपका मतलब
प्रिंटर मतलब प्रिंटर क्या है आपका जैसे
लैपटॉप है, सर्वर है, कंप्यूटरटर्स है अगर
उसमें एडीआर सॉलशंस जो है उस एडीआर
एजेंट्स जो है वहां बैठे रहते हैं और उसकी
डिटेक्शन करते हैं। सो दीज़ आर कॉल्ड होस्ट
ओनली सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन। नेटवर्क लेवल
के थ्रेट्स को ये डिटेक्ट नहीं करते हैं।
ठीक है? ये इनका एक वो है। बट इसीलिए फिर
एसआईएम और इसमें बहुत सारी चीजें होती
हैं। वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा। एसआईएम का
क्यों यूज़ होता है? व्हाई एसआईएम बीइंग इज़
यूज्ड। ठीक है? अब यहां पे तो आ गया। अब
हम वापस से अपने पीपीडी पे आ जाते हैं।
फिर वापस से हम इसको आगे की तरफ देखते
हैं। चलिए ये तीनों चीजें आपकी क्लियर हो
गई। विजिबिलिटी, डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस।
ये तीनों चीजें क्लियर है? बता दीजिए।
ओके आई एम वेटिंग फॉर योर रिस्पांस। प्लीज
रिप्लाई एवरीबॉडी।
आप सभी रिप्लाई करेंगे तो फिर हम आगे बढ़
जाते हैं। एक बार बता दीजिए सभी लोग कि इज
इट क्लियर?
एक डाउट है। यहां डाउट पूछिए आप। प्लीज
बताइए।
मैंने ऑलरेडी बताया अलबिनी 75% हो चुका
है।
एसआईएम पर हम काम करेंगे। बिल्कुल करेंगे
कि टेंशन क्यों ले रहे हो भाई? बिल्कुल
करेंगे।
सुजोय साह पढ़ते जाओ। कोर्स करते जाओ
धीरे-धीरे पहले कोर्स करते जाओ। बाद में
देखते हैं। मिलता जाएगा सब सब चीजें।
ऑल क्लियर क्लियर।
जिनका डाउट है वह प्लीज यह मत बोलिए डाउट
है सीधा डाउट पूछिए चैट में क्लियर है
ओके गुड चलिए जिनका डाउट है वो डाउट पूछ
लीजिए हां एडीआर फॉल्स नेगेटिव हो सकता है
बिल्कुल हो सकता है
पॉसिबल है बिल्कुल हो सकता है फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव फॉल्स नेगेटिव हो सकता है पॉसिबल
है
वाजू इंडिया नहीं है यार। वाजू इज अ
एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म।
थ्योरी पढ़-पढ़ के बोर हो गए हैं। कोई बात
नहीं आप छोड़ दीजिए पढ़ना क्योंकि थ्योरी के
बिना एसओसी का
एसओसी को पढ़ाया नहीं जा सकता और ना ही
समझा जा सकता है।
ऑलरेडी बताया मैंने कि कोर्स 75% कंप्लीट
हो चुकी है। 25% बची है।
हां, पॉसिबल है। कभी वर्क ही ना करें।
पॉसिबल है। बहुत महंगा है। एडीआर को सेटअप
करना इज़ वेरी कॉस्टली। तभी बड़ी कंपनीज़ ही
ओनली अफोर्ड कर सकती है इसको।
सर ईडीआर का अलर्ट हमें एसआईएम में मिलता
है ना? बिल्कुल। हां जी। हां जी। एसआईएम
में ही मिलता है। मैं बताऊंगा क्या होता
है एक्सैक्टली। एसआईएम में ही मिलता है।
ठीक है।
एसआईएम में ही मिलता है। एसआईएम तभी तो
यूज़ होती है। अभी तो मैं बताऊंगा आपको
बेसिकली
एग्जैक्टली क्या है?
हां अ
देखो तुम
जो पूछ रहे हैं ना ओपन सोर्स एक
वर्जन है इसका। अ ओपन ईडीआर नाम है उसका।
आप उसको एक बार चेक आउट कीजिएगा। दैट इज़
एन ओपन सोर्स वर्जन। आप उसको एक बार ट्राई
कर लीजिएगा। यूज कर सकते हैं। ओपन ईडीआर
ओपन ईडीआर।
यह जो ओपन एडीआर है यह ओपन सोर्स वर्जन
है।
हाउ ईडीआर एंड एसआईएम कनेक्ट टुगेदर?
कनेक्ट नहीं होता है। ईडीआर एसआईएम के का
पार्ट ही है ईडीआर। ईडीआर इज़ बिकम्स द
पार्ट ऑफ़ एसआईएम। बताऊंगा मैं अभी। चलिए
ठीक है। समझ में आ गया? चलिए अब आगे बढ़ते
हैं। अब आते हैं यहां पे हाउ ईडीआर
वर्क्स। एग्जैक्टली ईडीआर काम कैसे करती
है? ऑपरेशनल फ्लो ये समझते हैं। फिर एक
चार्ट के थ्रू भी समझेंगे। चार्ट के थ्रू
ताकि और ज्यादा क्लियर समझ में आए। एंड
इडीआर डज़ नॉट स्लिप। कभी सोती नहीं है।
जैसे एंटीवायरस कभी-कभी सो भी जाता है। इट
कॉन्सेंटली लूप्स थ्रू अ फोर स्टेज लाइफ
साइकिल टू कीप द एनवायरमेंट सिक्योर। चार
स्टेज का एक लाइफ साइकिल होता है जिसमें
ईडीआर ऑपरेट करता है एंड सिक्योर करता है
एंड पॉइंट डिवाइसेस को। पहला स्टेज
कंटीन्यूअस डेटा कलेक्शन जिसको हम
टेलीमेट्री भी बोलते हैं। जैसा एक टर्म
कुछ देर पहले कई लोग समझ नहीं पा रहे थे
टेलीमेट्री क्या होता है? तो डेटा जो होती
है वही टेलीमेट्री है जो डेटा कलेक्ट करके
आता है। तो कंटीन्यूअस डेटा कलेक्शन। ठीक
है? कंटीन्यूअस। तो कंटीन्यूअस डेटा जब
कलेक्शन होती है उसको टेलीमेट्री बोल रहे
हैं। पहला स्टेज है ये। द अब इधर सभी लोग
इधर ध्यान दे देंगे। सभी लोग चैट से निकल
के इधर ध्यान देंगे क्योंकि मैं चैट अब
मॉनिटर नहीं कर रहा। द एंड पॉइंट एजेंट
रिकॉर्ड्स एव्री फंडामेंटल एक्शन टेकिंग
प्लेस ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। जो एंड पॉइंट
के एजेंट्स होते हैं वो हर एक एक्शन को
मॉनिटर करते हैं। दिस डाटा स्ट्रीम
इंक्लूड्स इसमें क्या-क्या इंक्लूड है?
कौन-कौन से एक्शंस होते हैं भाई? प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूशंस, रजिस्ट्री चेंजेस, नेटवर्क
कनेक्शंस, फाइल मॉडिफिकेशंस, प्रोसेस
एग्जीक्यूशन व्हाट एप्लीकेशनेशंस आर
लॉन्चिंग? कौन-कौन से एप्लीकेशन ल्च हो
रहे हैं? इज cmd.exc बीइंग ओपन बाय
वर्ड.exc क्या कमांड प्र्प वर्ड के द्वारा
ओपन हुआ है? यह भी मॉनिटर किया जाता है।
तो भैया कमांड प्र्प्ट वर्ड के द्वारा
क्यों ओपन होगा? सीएमडी cएमडी यूजर के
द्वारा ओपन होगा। सीएमडी को डायरेक्टली
ल्च किया जाएगा ना नॉर्मली नॉर्मल
सिनेरियो में कमांड प्र्ट को cmdexee को
हम डायरेक्ट रन करते हैं यूजर चलाता है
ऐसा थोड़ी ना है कि हमने वर्ड को चलाया
वर्ड ने कमांड प्र्ट को चला दिया मतलब कुछ
गड़बड़ है इस तरह के बिहेव इस तरीके की जो
डिटेक्शंस है जो डेटा है यहां से कलेक्ट
होती है इस तरीके की चीजों को मॉनिटर किया
जाता है रजिस्ट्री चेंजज़ इज़ अ प्रोग्राम
ट्राइंग टू मॉडिफाई बूट सेटिंग्स टू स्टे
ऑन द सिस्टम आफ्टर अ रिबूट क्या कोई बूट
सेटिंग बूट सेटिंग्स जो है उसकी कोई
चेंजेस की जा रही है किसी प्रोग्राम के
द्वारा रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में नेटवर्क
कनेक्शंस व्हाट इंटरनल और एक्सटर्नल IPपी
एड्रेसेस इन दिस स्पेसिफिक मशीन टॉकिंग टू
जो यह मशीन है वो किस-किस इंटरनल आईपी से
बात कर रही है या कौन सी कैसी एक्सटर्नल
आईपी से बात कर रही है। अब कोई ऐसी इंटरनल
आईपी जो उसी उसी नेटवर्क के अंदर में
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड पीसी है कहीं उससे तो बात
नहीं हो रही ऑलरेडी हैक्ड पीसी है ज़ॉम्बी
पीसी है या कोई एक्सटर्नल आईपी से तो बात
नहीं करी है जो आउट ऑफ द नेटवर्क है
मलेशियस है सस्पिशियस है फाइल मॉडिफिकेशंस
आर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ डॉक्यूमेंट्स सडनली
चेंजिंग एक्सटेंशनंस टू डॉट लॉग्ड क्या
बहुत सारे डॉक्यूमेंट्स हैं उनका सबका
एक्सटेंशनंस अचानक से चेंज होने लग रहा है
डॉट लॉग्ड मतलब रैंसमवेयर का बिहेवियर है
या बहुत सारे फाइल्स हैं वो कुछ अलग बिहेव
कर रहे हैं नॉर्मल बिहेवियर से तो वो सारे
चीजों को मॉनिटर किया जाता है स्टेज वन
में। अब आता है आपका स्टेज टू जहां पे
होती है बिहेवियरल एनालिसिस एंड डिटेक्शन।
ये स्टेज टू का पार्ट है। द क्लाउड कंसोल
यानी इडीआर कंसोल जो है इन जस्ट दिस मैसिव
लेक ऑफ टेलीमेट्री। ये जो मैसिव बहुत बड़ा
एक डेटा होता है।
ठीक है?
इंस्टेड ऑफ जस्ट लुकिंग फॉर स्टैटिक फाइल
सिग्नेचर्स इट रंस द डाटा अगेंस्ट
एडवांस्ड बिहेवियरल मॉडल्स मशीन लर्निंग
एंड थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस फीड्स। अब नॉर्मली
एक फाइल को एनालाइज करने के बजाय जैसे
एंटीवासेस करती हैं। ये क्या करता है? जो
भी डाटा यह टेलीमेट्री जो कलेक्ट किए रहता
है उस डाटा को एडवांस बिहेवरल मॉडल्स जो
होते हैं जो एआई मॉडल्स बिहेवरल बेस्ड
मॉडल्स होते हैं उनको फीड करता है। मशीन
लर्निंग के थ्रू ये मशीन लर्निंग
एल्गोरििदम यहां पे यूज़ होती है। बहुत
सारे थ्रेट थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस जो फ़ीड जो अह
मॉडल्स होते हैं, थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस जो
प्लेटफ़ॉर्म है, उनको फीड करता है और उनके
बिहेवियरल एनालिसिस करता है। यानी
बिहेवियर को एनालाइज़ करता है। द सीक्रेट
वेपन बिहेवरल हरिस्टिक्स। इसका मतलब क्या
है? यह इसका सीक्रेट वेपन है। क्या है? एन
इडियट डज़ नॉट केयर इफ अ स्क्रिप्ट हैज़ अ
कंप्लीटली यूनिक नेम, इट हैज़ नेवर सीन
बिफोर। इससे उसको कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है।
इफ दैट स्क्रिप्ट अटेमप्ट्स टू डंप द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पासवर्ड डेटाबेस दैट इज़
एल्स मेमोरी द इडियर फ्लैग्स इट बेस्ड ऑन
व्हाट इट इज़ डूइंग नॉट व्हाट इट इज़ नेम।
इसका मतलब कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है कि फाइल
का नाम क्या है। ठीक है? उस फाइल का नाम
वायरस.ex रख दो और कुछ नहीं कर रहा तो
ईडीआर कभी उसको फ्लैग नहीं करेगा। उसको
ईडीआर लगेगा अरे कुछ नहीं है। और सही में
कुछ नहीं कर रहा तो कोई बात नहीं है। बट
अगर वह फाइल अपडेट exc है। अगर वह फाइल एक
नॉर्मल cmd.exec फाइल से ही है या कुछ भी
नॉर्मल नाम भी है। बिल्कुल सिमिलर अच्छा
नाम है। बट अगर उसका बिहेवियर गंदा है तो
वो उस बेसिस पे फ्लैग करता है। तो ये एक
अच्छा पेरेंट है। एक अच्छा पेरेंट है जो
बिहेवियर के बेसिस पे जज कर रहा है। तो
यहां पे जो आपका इडीआर है वो बिहेवियरल
एनालिसिस के तौर पे जो है रिसोंड करता है।
उसके आधार पे यह बताता है कि भैया यह
थ्रेट हो सकता है कि नहीं। तो अगर कोई
पर्टिकुलर थ्रेट एक्टर है जो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का पासवर्ड डेटाबेस डंप कर रहा है
यानी एल्स की मेमोरी को डंप कर रहा है तो
डिटेक्ट खतरनाक गायब। ये रहा भाई।
तो टेलीमेट्री और बिहेवरल डिटेक्शन के बाद
आती है थर्ड स्टेज इन्वेस्टिगेशन एंड
थ्रेट हंटिंग। यह इसका थर्ड स्टेज होता
है। इन्वेस्टिगेशन करना और थ्रेट हंटिंग
करना। अब इसमें क्या होता है? व्हेन द
डिटेक्शन इंजन स्पॉट एन एनोमली कोई तरह का
कोई छेड़छाड़ यह डिटेक्ट करता है। इट
पैकेजेस इट इंटू एन अलर्ट फॉर एनालिस्ट्स।
ठीक है? लाइक अस। हमारे जैसे एनालिस्ट के
लिए यह एक अलर्ट थ्रो कर देता है।
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट यानी एसोसिएशन
एनालिस्ट के लिए थ्रेट अलर्ट जो है वह
फायर करता है। बिकॉज़ द ईडीआर रिकॉर्ड्स
एवरीथिंग। क्योंकि एडिया सब कुछ रिकॉर्ड
करता है। इट गिव्स अस अ हिस्टोरिकल
टाइमलाइन। तो ये हिस्टोरिकल टाइमलाइन मतलब
हर चीज जो रिकॉर्ड करता है ये एक टाइमलाइन
के अंदर में टाइम के अकॉर्डिंग इस टाइम पे
हुआ। फिर अगले टाइम पे ये टाइम पे इस डेट
में ऐसे करके ये पूरा रिकॉर्ड रखता है। तो
आप पहले की पास्ट की भी रिकॉर्ड्स वगैरह
सब चेक कर सकते हो। वी कैन ट्रेस एन अटैकर
बैक टू इट्स रूट कॉज पेशेंट ज़ीरो या
अफेक्टेड मशीन ज़ीरो। यानी पेशेंट जीरो जो
आप बोलते हैं जैसे कोई भी पेशेंट जीरो का
मतलब आप में से सब लोगों को शायद पता
होगा। जैसे मान लो कोई किसी भी तरह का कोई
हेल्थ हज़ार्ड आता है। किसी भी तरह का कोई
बहुत बड़ी कोई डिसीज फैलती है। ठीक है? या
जैसे कोविड-19 राइट कोविड-19 आपकी आई थी।
राइट?
उस तरीके का कुछ होता है। तो उसमें जो
सबसे पहला पर्सन इनफेक्टेड होता है, सबसे
फर्स्ट दुनिया का सबसे पहला पेशेंट जो
इनफेक्ट हुआ होगा, उसको पेशेंट जीरो बोला
जाता है। तो उसी तरीके से यह जो इडीआर के
थ्रू एक अटैकर को हम रूट कॉज तक ट्रेस कर
सकते हैं। जो पेशेंट जीरो यानी कि
एग्जैक्ट शुरू कहां से हुआ था। वहां तक
ट्रेस कर सकते हैं टू सी एक्सैक्टली हाउ द
हैकर गॉट इन वेदर दे डाउनलोडेड अ मशियस
ईमेल अटैचमेंट और एक्सप्लइटेड एन अनपैता
है अटैकर ने क्या उन्होंने कोई एक मशियस
अटैचमेंट डाउनलोड करवा के इस पर्टिकुलर
अटैक को अंजाम दिया था या किसी अनपैच्ड
एप्लीकेशन को एक्सप्लइट कर दिया था किसी
वनेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट करके किया था ये
सारी चीजें आपकी होती है यह होता है
इन्वेस्टिगेशन एंड थ्रेट हंटिंग के अंदर
में बिल्कुल हां ये उसका पार्ट बोल बोल
सकते हो सुरेंद्र। अब लास्ट स्टेज आता है
ऑटोमेटेड एंड मैनुअल रिस्पांस। तो दिस इज़
वेयर द आर इन द ईडीआर अर्न्स इट्स की
रिस्पांस। इडीआर में आर रिस्पांस का मतलब
होता है आर। ठीक है? तो अब इफ द ईडीआर
डिटेक्ट्स एन एक्टिव हाई स्पीड थ्रेट लाइक
रैंसमवेयर। अगर इसको यह डिटेक्ट हुआ कोई
एक बहुत ही एक्टिव रैंसमवेयर टाइप अटैक।
इट डज़ नॉट वेट फॉर अ ह्यूमन एनालिस्ट टू
वेक अप। इट कैन एग्जीक्यूट ऑटोमेटेड
कंटेनमेंट एकशंस इंस्टेंट। तो एडीआर में
अगर ऐसा कुछ बहुत ही हाई सीवियरिटी की कोई
अटैक इसने डिटेक्ट कर लिया। रैंसमवेयर
टाइप का अटैक या कोई फाइललेस मैलवेयर कोई
मेमोरी में कोई अटैक डिटेक्ट कर लिया
जिससे कि यह अब बताएगा अलर्ट देगा। वो
उससे पहले यह क्या करता है? अपना
एग्जीक्यूशन चालू कर देगा। एंड बोलेगा
भैया तुम निकलो। कोई जरूरत नहीं है
ह्यूमंस की। मैं ही तुम्हारे लिए काफी हूं
और एग्जीक्यूट कर देगा अपना कंटेनमेंट
एक्शन यानी उसको एलिमिनेट करने का एकशंस।
ये होती है आपकी स्टेज हो। चार स्टेज में
एडीआर आपका काम करता है। अब इसको
ग्राफिक्स के थ्रू थोड़ा अच्छे से और
समझते हैं। इसको और क्लेरिटी के साथ समझते
हैं। तो यहां पे ग्राफिक्स में आप देखेंगे
यहां पे बेसिकली एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
रिस्पांस वर्क फ्लो है ये जो मैं आपको
बताने वाला हूं। इसके थ्रू और भी ज़्यादा
क्लेरिटी आपको मिल जाएगी। और क्लियर आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा। रियल वर्ल्ड मैलवेयर
अटैक एंड रिस्पांस। यहां पे मैं एक
मैलवेयर अटैक एंड रिस्पांस को
डेमोंस्ट्रेट करने वाला हूं इस
इनफोग्राफिक्स के थ्रू। ठीक है? आपको समझ
में आएगा। तो यहां पे चार स्टेज जो है वो
चारों स्टेज आपको यहां पे दिख रहे होंगे।
उसके थ्रू मैं आपको बताऊंगा। पहला है डेटा
कलेक्शन का, दूसरा है बिहेवियरल डिटेक्शन
का, तीसरा कंटेनमेंट का, चौथा रिमशन का।
तो मैलवेयर मान लो कोई एक मैलवेयर अटैक
होता है। उसके उसके ऊपर कैसे यह काम करता
है यह देखते हैं। अब पहला है कंटीन्यूअस
पहला है थोड़ी देर और रुक जाओ। अभी थोड़ी
देर और चलेगी क्लास। कंटीन्यूअस
विजिबिलिटी एंड कलेक्शन। ठीक है? जिसको हम
टेलीमेट्री बोलते हैं। टेलीमेट्री डाटा।
ठीक है? क्या हो रहा है यहां पे? बेसिकली
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग? ये हमारा भैया ये हमारे
एंड पॉइंट है। ठीक है? ये हमारा एंड पॉइंट
हो गया। ये क्लाउड वर्चुअल मशीन हो गया।
ये हमारा सर्वर हो गया हमारा। ये ये सर्वर
हो गया। ये हमारे मशीन हो गया। ये हमारा
इडीआर एजेंट है जो इस एंड पॉइंट पे काम कर
रहा है। अब इस एंड पॉइंट से ये पूरे एंड
पॉइंट से ये टेलीमेट्री डेटा जा रही है।
मतलब ये डेटा जा रही है। ये डेटा जा रहा
है। ये डेटा जा रहा है। ये डेटा सब जा रहा
है। क्या किस टाइप के डेटा जा रही है?
कौन-कौन से प्रोसेस एग्जीकशंस हुए हैं?
नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस कौन-कौन से हैं?
रजिस्ट्री कोई चेंजेस हुए हैं क्या? फाइल
मॉडिफिकेशंस हुई है क्या? ये पहले स्टेज
में ये सारा हो रहा है। अब यहां पे यहां
से अब आ जाते हैं दूसरे स्टेज पे।
इंटेलिजेंट डिटेक्शन एंड एनालिसिस दूसरे
स्टेज पे है। इसमें क्या हो रहा है?
बेसिकली इंटेलिजेंट डिटेक्शन एनालिसिस में
यहां पे अब मान लो कोई pdf.exe फाइल है।
ये वाली फाइल है। ये मलिशियस है। मान लो
एग्जीक्यूट हुई है यहां पे। ठीक है? अब
एग्जीक्यूट हुई है तो भैया अब हमें
देखेंगे कि इसके अंदर किस तरीके की
प्रोसेस फ्री हो रही है। तो मान लो एक ऐसा
बोलेंगे। मान लो ये ईडीआर कंसोल है जो
सेंट्रल मैनेजमेंट ईडीआर कंसोल है। जैसे
यहां से सारी डाटा निकली है एंड पॉइंट से।
एंड पॉइंट से डाटा निकल के सारी डाटा
इडीआर कंसोल को चली गई। ठीक है? अब इडीआर
कंसोल से जैसे ही गई तो यहां पे
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग हुई है। मान लो इसको
डिटेक्ट हुआ कि डिटेक्शन में क्या आया कि
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग यहां पे लग रहा है। ये
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग है। एआईएमएल का यूज़
किया गया है यहां पे। अब क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग में भी किस तरीके का एक प्रोसेस
ट्री यूज़ हुआ है? कुछ इस तरीके का प्रोसेस
ट्री यूज़ हुआ है। देखो इसमें क्या हुआ है?
आउटलुक आउटलुक exc जो है वह एग्जीक्यूट
हुई है। एक नॉर्मल एक एकदम बिलकुल भी नॉट
बिलकुल भी मलेशियस कैटेगरी में नहीं आने
वाला एक जेन्युइन फाइल एग्जीक्यूट हुई है।
टलुक exc उसने क्या किया है? Chrome.exee
को एग्जीक्यूट किया है। Chrome.exec ने
pdf.exee को एग्जीक्यूट डाउनलोड किया है।
pdf.exec ने cmd.exc कमांड प्र्ट को
एग्जीक्यूट किया और इसने पावर शेल को
एग्जीक्यूट किया है। तो ये पूरा का पूरा
एक हायरार्की चल रहा है। एक प्रोसेस ट्री
बन रही है। टलex प्रोसेस ने chrome.exe
प्रोसेस को चालू किया। इसने pdf.exc को
डाउनलोड किया। इसने cdm cmd.exc को
प्रोसेस किया और इसने पावर शेल को स्टार्ट
किया। तो अब इस तरीके से ये चीजें काम कर
रही हैं। तो इसने ये डिटेक्शन लिया यहां
पे क्लाउड इंजंस फाइंड एनमलीज़ एंड
बिहेवियर्स। इसने इसमें छेड़छाड़ इसमें
एनोमलीज़ को फाइंड किया। एंड यहां देखा
भैया कि रेड फ्लैग जो है यहां पे इसमें जो
सबसे बड़ा रेड फ्लैग है वो है pdf.exc
की जो कि Chrome से डाउनलोड हुई है।
आउटलुक खुलना बिल्कुल सही था। Chrome डॉट
exc ओपन होना यह भी बिल्कुल सही था। इसमें
भी कोई गड़बड़ी नहीं लेकिन pdf.exec जो
फाइल है सारी गड़बड़ी इसी में है। तो
हमारा जो मेन ये जो मेन जो हमारा विलेन है
pdf.exe है तो ये मलिशियस एग्जीक्यूशन कर
रहा है। कमांड प्र्ट को ओपन करके पार्शियल
को ओपन करके क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। एल्स एस को डंप करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। ये सेकंड स्टेज में होता
है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे जो भी चीजें सेकंड
स्टेज में हुई है जैसे ये प्रोसेस ट्री
बनी है आपकी आउटलुक Chrome.exe ये सारी
चीजें। अब ये तुरंत नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे जाता
है थर्ड स्टेप पे जहां पे कंटेनमेंट या
इमीडिएट रिस्पांस एंड कंटेनमेंट का स्टेप
होता है। अब इसमें क्या होता है भैया
हमारे एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एक्शंस होते हैं।
एसओसी हमारे एनालिस्ट होते हैं। तुरंत ये
इसकी अलर्ट आती है। जैसे ही इसको पता चलता
है नहीं अरे यार ये pdf.ex डेंजरस फाइल
है। ये तो इसने तो ये ये चीज़ एग्जीक्यूट
की पावर सेल कर। अब तुरंत ये हमारा ईडीआर
क्लाउड जो है कंसोल जो है ये अलर्ट भेजता
है नेक्स्ट स्टेप के लिए। हाई सीवियरिटी
अलर्ट। बहुत सीवियर अलर्ट एक आया है भैया
बच जाओ। अब यह सीवियर अलर्ट यह पता चलता
है हमारे एसओसी भैया जो बैठे हुए हैं ना
हमारे जैसे तुम एसओसी बनोगे तुम चुपचाप
ऐसे बैठे रहोगे ऐसे ऐसे बैठे रहोगे ऐसे
देखते रहोगे ऐसा ही हमको एक अलर्ट आएगा
अलर्ट आ गया अलर्ट आने के पहले के सारे
स्टेप्स थे जो ईडीआर आपका कर रहा है जो
फर्स्ट सेकंड स्टेप था अब तुम अब तुम अब
एक्शन में आओगे कि भैया अब तो अलर्ट आ गया
वो भी हाई सीवियरिटी अलर्ट देखो क्या है
तो अब तुमने क्या किया भैया तुम्हारा जो
अह यह लैपटॉप है, डिवाइस है। ठीक है? तो,
तुमने अलग-अलग एक्शंस लिए। तुम्हारे पास
डिफ़ेंट-डिफ़ेंट एक्शंस हैं। ठीक है?
तुम्हारे पास ऑप्शंस हैं बहुत सारे। तुम
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट हो। तुम्हारे पास बहुत
ऑप्शन है। अब तुम्हारी अपनी इंटेलिजेंस
क्या है? तुम अपनी इंटेलिजेंस को कितना
यूज़ कर पा रहे हो? ये कैसे डिसाइड करोगे?
ये तुम कॉन्सेप्ट के थ्रू ही तो डिसाइड
करोगे। तुमने जो चीज सीखा है इसमें एआई का
कहां रोल है? सीखने में कोई एआई का रोल
नहीं होता है। एआई का रोल है एग्जीक्यूशन
में। अब यहां पे तुमने सीखा है जो तुम उसी
के अकॉर्डिंग एक्ट करोगे। अब तुमने सीखा
है उसी के अकॉर्डिंग उसी कांसेप्ट के
अकॉर्डिंग
आप इसको रिसोंड करोगे। अब आपके पास एक्शंस
क्या-क्या हैं कि इस डिवाइस को नेटवर्क से
आइसोलेट कर दो। इस डिवाइस से इंटरनेट बंद
कर दो। इस डिवाइस के प्रोसेस को टर्मिनेट
कर दो। इस डिवाइस को पूरे नेटवर्क से
आइसोलेट कर दो। ये सारे ऑप्शंस हैं जो आप
करोगे।
ठीक है? तो आइसोलेट एंड पॉइंट एंड किल
मलेशियस प्रोसेस। तो आपका काम इस तरीके का
हो सकता है कि या तो आप उसको आइसोलेट कर
दो नेटवर्क से ही बाहर कर दो और उन
प्रोसेससेस को किल कर दो या सिर्फ
प्रोसेससेस को किल करके भी हो जा रहा है
तो दैट्स ऑल फाइन किल कर दो दैट्स इट। एंड
लास्ट स्टेज हमारा आता है इरेडिकेशन एंड
रिकवरी यानी रेमडीिएशन का प्रोसेस। ठीक
है? तो एनालिस क्लीन सिस्टम ब्लॉक्स हैशेस
ग्लोबली। तो अब यहां पे क्या होता है कि
मेसियस फाइल यहां से ये जो यहां से
मेलिशियस फाइल जो है भेज दी गई है कि भैया
यही मेलिसिस फाइल था जो सारा हंगामा कर
रहा था। अब यहां पे देखा जाता है
रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर में क्या किया जाता
है वो चीजें सारी अपडेट की जाती हैं।
हैशेस को ग्लोबली जो है ऐसे हैशेस को जो
है वो ब्लॉक कर दिए जाते हैं। डेटाबेस में
डाल दिया कि भैया इस इस टाइप के हैश की
कोई अगर फाइल आती है अगली बार तो उसको बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट थ्रेट समझा जाए। एंड वो उसका एक
डेटाबेस बन जाता है एंड वो डेटाबेस में
चली जाती है। एंड वो फाइल फिर उसके हैशेस
जो है वो बिल्कुल ही ब्लॉक कर दिए जाते
हैं। वो हैशेस फर्दर आपके नहीं एग्जीक्यूट
हो सकते और आपका सिस्टम जो है क्लीन हो
जाता है। आपका जो एंड पॉइंट है वो बिल्कुल
क्लीन हो जाता है। इस तरीके से एडीआर आपकी
काम करती है। बस तो अब एडीआर कैसे काम
करती है? ये समझ में आया कि नहीं? मुझे
सभी लोग बताइए जितने 50 लोग यहां पे
प्रेजेंट हैं। आई वांट रिस्पांस फ्रॉम
एवरीबॉडी।
क्या यार मैं इतना बोलता हूं और आप एक
टाइप करने में भी आपको अगर
इतनी प्रॉब्लम हो रही है तो फिर कैसे कैसे
चलेगा तो बताइए जल्दी
थप्पड़ फाड़ के क्लियर हुआ ना
हम
छप्पर फाड़ के
ओके
बहुत अच्छी बात है। डे बाय डे नॉलेज
इनक्रीज।
देखो वन शॉर्ट ब्रीफ तो ऐसा कुछ नहीं होता
यार। मैं बहुत ऑलरेडी बोल रहा हूं। अगर
आपको लेट्स सपोज क्लियर उतना नहीं हुआ
होगा तो दोबारा वीडियो देखेंगे आपको
क्लियर हो जाएगा। सिंपल कि काम है पहला
स्टेप
डाटा कलेक्ट करना। दूसरा उसको एनालाइज
करके डिटेक्शंस करना। डिटेक्शन के बाद आगे
अलर्ट को थ्रो थ्रो करना जिससे पे एसओसी
एनालिस्ट को अलर्ट मिलता है। और एसओसी जो
है उस पे काम करना शुरू कर देता है। और
फिर उसको क्लीन कर देना, टर्मिनेट कर
देना, इलिमिनेट कर देना।
ठीक है?
ओके।
अब मुझे आप में से
सभी लोगों में से कोई बताइए। आप में से
किसी ने एसओसी का कोई पेड कोर्स करा है।
एसओसी एल1 का कोई भी पेड कोर्स किसी ने भी
ओके गौरव जांगरा मैं समझ सकता हूं दैट्स
फाइन
हां सॉफ्टवेयर बनाना पॉसिबल है क्यों नहीं
है किसी ने भी एसओसी का कोई पेड कोर्स करा
है क्या
नो सर ओनली ट्रस्ट ऑन यू क्या बात है
नो नो नो किसी ने भी नहीं कहा था ना
ठीक है। नहीं एक्चुअली मैं इसलिए पूछ रहा
था कि अगर करा होता ना तो मैं कंपैरिजन
करने के लिए लाइव यहां पर आप में से किसी
को बोल देता जिसने करा होता तो शायद आपको
क्लियर में समझ में आ जाता कि पेड कोर्स
में भी आपको इस तरीके की चीजें इतनी डीप
और इस तरीके से समझा के नहीं बताया गया
होता तो मैं लाइव यह प्रूफ कर पाता लेकिन
आप में से शायद किसी ने भी पेड कोर्स नहीं
करा है तो कुछ नहीं कर सकते। ठीक है?
एज सर एज एन हैकर इडीआर इवेट करना
डिफिकल्ट है नहीं ऐसा नहीं है इडीआर को
इवेट किया जाता भी है इवेशन होती है इडीआर
इवज़
हां एज एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट आप
जो मैनेज्ड एसओसीस होते हैं मैनेज्ड
एसओसीस
उसके लिए काम कर सकते हो रिमोटली बट
मैनेज्ड अगर जो नहीं होते ना उस तब तो आप
नहीं कर
चलिए लेट्स मूव अहेड। आगे तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
समझते हैं ईडीआर वर्सेस ट्रेडिशनल
एंटीवायरसेस। क्योंकि ये कई लोगों के
दिमाग में होगा कि क्या है एक्सैक्टली इन
दोनों के बीच का डिफरेंस? तो इन दोनों के
बीच के एक्चुअल डिफरेंस को समझते हैं। ठीक
है? इडीआर वर्सेस ट्रेडिशनल एंटीवासेस।
ठीक है?
हां जो मैनेज्ड एसओसीस होते हैं एमएसएसपी
राइट राइट एमएसपी या एमएसएसपी जो भी है तो
उसके उस चीज के लिए आप एसओसी का अगर रोल
है आपका तो आप रिमोटली काम कर सकते हैं
अदरवाइज नहीं
तो
योर क्लास इज़ वेरी नॉलेजेबल थैंक यू सर यू
आर वेलकम वेलकम
शायद अभी पता नहीं वो है कि नहीं है बट एक
विपिन करके कोई था बंदा इसी सीरीज के
हमारे वो लर्नर हैं। उनका जॉब भी हो चुका
है। एंड ही टोल्ड इन द चैट एट द स्टार्ट।
एंड यह फर्स्ट जॉब है हमारे एसओसी 11
सीरीज के किसी लर्नर का। सो इट वाज़
एक्चुअली अ प्राउड मोमेंट। एक्चुअली यह
काफी हालांकि अ एक्साइटिंग एक्साइटेड एक
मोमेंट था। मजा आया। सुना तो काफी अच्छा
लगा कि चलो वो बंदे ने आके कम से कम चैट
में बोला है कि सर जॉब लगी है। ऐसी करिए।
एंड इट वाज़ वेरी गुड। रियली रियली वेरी
गुड अगर वो Lindin पे पोस्ट करता है तो हम
उसको रीपस्ट करेंगे तो आपको वहां भी पता
चल जाएगा।
चलिए ईडीआर वर्सेस ट्रेडिशनल एंटीवायरस
में क्या डिफरेंस है? ठीक है? फीचर्स की
बात करते हैं। देन ट्रेडिशनल एंटीवायरसेस
में देखेंगे। देन ईडीआर में देखेंगे सभी
लोग वापस। यस प्रोटीन प्रोटीन वाले में
लगा है। प्रोटीन ई गवर्नमेंट करके जो है
प्रोटीन इंफS
ओके
डिटेक्शन मेथड्स की हम बात करें तो
एंटीवासेस में सिग्नेचर बेस्ड होता है।
नोज़ व्हाट बैड फाइल्स लुक लाइक। सिग्नेचर
बेस्ड का मतलब बैड फाइल्स कैसे दिखते हैं?
उस पे यह काम करता है। बिहेवल्स में होते
हैं एंड पॉइंट्स का। नोज़ व्हाट बैड
एक्टर्स डू। बैड एक्टर्स या बैड जो
अटैकर्स होते हैं, वह एग्जैक्टली क्या
करते हैं, इस पे यह काम करता है। तो, यह
सिग्नेचर बेस पे यह सिग्नेचर प्लस
बिहेवियर दोनों पे ही काम करता है। उसके
बाद आते हैं डेटा रिटेंशन में। ओनली लॉग्स
व्हेन समथिंग इज ब्लॉक्ड। यह तभी लॉगिंग
करता है जब कोई चीज को ब्लॉक करता है
एंटीवायरस आपका। बट एंटीवायरस के अलावा
अगर इडीआर की बात करें तो यह लॉग्स
एवरीथिंग कंटीन्यूअसली। मतलब हर चीज को
लॉक करता है। कंटीन्यूसली लॉक करता रहता
है। इसका कोई काम नहीं है। लॉगिंग लॉगिंग
करता रहता है। विजिबिलिटी की बात करें।
ब्लाइंड टू सोफिस्टिकेटेड फाइललिस और
लिविंग ऑफ द लैंड अटैक्स। मतलब जो फाइललेस
मैलवेस होते हैं जो मेमोरी में एक्सक्यूशन
होती है। ऐसे अटैक्स को रोकना थोड़ा
मुश्किल है एंटीवायरसेस के लिए। एंड पॉइंट
सिक्योरिटीज के लिए, एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
रिस्पांस इडीआर्स के लिए, फुल विजिबिलिटी
इनू मेमोरी इंजेक्शंस एंड स्क्रिप्ट्स।
यानी कि मेमोरी बेस्ड अटैक्स, मेमोरी
इंजेक्शंस, मेमोरी वाले अटैक्स जो होते
हैं, स्क्रिप्ट जो होते हैं, उन पर यह
पूरा कंट्रोल उनका पूरा प्रोटेक्शन ये
प्रोवाइड आपके करते हैं।
रिस्पांस ऑप्शंस में हम बात करें तो यह
फाइल को क्वारेंटाइन या डिलीट कर देते
हैं। सिंगल फाइल को और एंड पॉइंट इडीआर्स
जो होते हैं वो क्या करते हैं? पूरे होस्ट
को पूरे एंड पॉइंट या पूरे मशीन को
आइसोलेट कर सकते हैं। नेटवर्क से हटा सकते
हैं। प्रोसेससेस को टर्मिनेट कर सकते हैं।
रिमोट शेल के थ्रू होस्ट कंप्यूटर से
कनेक्ट हो के उस पे भी एक्शनंस परफॉर्म कर
सकते हैं। तो ये सारा कुछ ईडीआर कर सकता
है। तो ईडीआर वे मोर एडवांस देन आपका
एंटीवायरस। अब यहां पे फीचर बाय फीचर
कंपैरिजन भी करते हैं। दोनों के बीच में
एंटीवायरस और ईडीआर के बीच में। ये तो
मैंने नॉर्मल अ जो अ कंपैरिजन था एक
नॉर्मल कंपैरिजन फीचर वाइज़ ओनली एक नॉर्मल
जो कंपैरिजन था वो करा। अब यहां पे हम
फीचर व फीचर थोड़ा डिटेल कंपैरिजन करते हैं
तो आपको और भी ज्यादा क्लियर समझ में आएगा
दोनों के बीच के डिफरेंस। ठीक है?
ओके। फीचर प्राइमरी गोल
प्रिवेंशन। एंटीवायरस का प्राइमरी गोल है
प्रिवेंशन। स्टॉप नॉन मैलवेयर फ्रॉम
एग्जीक्यूटिव। जो कोई नॉन मैलवेयर है उसको
एग्ज़क्यूट होने से रोकता है। एंड पॉइंट
ईडीआर क्या कहते हैं? डिटेक्शन एंड
रिस्पांस का भी काम होता है। स्पॉट एक्टिव
थ्रेट्स एंड प्रोवाइड टूल टू फाइट देम।
थ्रेट्स को तुरंत क्या करना? स्पॉट करना
और उसको उड़ा देना। उसको उससे लड़ना, फाइट
करना। डेटा लॉगिंग ओनली लॉक्स एन इवेंट
व्हेन नोन वायरस इज़ ब्लॉक्ड। ये मैंने
पहले ही बताया कि तभी लॉक होता है जब कोई
नॉन वायरस होता है वहां पे। और यह
कंटिन्यू 24 * 7 जो है लॉक करता ही रहता
है। क्वारेंटाइन डिलीट फाइल यह आइसोलेट
वगैरह करता है। यह भी आपको पता चल गया है।
अब यहां पे फाइललेस अटैक में भी मैलवेयर
जो होता है जो ये मैंने ऑलरेडी बता दिया
है यहां पे कि मेमोरी में कोई अगर आता है
उसका है तो कैन नॉट डिटेक्ट अटैक्स रनिंग
प्योरली इन सिस्टम मेमोरी। तो मेलिशियस
पावर शेल स्क्रिप्ट्स हो गई या फिर आपका
फाइलिस मैलवेयर हो गया तो उसको डिटेक्ट ये
नहीं कर पाता है। ये भाई सब चीजें डिटेक्ट
हमारे करते हैं। हिस्टोरिकल डेटा की बात
करें तो यहां पे इफ एन इंसिडेंट हैपेंस
एंटीवायरस के केस में यू कैन नॉट ट्रेस
हाउ द मैलवेयर गॉट देयर। तो आप ट्रेस नहीं
कर सकते कि मैलवेयर यहां तक पहुंचा कैसे
है। बट इडीआर में क्योंकि वो पूरा
हिस्टोरिकल व्यू प्रोवाइड करता है। जब से
वो फाइल आई है एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है। उसने
किसी और को एग्जीक्यूट किया। वो सारा
हिस्ट्री है उसके पास। तो वो उसका ट्रेस
बैकक करके आप वहां तक पहुंच सकते हो।
पेसेंट ज़ीरो तक कोर पे कि एग्जैक्टली वह
कहां से शुरू हुई थी फाइल। तो पूरा का
पूरा व्यू आपको मिलता है। यह पूरा डिफरेंस
है। अब यहां पे अब बात करते हैं एक एक
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो को समझते हैं।
एनालाइजिंग द इडीआर प्रोसेस फ्री और यह
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो है। तो इस चीज पे
पूरा फोकस रहना चाहिए आपका। तभी समझ में
आएगा। अभी हम समझेंगे कि आपका जो एसआईएम
टूल है उसने जस्ट एक हाई सीवियरिटी अलर्ट
ट्रे किया है। एक सिनेरियो है उसको मैं
पूरा एक्सप्लेन करूंगा ताकि आपको पूरा का
पूरा यह चीज जो है ना समझ में आ जाए अच्छे
से। सस्पिशियस पावर शेल एग्जीक्यूशन
डिटेक्टेड। यह एक अलर्ट आया है ईडीआर के
द्वारा आपके आप आपके लिए एज एन एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट। ठीक है? गॉट इट? सस्िशियस पावर
सेल एग्जीक्यूटेड
एग्जीक्यूशन डिटेक्ट हुआ है। अब यहां पे
क्या है? वी नीड टू फिगर आउट हाउ दिस
हैपेंड। हमें यह फिगर करना है। व्हाट द
अटैकर डीड? अटैकर ने क्या किया? एंड हाउ
टू स्टॉप देम बिफोर दे मूव लेटरली। मतलब
नेटवर्क के अंदर दूसरे डिवाइसेस के अंदर
भी यह मूव कर जाए। उसके पहले हमें रोकना
है उनको। ठीक है? टू डू दिस वी ओपन आवर
एडीआर कंसोल। हमें अपना एडीआर कंसोल ओपन
करेंगे। क्लाउड स्ट्राइक ऑफ़ एल्कन हो गया
या सेंटिनल हो गया कोई सा भी। एंड पुल अप
द प्रोसेस ट्री एंड प्रोसेस ट्री हम
देखेंगे। एडियर कंसोल में एक ऑप्शन होता
है प्रोसेस ट्री का। उस पे जाएंगे प्रोसेस
ट्री को देखने के लिए फॉर द
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड एसेट। एसेट्स को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज एसेट को देखेंगे। द इडियर
गिव्स अस द फैमिली ट्री ऑफ़ द एग्जीक्यूशन।
पूरा एग्जीक्यूशन का फैमिली ट्री दिखाता
है। शोइंग अस द एग्जैक्टली हु स्पिसड हुम
मतलब किसने किसको स्टार्ट किया है। किस
प्रोसेस ने किस प्रोसेस को स्टार्ट किया
है। तो कुछ इस तरीके का प्रोसेस ट्री आपको
देखने को मिलता है एडीआर कंसोल में।
ठीक है?
अब पहला outlook exc एक ईमेल क्लाइंट है
वह एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है। ठीक है भाई आपका
चलेगा। दूसरा उसने Chrome.exc को स्पॉन
किया यानी एग्जीक्यूट किया। यूजर क्लिक अ
लिंक ओपन ब्राउज़र एग्जीक्यूट किया। ठीक
है? अब उसने invoice 9932.pdf.exc
इस फाइल को डाउनलोड किया। डाउनलोड फाइल
मैस्क्यू रीडिंग एज अ पीडीएफ इस फाइल को
डाउनलोड किया। अब यह फाइल ऐसा लग रहा है
जैसे कोई पीडीएफ फाइल है बट लास्ट में
एक्स एक्सटेंशन भी आप देख रहे हैं फोर्थ
cmd exc कमांड लाइन रैपर अब इसको जब हमने
डाउनलोड किया इस फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट किया
तो इसने कमांड प्र्प को स्टार्ट किया और
उसके बाद इसने स्टार्ट किया powerltexc को
तो powers exc हफन एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी
बाईपास इंक्रिप्शन ठीक है www
यानी एक मलिश स्क्रिप्ट यानी कि पावर शेल
को स्टार्ट किया पॉलिसी एग्जीक्यूशन
पॉलिसी बाईपास यहां यहां पे कमांड रन हुआ
इंक्रिप्शन को ईएनसी के लिए एंड यहां पे
इंक्रिप्शन एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी इंक्रिप्शन
का पॉलिसी बाईपास किया एंड यहां पे एक
मॉलिशियस स्क्रिप्ट रन करने का कमांड आया
तो बेसिकली एक पावर शेल के कमांड को रन
किया जा रहा है जहां पे एक मॉलिशियस
स्क्रिप्ट को चलाने का कमांड डाला जा रहा
है पावर शेल के थ्रू एक स्क्रिप्ट चलाई जा
रही है पावर शेल के थ्रू क्योंकि ये
स्क्रिप्ट चलाने की कैपेबिलिटीज आपके पावर
शेल के अंदर में है तो इसने ये पावर शेल
को एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया तो ये पूरा का पूरा
जो है प्रोसेस ट्री स्टार्ट हो चुका
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल तो इसने क्या किया आपका
एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी बाईपास कमांड चला के
इंक्रिप्शन जो है उसको स्टार्ट बंद कर
दिया और आपका जो है मलिश स्क्रिप्ट को
यहां पे चला दिया है। अब एग्जैक्टली क्या
हो रहा है यहां पे? एग्जैक्टली यहां पे
क्या हो रहा है? अब इस पूरे प्रोसेस थ्री
को जब आप देखोगे तो इसको समझने की जरूरत
है। जब आप समझ जाओगे तो आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा कि एग्जजेक्टली किस तरीके से यह
पूरा का पूरा काम कर रहा है। ठीक है? चलिए
अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब एक एसओसी एनालिस्ट
का ब्रेकडाउन क्या होगा इस पूरे प्रोसेस
का? एज एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट आप किस तरीके से
इसको ब्रेकडाउन करेंगे? तीन पार्ट्स में
ब्रेकडाउन करेंगे। एक आउटलुक एंड क्रोम द
डबल एक्सटेंशन ट्रिक और द पावर शेल कमांड।
ठीक है? इस तरीके से यहां पर अब यहां पे
पहला आउटलुक एंड Chrome को देखते हैं। द
यूजर रिसीव्ड एन ईमेल क्लिक द लिंक एंड
डाउनलोडेड अ फाइल। ठीक है? यूजर ने एक
लिंक रिसीव किया ईमेल पे। आउटलुक पे उसने
उस पे क्लिक किया और उसने Chrome को
स्टार्ट किया और Chrome से वह फाइल
डाउनलोड कर ली। डबल एक्सटेंशन ट्री लुक
क्लोजली एट स्टेप थ्री। थर्ड स्टेप पे आप
क्लोजली देखेंगे।
थर्ड स्टेप पे आप देखेंगे इनवॉइस ये वाली
इसने क्या किया है?
द फाइल इज़ नेम इनवॉइस 9932.pdf.exe
windows ऑफेन हाइड्स द.ex एक्सटेंशन बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट। सो द यूजर थॉट दे वेयर ओपनिंग अ
रेगुलर पीडीएफ। दिस इज़ क्लासिक फिशिंग। तो
नॉर्मली Windows में exc जो एक्सटेंशन है
वो हिडन रहती है। आप सबको पता होना चाहिए
यह बात कि extc एक्सटेंशन हिडन होती है।
सीधा फाइल का नाम होता है और स्टार्ट होती
है। ठीक है? बट यहां पे इस केस में क्या
हो रहा है कि यहां पे लास्ट में exc लगाया
हुआ एक exc फाइल एग्जीक्यूट की गई है। तो
ऐसा exc हाइड हो जाएगी। तो जनरली ऐसा
लगेगा कि ये पीडीएफ फाइल है। बट
बैकग्राउंड में वो exc हो रहा होगा। द
पावर शेल कमांड द कमांड कंटेन्स फ्लैग्स
लाइक एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी बायपास टेल्स
विंडोज़ टू इग्नोर सिक्योरिटी रेस्ट्रिकशंस
ऑन स्क्रिप्ट्स मतलब आप एग्जीक्यूशन
पॉलिसी को इग्नोर कीजिए जो भी आपका
सिक्योरिटी आप जैसे Windows डिफेंडर या
कोई सा भी एग्जीक्यूशन जो कोई भी आप
सिक्योरिटी टूल यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो उसको
इग्नोर कीजिए। हफन ईएनसी अह स्टैंड्स फॉर
इनकोडेड मतलब इंक्रिप्शन अगर कोई है किसी
तरह का इंक्रिप्शन लगा है, किसी तरह का
इनकोडिंग लगा है, उसको आप इग्नोर कीजिए,
हटाइए। मीनिंग द अटैकर ऑफ फसकेटेड द
स्क्रिप्ट इंटू अ जॉयंट स्ट्रिंग ऑफ रैंडम
गिबर्स लाइक www बी डॉट डॉट डॉट टू हाइड
व्हाट इट डज़ फ्रॉम द बेसिक टेक्स्ट
फ़्टर्स। सो बेसिकली इसने एक रैंडम एक
गार्बेज टेक्स्ट स्ट्रिंग का एक गार्बेज
भर के रखा है और इसने बोला है कि भैया कोई
भी इनकोडिंग इंक्रिप्शन है किसी भी तरह का
सिक्योरिटी उसको इग्नोर किया जाए और इस
स्क्रिप्ट को हमारे रन कर दिया जाए। एंड
इसने बेवकूफ बनाने की कोशिश करी आपके
किसको? एडीआर को। तो यह पूरा प्रोसेस चला
है। यह पूरा प्रोसेस जो है यह पूरा
प्रोसेस जो है वो यहां पे यह तीन पार्ट
में एनालिस्ट ने डिकोड किया है या
ब्रेकडाउन किया है। अब हम बढ़ते हैं कि ये
कैसे काम करता है। डिकोडिंग द पेलोड एंड
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग बिहेवियर। अब इस पेड को
डिकोड करके हम इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे। कैसे?
यूजिंग आवरीडिया टूल वी डिस वी डिकोडेड द
ऑफ़ फस्टेटेड स्क्रिप्ट। जो स्क्रिप्ट
इनकोड की गई थी अटैकर के द्वारा जो यहां
पे ये चलाई जा रही है ना स्क्रिप्ट ये जो
आप देख रहे हैं मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट वी डॉट
डॉट डॉट कोई सा भी कुछ भी रैंडम उसमें डाल
के एक स्क्रिप्ट को हाइड किया है तो इस
स्क्रिप्ट को चलाया जा रहा है तो अब हमारे
इडीआर ने हमारे इडीआर टूल ने इस स्क्रिप्ट
को डिकोड किया है। ठीक है?
इस स्क्रिप्ट को डिकोड किया है। वी सी द
स्क्रिप्ट ट्राइंग टू एग्जीक्यूट टू
स्पेसिफिक एकशंस ऑन द होस्ट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम। अब जब डिकोड किया है हमारे इंडिया
टूल ने तो यह दिख रहा है कि यह स्क्रिप्ट
दो एकशंस को परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश कर रही
है होस्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को। क्या एक्शंस
है दो? एक है रजिस्ट्री मॉडिफिकेशन। दूसरा
है एल्स एस डंपिंग। पहला एग्जीक्यूशन कर
रही है रजिस्ट्री को मॉडिफाई करने की
कोशिश। क्या कर रही है ये? इट राइट्स अ की
टू इस लोकेशन पे एक की को ये डाल रही है।
कौन सा लोकेशन है? एचके सीयू यानी कि आपका
एच के करंट यूजर जो आता है वो उसके अंदर
सॉफ्टवेयर Microsoft Windows करंट वर्जन
रन यानी कि ये ऑटो रन वाली जगह पे डाल रही
है। यानी कि सिस्टम जैसे ही स्टार्ट होगा
ये ऑटोमेटिक रन करेगा। जैसे ही सिस्टम को
तुम रिस्टार्ट करोगे रिबूूट करोगे
ऑटोमेटिक स्टार्ट होगा। दिस इज़ अ
पर्सिस्टेंस मैकेनिज़्म। पर्सिस्टेंस वाली
है। बात आ गई। इट इंश्योरर्स दैट इवन इफ द
यूजर रिबूूट्स देयर लैपटॉप। जैसा मैंने
बोला द मैलवेयर लॉन्चेस अगेन ऑटोमेटिकली
क्योंकि ये इस लोकेशन पे है रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर रन इस लोकेशन पे कोई सी भी ऐसी
स्क्रिप्ट या फाइल है तो वो ऑटोमेटिकली
रिबूूट पे रन करता है। ठीक है? ऑफ
फस्केटेड का क्या मीन है? ऑफ फसकेटेड का
मतलब होता है कि अ इनकोडेड मान लो। मतलब
इनकोड किया हुआ उसमें रैंडम चीज़ गार्बेज
डाल के और उसको अनडिटेक्टेबल बनाने की
कोशिश की जाने वाली है। यह पूरा इसने
रजिस्ट्री में यह पहला चाह रहा है
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर रन के अंदर डाल देना।
दूसरा है एलsस डंपिंग। यह काम करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। स्क्रिप्ट्स अटेम्प्ट टू
रीड मेमोरी स्पेस फॉर एलs.ex। एलsस जो है
एलs.ex एलs के बारे में मैंने पहले ही
बताया हुआ है कि ये एक ऐसा
प्रोसेस है जो कि आपके Windows के
ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए अ आपका लायबल होता है।
Windows ऑथेंटिकेशन
को
अलऊ करता है। Windows ऑथेंटिकेशन इसी के
थ्रू काम करती है। ठीक है? तो एलsस exc ये
जो है जो कि जिसका फुल फॉर्म बेसिकली लोकल
सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम सर्विस होता
है। तो इसके मेमोरी स्पेस को इन मेमोरी
इसी एलsस के मेमोरी के अंदर में यूज़र्स के
अ जो पासवर्ड्स हैं, टोकंस हैं वो सारे
स्टर्ड होते हैं। द अटैकर इज़ ट्राइंग टू
स्टील क्रेडेंशियल्स टू हाईजैक अदर
आइडेंटिटीज़। एंड अटैकर इसके थ्रू
क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुराना चाह रहा है। यह
चीज है। तो, यह दो चीजें यह कर रहा है
स्क्रिप्ट। इससे यह पता चलता है। अब आगे
की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। अब हम इमीडिएट रिस्पांस
लेंगे। सो, सबसे पहले हमने क्या किया?
हमने
एनालाइज किया।
हमने एनालाइज किया। ठीक है? दूसरे ऑप्शन
में हमने डिटेक्ट किया और इन्वेस्टिगेट
किया। ठीक है? तीसरे स्टेप में हम यहां पे
रिस्पॉन्ड करेंगे। रिस्पांस देंगे। एडीआर
का यही तो तीन मेन कोर फीचर है।
विजिबिलिटी,
डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस। विजिबिलिटी,
डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस। वीडीआर
हां, अब हम रिस्पांस करने की बारी आ जाती
है। रिस्पांस में देखो। द टैकर हैज़ एक्टिव
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन एंड इज़ ट्राइंग टू
हार्वेस्ट पासवर्ड।
पासवर्ड हार्वेस्ट करना चाह रहा है। वी
कैन नॉट अफोर्ड टू वेट। हम अब वेट नहीं कर
सकते। तो वी एग्जीक्यूट आवर एडीआर
कंटेनमेंट प्लेबुक डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम द
कंसोल। अब हमें ईडीआर कंटेनमेंट जो है वो
शुरू कर देंगे डायरेक्ट। तो क्या-क्या
हमारे पास ऑप्शंस हैं? नेटवर्क आइसोलेशंस।
तो हमारे को दो सेकंड लगेंगे नेटवर्क से।
हम जो है एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
हेलो रेखांश राजपूत कौन सी मैसेज आपने
भेजे थे रेखांश WhatsApp के ऊपर एक बार
बता दीजिए क्योंकि WhatsApp जो होती है वो
कंपनी हमारी कंपनी का WhatsApp होता है तो
मैं हमेशा एक्टिव उस पे नहीं होता हूं।
हमारी टीम के लोग होते हैं जो कभी ऐसाेंट
होता है तो मुझे वह इंफॉर्मेशन बताई जाती
है। बाकी टीम के लोग मैनेज करते हैं। तो
आपने क्या मैसेज किया था एक्सैक्टली बता
दीजिए किस टाइप का मैसेज था। ठीक है?
ओके।
सो सबसे पहला यहां पे नेटवर्क आइसोलेशन।
ठीक है? टेक टू सेकंड्स। वी हिट द आइसोलेट
होस्ट बटन ऑन इंडिया। इडिया के ऊपर एक बटन
होता है आइसोलेट होस्ट बस एक बटन काम खत्म
एक बटन काम खत्म द लैपटॉप इज़ इंस्टेंटली
कट अप फ्रॉम द लोकल ऑफिस नेटवर्क एंड द
इंटरनेट लैपटॉप तुरंत नेटवर्क से लोकल
नेटवर्क से और इंटरनेट से कट डाउन हो जाता
है द अटैकर्स कमांड कंट्रोल सर्वर कनेक्शन
ड्रॉप्स अटैकर का जो C2 सर्वर होता है
कमांड कंट्रोल सर्वर वह बिल्कुल ही बंद हो
जाता है दे कैन नो लगर सेंड कमांड्स और
पुल स्टोलॉन डेट अब वह किसी तरह का कोई
कमांड भी इशू नहीं कर सकते और डाटा भी
नहीं ले सकते क्योंकि जब नेटवर्क
कनेक्टिविटी खत्म हो गई तो कुछ नहीं कर
सकते बेचारे प्रोसेस टर्मिनेशन टेक्स 5
सेकंड्स वी इशू अ कमांड थ्रू द इंडिया टू
किल द रनिंग पावर शेलxc एंड cmdexc
प्रोसेससेस कंप्लीटली हल्टिंग द एक्टिव
मैल स्क्रिप्ट्स अब जैसे कि उस मैल ने
पावर शेल को स्टार्ट किया था सीएमडी को
स्टार्ट किया था अब इन दोनों प्रोसेस को
ही अगर
हमने
स्टॉप कर दिया व्हाट विल हैपन सिंपल
तो यहां पे क्या होगा? प्रोसेस को
टर्मिनेट किया जाएगा। राइट?
रेखांश ने क्या बोला? एडमिन पैनल रिपोर्ट
किया था आपकी वेबसाइट का उन्होंने। ठीक
है। हां हां यस यस रेखांश। आई नो अबाउट
दिस। अगर रिस्पांस आपको नहीं मिला है तो
डोंट वरी रिस्पांस आपको मिल जाएगा। एंड
डेफिनेटली अगर आपको बोला गया है कि हॉल ऑफ
फेम हॉल ऑफ फेम नहीं मिलता है। एप्रिसिएशन
लेटर मिलती है क्योंकि हम किसी भी तरह का
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोज़र प्रोग्राम नहीं
चलाते हैं। ना तो हम कोई भी बग बाउंड्री
प्रोग्राम चलाते हैं। बट हमारे पास अगर
कोई वैलिड रिपोर्ट आ जाती है और कोई
सीवियर रिपोर्ट होती है तो ऑब्वियसली हम
लेटर ऑफ एप्रिसिएशन देते हैं। तो आपको
लेटर ऑफ़ एप्रिसिएशन जो है वो मिलेगा। तो
आपको रिस्पांस मिल जाएगा। कभी हो सकता है
कभी-कभी रिस्पांस क्योंकि हमारे पास जो
हमारा बिनेस WhatsApp होता है हमारे पास
एक दिन के हजारों मैसेज आते हैं। लिटरली
थाउजेंड्स में मैसेज आते हैं। ऐसा नहीं है
कि चार पांच 10 20 50 100 मैसेज आते हैं
और वो नए-नए मैसेज ऊपर आते हैं। बाकी पीछे
बाकी ऐसे ऐसे होते हैं। तो कई मैसेजेस छूट
जाते हैं। ऐसा भी होता है। हो सकता है
आपका रह गया हो या जो भी हो व्हाटएवर
ध्यान नहीं दिया हो। तो आपको जो है वो
लेटर एप्रिसिएशन मिलेगा। एंड थैंक यू वेरी
मच। मैं आपको फिर से बोल देता हूं फॉर
मेकिंग प्लेटफार्म सिक्योर। आप जैसे लोग
जो हैं वह रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोज़र जो करते
हैं कभी भी आप किसी वनेबिलिटी को आप किसी
भी प्लेटफार्म किसी भी वेबसाइट या किसी भी
जगह पे जब भी कोई आपको वनेबिलिटी मिलती है
तो रिस्पांसिबली आपको रिपोर्ट करना चाहिए
ना कि उसका गलत यूज़ करना चाहिए। क्योंकि
जब गलत आप यूज़ करते हैं और आप उसके लिए
ऑथराइज़्ड भी नहीं है तो आपके ऊपर लीगल
एक्शन तो होता ही होता है। साथ में वो एक
गलत प्रैक्टिस है। बट आप रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
डिस्क्लोज़ करते हैं। तो ये आपको एथिकली शो
करता है वहां पे। राइट?
ओके सर डे 14 से ऑनवर्ड पीडीएफ डाउनलोड
नहीं हो रही है। काइंडली वो दोबारा शेयर
कर दें। ठीक है। ठीक है। ठीक है। शेयर हो
जाएगी। दूसरा यहां पे प्रोसेस टर्मिनेशन
ये आपने देख लिया है। तीसरी जो है यहां पे
रेमडीएशन एंड क्लीन अप जिसमें 10 मिनट का
लगभग समय लगता है। तो यूजिंग द लाइव
रिस्पांस रिमोट शेल वी सिक्योरली कनेक्ट
टू द आइसोलेटेड मशीन। अब जो मशीन है जो
आइसोलेट कर दी गई है उसे सिक्योरली कनेक्ट
किया जाता है। लाइव रिस्पांस रिमोट शेल के
थ्रू वी डिलीट द डाउनलोडेड इनवॉइस 932
pdf.xt फाइल एंड स्क्रब द पर्सिस्टेंट
रजिस्ट्री की द स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएटेड। तो अब
क्योंकि हमने उस नेटवर्क से उस इंटरनेट
कनेक्शन से नेटवर्क से उस कंप्यूटर को या
लैपटॉप को हमने हटा दिया है। हमने क्या
किया है? उसको आइसोलेट कर दिया है। तो अब
हमारा रेमिडेशन के स्टेप में क्या होगा
भैया? कि हम एक रिमोट रिस्पांस शेल के
थ्रू क्या करेंगे? कनेक्ट करेंगे। मारेंगे
और जो चेंज किया गया था रजिस्ट्री में
उसको हटा देंगे। यह प्रोसेस है भैया आपका
यहां पे इमीडिएट रिस्पांस टेक। तो तीन
स्टेप आपको करने होते हैं। आपका
विजिबिलिटी डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस एंड
दैट्स इट। कहानी समाप्त हो जाती है यहां
पे। एज सिंपल एज दैट। क्लियर? आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा। राइट? करेक्ट। बिल्कुल
करेक्ट। नेक्स्ट है क्लोजिंग द लूप। अब
पोस्ट इंसिडेंट। अब यह सारा काम हो गया।
इंसिडेंट आपका कंटेनमेंट हो गया। आपने रोक
लिया एक अटैक को सब कुछ हो गया। अब इसके
बाद क्या? इसके बाद भी एक चीज़ होती है जो
आपको समझनी है। क्या है यहां पे? नाउ दैट
द एसेट इज़ सेफ। नाउ अब एंड पॉइंट आपका सेफ
है। वी डोंट जस्ट स्टॉप हियर। हमें यहीं
पे नहीं रुक जाना कि भैया एसेट सेफ है
आपका या आपका एसेट बिल्कुल वो है। तो अब
यहां पे रुक जाओ। नहीं ऐसा नहीं आपको करना
है। वी पाइव टू द अदर कॉनंसेप्ट्स वी
लर्नड अर्लियर टू इंश्योर टोटल इरेडिकेशन।
अब हमें टोटल इरेडिकेट करना है। बिल्कुल
ही हटाना है एकदम। तो सबसे पहले आइडेंटिटी
चेक वी पाइवट टू आवर आइडेंटिटी टूल दैट इज
Microsoft इंट्रा आईडी। अब यहां पे
Microsoft इंट्रा आईडी या एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का यूज़ करेंगे हम जो हमारा
आइडेंटिटी टूल है। एंड फोर्स अ पासवर्ड
रिसेट एंड सेशन रिवोकेशन फॉर दिस यूजर। अब
हम यहां पे ये फोर्स करेंगे कि इस यूजर के
लिए जिस पे जिसके थ्रू ये अटैक हुआ था
उसका फोर्सफुली पासवर्ड रिसेट हो जाए।
सेशन जो है वो खत्म सारे सेशंस को एंड कर
दिया जाए। जस्ट इन द केस द अटैकर मैनेज टू
स्क्रेप देयर क्रेडेंशियल्स बिफोर वी किल
द प्रोसेस। तो कहीं बाय चांस उसका
क्रेडेंशियल्स उसने चुरा लिया हो या निकाल
लिया हो हमने प्रोसेस किल किया उसके थ्रू
उसके पहले ही अटैकर ने अगर कोई
क्रेडेंशियल निकाल लिया सेंसिटिव चीज़
निकाल ली तो उस केस में क्या करेंगे? हम
पासवर्ड रिसेट कर देंगे और सेशन को
बिल्कुल क्लीन कर देंगे, क्लियर कर देंगे।
उसके बाद आती है वर्कब lookup। द नेक्स्ट
थिंग इज़ वर्क बुक lookup। क्या होता है?
वी क्रिएट अ लुकअप। वी क्रिएट अ लुकअप
कंटेनिंग द मशियस फाइल हैश एंड द IP
एड्रेस स्क्रिप्ट ट्राइड टू टॉक टू। वी रन
अ ग्लोबल क्वेरी अक्रॉस आवर एसओसी वर्कबुक
टू सी इफ एनी अदर मशीन इन द एंटायर
एंटरप्राइज़ हैज़ डाउनलोडेड द सेम फाइल। तो
हमने एक वर्क बुक बनाया बेसिकली lookup जो
वर्क बुक lookup जिसके बारे में मैंने
आपको लास्ट क्लास में बताई थी तो वो
lookuअप का lookup मतलब एक डायरेक्टरी
बनाया ठीक है एक डायरेक्टरी हमने बनाया उस
डायरेक्टरी में हमने इस पर्टिकुलर
स्क्रिप्ट का#श
जो है वो डाला और आईपी एड्रेस की कॉलन डाल
दी एक कॉलन उसका हैश और आईपी का कॉलन बना
दिया और हमने उसको पूरे अपने जो है
नेटवर्क में रन कर दिया और देखा कि और
कौन-कौन सी मशीन है नेटो के अंदर में
जिसने इस फाइल को डाउनलोड किया अगर है तो
उसको आइडेंटिफाई करो फिर से उस पे वही
प्रोसेस करके किल करो डील करो फेल करो
खत्म करो तो ये पूरा प्रोसेस होता है तो
ये पोस्ट इंसिडेंट या इसी तरह का बिल्कुल
कोई एपीटी एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट जैसा
सिनेरियो जो है ऐसा ना हो कोई एपीटीज ऐसा
ना हो कि वह सिस्टम में आपके नेटवर्क में
रह रहे रह जाए लॉन्ग टर्म के लिए और फिर
आगे चलके गड़बड़ी पैदा कर ले। सो दिस इज
हाउ एन इडीआर ट्रांसफॉर्म्स अ पोटेंशियल
कंपनी वाइड डिजास्टर इनू अ 15 मिनट
कंटेनमेंट कंटेन इंसिडेंट। ये है इडीआर की
पावर।
ठीक है?
समझ में आ गया ये सारी चीज़। अब देखो यहां
पे ईडीआर और एसआईएम कनेक्ट कैसे है? कुछ
लोगों का क्वेश्चन था ईडीआर और एसआईएम को
लेके। अब उस चीज को मैं यहां पे बताता
हूं। विद इन अ नेटवर्क विद इन अ नेटवर्क
यू विल सी फायर वाल्स आपको फायरवल
दिखेंगे। डीएलपीस दो डेटा लॉस प्रिवेंशन
सिस्टम्स होते हैं वो दिखेंगे। ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी गेटवेज ईमेल सिक्योरिटी के लिए
जो होते हैं वो सब दिखेंगे। आईएएम्स
आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट के
सिस्टम्स दिखेंगे। ईडीआर एंड पॉइंट
डिटेक्शन रिस्पांस सिस्टम लिखेंगे जिसके
बारे में हम अभी पढ़ रहे हैं। एंड अदर
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस प्रोटेक्टिंग द डिफरेंट
कॉमोनेंट्स ऑफ द नेटवर्क। अब ये सारे जो
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस है ना ये अलग-अलग
नेटवर्क के कॉमोनेंट्स को प्रोटेक्ट करते
हैं। ये अलग-अलग नेटवर्क के कॉम्पोनेंट्स
को प्रोटेक्ट करते हैं। ठीक है? सब
अलग-अलग एक यहां ईडीआर है। यहां से ईमेल
सिक्योरिटी गेटवे है। यहां डीएलपीस है।
यहां फायर वाल लगे हुए हैं। यहां पे
आईएम्स लगे हैं। ये सब कर रहे हैं। टू
मिनिमाइज द एफर्ट एंड मैक्सिमाइज द
एफिशिएंसी।
ऑल दी सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस आर इंटीग्रेटेड
विद अ एसआईएम।
सिक्योरिटी इनेशन एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट। तो
यह सारे डीएलपीस आर डाटा लॉस एंड
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम जो डाटा लॉस के लिए
जनरली यूज़ में लिया जाता है। उसको उनको
डाटा लॉस से बचाने के लिए प्रिवें
प्रिवेंट करने के लिए ये सारे सिक्योरिटी
सोशल उसको मिला दिया गया और एक जगह ला के
रख दिया गया और उस एक जगह को हम बोलते हैं
एसआईएम सिक्योरिटी इंफॉर्मेशन एंड इवेंट
मैनेजमेंट। सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड चीजें
भी और इवेंट से रिलेटेड चीजें भी वो सब
होगा। तो एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन के अंदर सब
इंटीग्रेट कर दिया। दैट बिकम्स द सेंट्रल
पॉइंट ऑफ इन्वेस्टिगेट इन्वेस्टिगेशन फॉर
द एनालिस्ट। इसीलिए एसआईएम बहुत पावरफुल
होती है। एसआईएम के अंदर ही आपके एडीआर
ऑपरेट करते हैं। आपके आईएम्स ऑपरेट करते
हैं। ईमेल सिक्योरिटीज ऑपरेट करते हैं।
फायर वॉल्स डी के एग्जीकशंस डीएलपी ये सब
ऑपरेट करते हैं।
राइट? हां, एसआईएम इज़ अ ह्यूज थिंग। उसका
पार्ट है ईडीआर लेकिन ईडीआर इंडिपेंडेंटली
भी ऑपरेट करता है। ऐसा नहीं है कि ईडीआर
इंडिपेंडेंट ईडीआर पर ईडीआर की अपनी
कैपेबिलिटीज है कि वो इंडिपेंडेंटली किसी
भी थ्रेट को एनालाइज करके डिटेक्ट करके
रिसोंड कर सकता है। लेकिन क्योंकि हमें एक
एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में यूज़ करना है ईडीआर
को तो उसको हमने एसआईएम के अंदर ही
इंटीग्रेट कर दिया। बाकी दूसरे सिक्योरिटी
सॉलशंस के साथ ताकि हमारा सारा जो भी
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन है एक साथ एक छत के
नीचे ऑपरेट और काम कर सके और एक बेटर जो
है सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइड कर सके। दैट्स इट।
ये पूरा का पूरा कांसेप्ट था। आई होप आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा।
एवरीथिंग डन। तो ये पीपीटी का पार्ट तो
यहां पे डन है। इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं। इसकी जरूरत हमें नहीं है। अब मैं आ
जाता हूं हमारे ट्राईकमी
के ऊपर भैया। ठीक है? हम आते हैं ट्राईकमी
के ऊपर। तो ट्राईकमी में भी जो भी जो भी
चीजें हैं यहां पे मैंने सारी चीजें
ऑलमोस्ट कवर कर दी है। ठीक है? यहां पे
रिस्पांस आपने देख लिया। यहां पे ये तो
क्वेश्चंस है। ये आपके वॉक थ्रू के
क्वेश्चंस वगैरह हैं। ये आप अपना पढ़ के
सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा। कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है।
पढ़ेंगे तो सॉल्व हो जाएगा। सिंपल सा फंडा
है। ठीक है?
अब
बियोंड द एंटीवायरस वही चीज है कि
एंटीवायरस और ईडीआर कैसे अलग हैं? क्यों
अलग हैं? क्या एग्जैक्टली करते हैं? तो यह
चीजें यहां पे दी गई है। तो आप देख सकते
हैं ये स्टेप्स ये जो प्रोसेससेस है ये जो
डिफरेंस है ये सारी डिफरेंसेस मैंने जो है
वो आपको बता दी है। जो भी यहां पे
डिफरेंसेस यहां बताए गए हैं। उसके बाद
ईडीआर कैसे काम करती है? यह भी मैंने आपको
पूरा प्रोसेस बता दिया है। एजेंट्स के
बारे में बता दिया। इडीआर कंसोल वगैरह के
बारे में बता दिया। कुछ इस तरीके से कंसोल
होता है। यह क्लाउड सॉरी यह क्राउड
स्ट्राइक फेल्कन का कंसोल है। एडीआर कंसोल
जो एक्टिविटी डैशबोर्ड आपको दिखा रहा है।
तो बेसिकली यहां पे करंट क्राउड स्कोर
होता है आपके नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
लिए। मतलब आपके नेटवर्क का क्राउड स्कोर
क्या है? क्राउड स्कोर एक ऐसा स्कोर बनाया
गया है क्राउड स्ट्राइक के तरफ से इनके
एडीआर सिस्टम्स के तरफ से जो कि आपके पूरे
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे जो भी अटैक्स
वगैरह हो रहे हैं अलग-अलग तरह के या जो भी
अटैक्स होते हैं उन सबको मिला के बहुत
सारे अटैक्स को कंबाइन करके उनके उस को और
एक स्कोर बनाया गया है कि आपके नेटवर्क के
ऊपर किस लेवल का अटैक अभी हुआ है। तो, यह
यह स्कोर है। जैसे ज़ीरो है। अभी 1 2 3 4 5
6 जो भी स्कोर है। तो, अगर ज़्यादा स्कोर
है, मतलब कि आपके नेटवर्क के ऊपर ज़्यादा
अह अटैक्स जो हैं वो हो रखे हैं। एंड यहां
पे न्यू डिटेक्शन आप देख रहे हैं 175 या
ये आपको बताता है। उसके बाद बताता है
एसएचए बेस्ड डिटेक्शंस कितने हैं वो आपको
यहां पे बताता है। प्रिवेंटेड मैलवेयर बाय
होस्ट। यह भी बताता है कि मैलवेयर्स कितने
प्रिवेंट किए गए हैं होस्ट के द्वारा। यह
भी आपको बताया जाता है। यह लास्ट सेवन डेज़
का आपको बता रहा है यहां पे। ठीक है? तो
यहां पे टोटल 12 यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है।
उसके बाद क्राउड स्ट्राइक स्कोर क्राउड का
स्कोर क्राउड स्कोर जो है ओवर द टाइम क्या
रहा है? मतलब कि लास्ट 1 महीने में या
क्वार्टरली ईयरली क्या रहा है क्राउड
क्राउड स्कोर आपका मतलब कब आपका क्राउड
स्कोर ज्यादा रहा है मतलब किस टाइम पे आप
किस कंपनी के नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
ऊपर ज्यादा अटैक्स हुए हैं वो आपको बताता
है मोस्ट रीसेंट डिटेक्शंस अभी रिसेंट में
जो जो डिटेक्शंस हुए हैं वो उसकी पूरी
यहां पे आपको डिटेल बताता है सारी डिटेल
आप देख रहे हैं यहां पे सारी डिटेल बताता
है और डिटेक्शन बाय टैक्टिक्स वही जो
टैक्टिक्स एंड टेक्निक्स बाय m्रे वाला है
उसका डिटेक्शन यह बताता है बेसिकली m्रे
फ्रेम वर्क को यूज़ करते हुए। तो ये आपको
बताता है कि मैलवेयर्स कितने हैं? डिफेंस
इवज़ मतलब मैलवेयर अटैक कितने हुए हैं?
यहां पे आप देख सकते होंगे। यहां पे सबसे
नीचे में यहां पे लिखा भी हुआ है कि
मैलवेयर अटैक्स कितने हुए हैं? डिफेंस
इवज़न अटैक्स कितने हुए हैं? मशीन लर्निंग
रिलेटेड अटैक्स कितने हुए हैं? कमाइन एंड
कंट्रोल से रिलेटेड अटैक्स क्या कितने हुए
हैं? और इंपैक्ट्स का क्या एंड हुआ। ठीक
है?
ये सारी चीजें आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिलेगी। व्हाट हैपेंस आफ्टर डिटेक्शन?
व्हेन अ डिटेक्शन कम्स एसोसिस
एनालिसिसिबिलिटीज़ टू एक्नॉलेज द अलर्ट एंड
प्रायोरिटाइज इट। तो एसओसी इसको एकनॉलेज
करता है, प्रायर कर प्रायोरिटाइज करता है
एंड ईडीआर खुद भी प्रायरिटाइज कर देती है।
ईडीआर के अंदर ये एक फैसिलिटी है कि आपको
हाई लो मीडियम करके प्रायोरिटाइज करती है।
तो इससे जैसे कोई हाई सीवियरिटी वाली
प्रायोरिटाइज इडीआर डिटेक्शन है तो उसको
एसओसी भी हाई सीवियरिटी में ही लेता है।
उसको ज्यादा प्रायोरिटाइज करता है। तो यह
पूरा आपका कैसे इडीआर काम करती है यह भी
मैंने आपको सारा कुछ बता दिया है। अब
इडीआर टेलीमेट्री है। इडियट टेलीमीटर के
बारे में मैंने बताया कि डाटा को कलेक्ट
करने वाला जो प्रोसेस है वही टेलीमीटरी
होती है जिसमें कि प्रोसेस एग्ज़क्यूशन एंड
टर्मिनेशन कलेक्ट होता है उसका डाटा
नेटवर्क से रिलेटेड कनेक्शंस डिटेक्ट जो
डाटा होती है वो कनेक्ट कलेक्ट होता है
कमांड लाइन एक्टिविटी जो है उससे रिलेटेड
डेटा कलेक्ट होती है फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स
मॉडिफिकेशन से रिलेटेड जो डाटा है वो
कलेक्ट होती है रजिस्ट्री मॉडिफिकेशन
रिलेटेड ये सारी चीजें मैंने ऑलरेडी
डिस्कस कर ली है।
अब आते हैं डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस
कैपेबिलिटीज़ पे। तो आप देखेंगे तो यह
मैंने ऑलरेडी बता दिया है कि डिटेक्शन एंड
रिस्पांस कैपेबिलिटीज क्या होती है। तो
मैंने डिटेक्शन का पूरा बताया कि कैसे
बिहेवल डिटेक्शंस वगैरह होते हैं। आईओसीस
के बारे में बता दिया था। कैसे होते हैं?
मथ्रे को यूज़ करके होता है। वो सब चीज़ बता
दिया है। रिस्पांस का भी मैंने बता दिया
है कि होस्ट को आइसोलेट करते हैं। प्रोसेस
को टर्मिनेट करते हैं। क्वारंटाइन या
रिमोट एक्सेस लेते हैं। ये सारे भी मैंने
चीजें क्लियर कर दी है ऑलरेडी। तो ये भी
आपका कवर है। अब इसमें लास्ट एक बचता है
इन्वेस्टिगेट एंड अलर्ट ऑन ईडीआर। मतलब कि
लाइव ईडीआर पर हम एक अलर्ट को
इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे। यह इसका मतलब बनता
है। इसका मतलब यह बनता है। तो यह यहां पर
चीजें दी हुई है। तो बेसिकली व्हाट वी कैन
डू वी कैन ट्राई ऐसे ऐसे करके। मान लो
इडिया डैशबोर्ड है। ये इडिया डैशबोर्ड है।
इसको हम ओपन कर लेते हैं। आपको मैं दिखा
भी देता हूं। ये क्लाउड स्ट्राइक का इडिया
डैशबोर्ड है। क्लाउड स्ट्राइक का इडिया
डैशबोर्ड कुछ इसी तरीके का होता है। तो
आपको मैं लाइव एक इडिया डैशबोर्ड दिखा रहा
हूं। कई लोगों को लगता होगा कि आप लोग पूछ
रहे थे ना कि सर तो ये जो एक तरह का
क्लाउड स्ट्राइक का ईडीआर जो होता है ना
उसी पे बेस्ड उसी तरीके का ये एक डैशबोर्ड
है जिस तरीके से वो दिखाता है जो चीज वो
उसी पे बेस्ड है ये लैब आपका तो ये आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा है राइट अब देखो यहां पे
ये आप ये तो अकाउंट का है अब यहां पे आप
देख सकते हो इरडिया डैशबोर्ड में सबसे
पहले क्या है कितने एक्टिव होस्ट हैं
कितने होस्ट पे इडिेंट्स जिस पे काम कर
रहे हैं जो इडीआर एजेंट्स काम कर रहे हैं
एंड पॉइंट्स पे वो कितने हैं न्यू न्यू
डिटेक्शंस कितने हैं? चार हुए हैं।
डिटेक्शन सोर्स क्या है? एनमली,
बिहेवियरल, थ्रेट इंटेल। थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
के थ्रू यह सारे प्रिवेंटेड मैल है, कोई
नहीं है। तो, चार यहां पे डिटेशंस हुए
हैं। इसी डिटेक्शंस के बेस पे आपको यहां
पे क्वेश्चंस कुछ है यहां पे आपको दिख रहे
होंगे। तो व्हिच टूल वाज़ ल्च बाय CMD.exc
टू डाउनलोड द पेलोड ऑन डेस्कटॉप HR01।
तो एक एक डिटेक्शन है जिसमें होस्ट है
डेस्कटॉप HR01। तो इसके अब देखो अब इसमें
बेसिकली इसकी डिटेल्स जानी है तो आपको इस
अलॉट पे क्लिक करना है। मतलब इस पर्टिकुलर
डिटेक्शंस पे आपको क्लिक क्लिक करना है।
मैंने ये क्लिक किया। अब इसकी पूरी डिटेल
आ जाएगी। इनिशियल एक्सेस वाया मलेशियस
ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट ये है। पहले इसका पूरा
समरी आएगा। ये इसके बाद प्रोसेस के
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन आपकी आएगी। आईओसी या
इंडिकेटर्स जो है उसकी इनेशन आएगी। देन
एक्शन या रिस्पांस जो है वो आएगा। समरी
में आपको इस पूरे अटैक के बारे में बताया
जाएगा। मतलब ये जो डिटेक्शन हुआ है उसके
बारे में बताया जाएगा कि अ माइक्रो
इनेबल्ड ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट जिसका नाम है
इनवॉइस डॉट एम वाज़ ओपन यूजिंग winword.exc
यानी वर्ड के थ्रू एक डॉक्यूमेंट को ओपन
किया गया। दिस डॉक्यूमेंट ट्रिगरर्ड
सीएमडी। इस डॉक्यूमेंट ने कमांड प्र्प
स्टार्ट किया व्हिच लॉन्चड सी यूआरएल
जिसने सी यूआरएल नाम का एक कमांड चलाया है
जिससे कि डाउनलोड की गई है पेलोड एक
एक्सटर्नल डोमेन से। इसका मतलब यह हुआ द
फाइल वाज़ सेव्ड टू डिस्क। फाइल को डिस्क
में सेव किया गया बट नेवर एग्जीक्यूटेड बट
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हुआ है। बिहेवियर
कंसिस्टेंट विथ मैलवेयर स्टेजिंग
टैक्टिक्स। बिहेवियर से पता चल रहा है कि
भैया ये मैलवेयर वाला सीन कुछ है।
बिहेवियर समरी क्या है? ऑफिस मैक लॉन्च
सीएमडी सीएमडी ट्रिगरर्ड सीयूआरएल टू
डाउनलोड पेलोड। फाइल सेफ टू पब्लिक फोल्डर
एग्जीक्यूशन डिड नॉट ऑकर पोटेंशियल
स्टैगिंग। तो अभी तक एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट
स्टार्ट नहीं हुई है। अब इसमें यूजर कौन
था? एलिस डॉट थॉमस होस्ट कौन था? डेस्कटॉप
एच आर01 टाइम स्टैंप क्या था? 7 जून 2026
को हुआ था ये। तो बेसिकली ये करंट टाइम
स्टैंप दिखाता है 9:03 पे अभी दिखा रहा
है। सीवियरिटी इसकी हाई थी। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे डिटेक्शन की डिटेल्स भी दिखाएगा
इडीआर के अंदर में। स्टेटस अभी एकनॉलेज
नहीं हुई है। मतलब मैंने एकनॉलेज इसको अभी
नहीं किया है कि हां भैया यह है
सीिवियरिटी हाई है। होस्ट आपको बताएगा
डिटेक्शन टाइप। रिस्क असेसमेंट का एक आपको
स्कोर मिलता है कि मथ्रे अटैक टैक्टिक जो
है इनिशियल एक्सेस है। टेक्निक कौन सा है?
टी वन टेक्निक का एक नाम होता है स्पेयर
फिशिंग अटैचमेंट। ये टेक्निक है स्पेयर
फिशिंग का यूज़। और कॉन्फिडेंस स्कोर क्या
है कि भैया इस पे ज्यादा इस एडीआर को
कितना कॉन्फिडेंस है कि हां ये सच में ये
एक अटैक ही हो सकता है। ये थ्रेट एक्टर हो
सकता है। तो 95 का स्कोर है यानी कि बहुत
ही ज्यादा इसको भरोसा है कि ये अटैक ही
है। देन आती है प्रोसेस इनफो जिसमें जो
प्रोसेस चेन है वो पूरी प्रोसेस चेन आपको
दिखेगी। तो ये ईडीआर की खूबी है। ईडीआर
पूरी प्रोसेस चेन दिखाता है कि भैया शुरू
कहां से हुआ था। तो एक विन वर्ड यानी वर्ड
से शुरू हुआ था Microsoft Word से। उसने
सीएमडी को चालू किया। तो उसने curआl exc
नाम की एक कमांड चलाई और इसी की पूरी
डिटेल है इस पे क्लिक करोगे ना विन वर्ड
पे ठीक है तो विन वर्ड का ये पूरा ईएक्सe
फाइल है यहां पे ये चल रहा है यहां पे ये
बेसिकली हो रही है ठीक है अब सीएमडी पे
क्लिक करोगे तो सीएमडी वाली पूरी डिटेल
आपको देगा सी यूआरएल पे क्लिक करोगे तो
curआरएल की पूरी डिटेल देगा इंस्टॉल
देखोगे तो इंस्टॉल की पूरी डिटेल देगा तो
डिटेल्स में कैसे होती है तो सीआर curआlx
बस 10 मिनट में आपकी क्लास करता हूं। 10
मिनट और रुक जाओ भाई। इतना हड़बड़ाते
क्यों हो? 10 मिनट 9:30 हो गए तो क्या हो
गया? अगर आपको जाना है तो आप जा सकते हो।
अगर आपको लीव करना है यू कैन लीव। कोई बात
नहीं। अगर आपको लगता है जैसे कोई जरूरी
काम है या कुछ ऐसा है, कोई लेट हो रहा है,
यू कैन लीव बट हमारा 10 मिनट में लगभग हो
जाएगा।
ओके। curआरl.
अब इसमें डिटेल्स क्या-क्या होती है? पाथ
ये किस पाथ पे बैठा हुआ है या इस किस पाथ
से एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है? तो फाइल अगर कोई है
तो किस पाथ पे है? कोई कमांड है तो किस
पाथ से एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है? कमांड लाइन
क्या था? तो ये कमांड चली हुई है। ये पूरी
कमांड चली हुई है। पीआईडी प्रोसेस आईडी
क्या है? वो पूरी डिटेल है। पैरेंट
प्रोसेस इसका पैरेंट प्रोसेस कौन है? यानी
किस कमांड किस प्रोसेस के थ्रू ये
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है? तो ये cmd.exc के थ्रू
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है वो यहां पे है। साइन
Microsoft साइन है भैया। अह ये जो है
सीआरएल.ex
क्योंकि ये कमांड है तो Microsoft का है।
यहां पे है। एसए 256#श यहां पे बिहेवियर
क्या है डाउनलोडेड एक्सटर्नल बाइनरी टू
डिस्क। इसने क्या किया है कि एक बाइनरी
एक्सटर्नल बाइनरी को आपके लोकल डिस्क पे
डाउनलोड किया है। स्टार्ट टाइम 11:12 52
सेकंड पे एंड टाइम 11:15
सेकंड पे। थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस क्या कहती है
इसकी? कि कॉमन ड्यूल यूज़ टूल बिहेवियर
फ्लैग्ड। ये एक कॉमन टूल है। एक नॉर्मल सा
टूल है। देखो थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस की पावर
कितनी होती है? ये समझना। ठीक है? हां जी।
रियल में भी ऐसा ही शो होगा। बिल्कुल। अरे
कुछ देखो जैसे कुछ लोगों का भी इशू था कि
सर ये प्रैक्टिकल ये प्रैक्टिकल ही है।
देखो तुम लोग प्रैक्टिकल एसओसी के
प्रैक्टिकल में कुछ ऐसा नहीं होगा कि
अचानक से कोई टूल ल्च हो जाएगी। उसने कोई
धमाका कर दिया ऐसा नहीं। ये ऐसे ही टूल्स
होते हैं। आपको एनालाइज एज एन एसओसी। आप
क्या करोगे? आप क्या गेम चलाओगे? कोई
एग्जीक्यूशन करोगे। कोई टूल को एग्जीक्यूट
करके ऐसे-ऐसे रन कराओगे जो नॉर्मली विंडज़
में चलती है। नहीं। आपके पास टूल रहेगा
ऑलरेडी। जैसे यह ईडीआर टूल है, एसआईएम टूल
है। आपको उसको एनालाइज करना है। उसकी
चीजों को देखना है। तो यह वही हो रही है।
लाइव एनालिसिस हो रहा है। ठीक है?
बिल्कुल हबीबी आप होम लैब तैयार कीजिए। तो
ये लाइव आपको मैं दिखा रहा हूं। ईडीआर ऐसे
ही आपको दिखाएगा। सब चीज़ ऐसे ही इनेशन
होती है। ये भी तो देखो कितना इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है। जस्ट सी इट। इसको फील करो। थ्रेट
Intel क्या बोल रहा है? देखो थ्रेड
इंटेलिजेंस कितनी इंपॉर्टेंट होती है कि
ये कॉमन टूल है
सी यूआरएल जैसे कि हम कमांड डालते हैं ना
डब्ल्यू गेट कमांड होती है अ सीडी कमांड
होती है राइट डेट कमांड होती है तो ये
बोलेगा हां ये नॉर्मल टूल है लेकिन
बिहेवियर इसका फ्लैग हुआ है ये जो चीज
डाउनलोड करने की कोशिश कर रहा है वो
एक्सटर्नल किसी आईपी से डाउनलोड हो रही है
यूआरएल से डाउनलोड हो रही है वो बिहेवियर
थोड़ा सा गड़बड़ है नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी में
डोमेन क्या यूज़ हुआ ए बीडीएम आईपी ये है
पोर्ट ये है तो ये पूरी डिटेल आपको
प्रोवाइड करता है एव्री डिटेल ठीक है
आईओसी इंडिकेटर्स में क्या होता है
एसोसिएटेड इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज अब
यही आईओसीस है जो कि यहां पे आपको डिटेल
आपको आईओसीस कहेंगे इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़
कॉम्प्रोमाइज यानी कि कॉम्प्रोमाइज
किस-किस इंडिकेटर के थ्रू ये कॉम्प्रोमाइज
हो सकता है अह वो बताते हैं। जैसे टाइप
में फाइल का पाथ क्या है? तो पब्लिक
फोल्डर के अंदर इंस्टॉल यह सस्िशियस
बाइनरी है क्वारेंटाइन हो गया फाइल नेम है
इंस्टॉल ड्रॉप्ड पेलोड है फ्लैग हो गया
डोमेन क्या है एbdtएम
ये एक c2 सर्वर है यानी कि कमांड कंट्रोल
सर्वर अटैकर का इसको ब्लॉक कर दिया गया
ठीक है IP एड्रेस यहां पे क्या है ये वाली
है एक्सटर्नल डाउनलोड है लॉक्ड इसको लॉक
कर दिया गया लॉग्स में डाल दिया गया एसए
यहां पे है अननोन एग्जीक्यूटेबल है एसए के
थ्रू यह पता चला कि एक अननोन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल है इसको एनालाइज करके फ्लैग
कर दिया गया। फाइल पाथ क्या है? तो इनवॉइस
डॉट ये डाउनलोड्स के अंदर में सस्िशियस
डॉक्यूमेंट दिख रहा है एंड इसको
क्वारेंटाइन कर दिया गया। तो ये आईओसी या
इंडिकेटर्स होते हैं। अब एक्शन रिस्पांस
में जो भी आप एक्शन लोगे एसओसी एलोन की
तरह जो भी आपका रिस्पांस होगा वो यहां पे
दिखता है। तो बेसिकली इसके बेसिस पे यहां
पे क्वेश्चंस हैं। तो व्हिच टूल वाज़ ल्च
बाय cmd.exc टू डाउनलोड? तो कौन सा टूल
यूज़ किया गया था? तो आप जब प्रोसेस ट्री
में जाओगे तो ये curआरl exc तो ये आपको
फहकमी के ये फ्लैग में डाल देना है
curआlxc हो गया व्हाट इज द एब्सोल्यूट पाथ
टू द डाउनलोडेड मैलवेयर डेस्कटॉप एचआर1
एब्सोल्यूट पाथ क्या है जो मैलवेयर
डाउनलोड हुई है तो भाई डाउनलोड कौन सा हुआ
है इंस्टॉल इस पे क्लिक करो इसका पाथ देख
लो ये पाथ है c यूज़र्स पब्लिक इंस्टॉल तो
हमने इंस्टॉल डाल दिया व्हाट इज द
एब्सोल्यूट पाथ टू द सस्िशियस
sin cv csvc exc सी ऑन Windows ENG लैप 0
लैपटॉप 03 यानी कि ये दूसरी मशीन है। उस
पे एब्सोल्यूट पाथ क्या है? सस्पिसियस इस
फाइल का। तो अब दूसरा मशीन है भैया लैब 03
ये वाली मशीन है। तो इसको खोल लो।
अब ये प्रोसेस इनफो पे चलो। तो ये कौन सा
फाइल था? ये वाला सिंस सीएसबीसी इस पे
क्लिक करो। इसका पाथ क्या है? तो ये वाली
पाथ है भाई। ये ऐप डेटा के अंदर लोकल टेम
के अंदर में है। तो हमने क्या किया? ऐप
डाटा लोकल टेम के अंदर। ये पूरी फाइल की
यहां पे पूरी पाथ दे दी। ऑन व्हिच यूआरएल
वाज़ द एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन अटेम्प्ट बीइंग मेड
ऑन लैपटॉप 03 कि एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन यानी कौन
से पाथ पे डेटा को एक्सफिल्ट्रेट किया गया
है भेजा जा रहा है। तो डेटा को भेजा जा
रहा है किस पे? तो अब मान लो मैंने इस इस
वाली प्रोसेस यही तो प्रोसेस है। मेन
हमारा मेन जो पेलोड है यही है जो सिन सी
एस वीसी करके है। अब इसी का डिटेल देखेंगे
तो इसमें पता चलेगा। तो ये पाथ इस जगह पे
बैठा हुआ है। कमांड ये चलाया है इसने और
यहां देखो यहां नीचे थ्रेट इंटेल में है।
ठीक है? ये है नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी में।
देखो नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी में क्या दिखा रहा
है? अटेम्प्टेड एक्स फेल टू। इसने कहां पे
अटेम्प्ट किया? इस इस लोकेशन पे यह भेज
रहा है डेटा को।
बिल्कुल सही। एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। दिस इज़ द
कॉम्बिनेशन ऑफ़ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस एंड डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स।
बिल्कुल सही बोला है कि आज की जो क्लास है
कुछ लोगों को शायद नहीं पता होगी शायद एंड
सुरेंद्र ने जो बोला बिल्कुल सही बोला है
कि हमने एक चीज को कवर नहीं किया हमने
एसओसी का इन्वेस्टिगेशन पार्ट जो है वो भी
कवर किया है हमने एसओसी के अलावा थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस को भी कवर किया है हमने
फॉरेंसिक्स डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स जो होती है
उसको भी कवर किया है तो हमने बहुत सारी
चीजें कवर की है एंड लिटरली मैं आपको
बताता हूं सच बता रहा हूं कि अब ऐसी ऐसी
क्लासेस आप किसी पेड क्लासेस कोर्सेज में
आपको मिल जाए तो मुझे बता देना। मुझे
बताना कि सर पेड क्लासेस में आपसे बेटर
पढ़ा रहे हैं। मैं गारंटी दे रहा हूं यू
विल नॉट फाइंड इट।
नेवर
इतना एफर्ट नहीं डालता ना कोई बात ये है।
ऊपर ऊपर का बता देंगे। हां ये है वो ठीक
है। बाकी करते रहो। सबको यही है। सबको यही
सबको यही करना होता है।
ठीक है? कोई मतलब ही नहीं होता है। तो
यहां पे एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन कहां हुई है?
अटेम्प्टेड एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन टू इस यूआरएल
पे। एक्सफिल्टरेट हुआ है डेटा यानी डेटा
आपका इस यूआरएल के पास इस यूआरएल पे भेजा
जा रहा है। अपलोड किया जा रहा है। ये
यूआरएल आपका अटैकर का वेबसाइट है। अटैकर
होस्टेड आपका सर्वर है वहां भेजा जा रहा
है। तो ये यूआरएल यहां डाल दीजिए। ये आंसर
हो जाएगा। व्हाट वाज़ अपडेट एजेंट डॉट exc
लेबल्ड बाय थ्रेट intel ऑन डेस्कटॉप
डेव01? अब ये एक और डेस्कटॉप दूसरा
डेस्कटॉप है। इस पे थ्रेटel के द्वारा
अपडेट एजेंट.exe फाइल को क्या लेबल किया
गया है? ये क्वेश्चन है तो भाई हम बैक
करते हैं हमारे थ्रेड्स के लिस्ट में
देखते हैं। डेस्कटॉप डेव 01 ये है। इसकी
डिटेल पे चल चले जाते हैं। अब यहां पे
अगेन हम प्रोसेस इनफो पे चलते हैं। इसमें
प्रोसेस कौन है? अपडेट एजेंटx इस पे क्लिक
करते हैं। इसकी डिटेल थ्रेट इंटेल ने इसको
क्या बोला है? नॉन इंटरनल आईटी यूटिलिटी
टूल। ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव आपका है कि ये नॉन
इंटरनल आईटी यूटिलिटी है। तो ये फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। दिस इज़ नॉट अ ट्रू। क्योंकि
ये एक इंटरनल आईटी यूटिलिटी टूल है। अपडेट
एजेंट. तो चलेगा। तो यहां पे डाल दिया नॉन
इंटरनल आईटी एडिटर। दैट्स इट। ये आपका
करेक्ट आंसर हो गया। कंक्लूजन में कुछ
करना ही नहीं। हो गया। आपने ये लैब सॉल्व
कर लिया। दैट्स इट। बिना लैब सॉल्व किए ही
आपने लैब सॉल्व कर लिया। खत्म कहानी यहां
पे। सिंपल। तो इस तरीके से ये पूरा का
पूरा ऑपरेट होता है। एंड कुछ इसी तरीके से
आपका जो है ईडीआर का दिखता है। जो
डैशबोर्ड है वो ऐसे ही दिखता है। आप किसी
कंपनी में जब जाएंगे जॉब करने एसोसिएल वन।
वहां पे आपको क्राउड स्ट्राइक फाल्कन या
ईडीआर सॉफ्टवेयर्स देंगे तो आपको समझ में
आ जाएगा। आपको लगेगा कि आपने पहले ईडीआर
देखा है। आपने पहले ईडीआर को यूज़ करा है।
ऐसा आपको फील होगा। एंड तब आपको पावर समझ
में आएगी इस क्लास की कि ये क्लास किस
लेवल की मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं।
अभी आपको शायद आप में से कई लोगों को
वैल्यू ना हो। जो लोग नहीं देखते लाइव या
जो लोग ऐसे ही समझते हैं अरे क्या ही है
यार फ्री में पढ़ा रहे हैं। कुछ क्वालिटी
थोड़ी ना होगी। तो जो लोग ये समझते हैं
उनको शायद कभी बाद में समझ में आएगी और वो
लोग वापस इसी वीडियोस को इन्हीं वीडियोस
को देखेंगे, रिपीट करेंगे, रिपीट पे
देखेंगे। कई ऐसे लोग हैं जो बताते नहीं है
और एसओसी की हमारी क्लासेस को देखते हैं।
कई ऐसे लोग हैं जो प्रोफेशनल्स हैं।
लिटरली मैं बता रहा हूं आपको प्रोफेशनल्स
हैं। एसओसी में ही है। एंड दे वॉच द
वीडियोस। मैं यह नहीं बोलता कि दे शुड नॉट
वॉच। दे शुड डेफिनेटली वॉच। दे शुड
डेफिनेटली गेट अलोंग। अभी हमारे बीच देयर
इज़ अ पर्सन पीतांबर। ही इज़ एन एसोसिएलिस्ट
बट ही इज़ ही इज़ नॉट हाइडिंग समवेयर ही
क्लियरली कम्स हियर ही क्लियरली वॉच द
वीडियोस वो रेगुलर रहता है एंड ही इज़ लाइक
इंटरेक्टिंग एंड एवरीथिंग सो इस तरीके का
आपके अंदर होना चाहिए हाइड क्या करना है
हमें नॉलेज लेना है सीखना है कौन सी वो
छोटे हो जाएंगे हम क्या हो जाएंगे और इस
लेवल की नॉलेज अगर मिल रही है फ्री में
मिल रही है तो आपका क्या जा रहा है यार
अगर आपका 2 घंटा लग रहा है वो भी 2 घंटा
डेली तो नहीं लग रहा मतलब कुछ-कुछ दिनों
पे लगती है तो आपका फायदा हो रहा है तो
सीखो ना यार सीखो आपसे कौन सा पैसा मैं ले
रहा हूं इसके लिए YouTube थोड़ा बहुत दे
रहा है आपसे तो मैं कोई चार्ज नहीं कर रहा
नो आई एम चार्जिंग नथिंग एंड डिलीवरिंग द
क्वालिटी हां ऐसा होता है कुछ भी कबाड़ा
आपको फेंक रहा होता कुछ भी कबाड़ा आपको
मिल रहा होता तो आपको लगता कि अरे भाई
क्या ही यार यहां तो कुछ अलग ही लेवल की
आपको चीजें मिल रही है यू शुड बी नोइंग
दैट
ठीक है
या दोबारा देखा करो
ठीक है हबीबी प्लीज आस्क योर क्वेश्चन अभी
पूछ लीजिए मैं आंसर कर दूंगा ठीक है समझ
समझ में आ गया? चलिए ये पूरा ईडीआर है
आपका। तो ईडीआर के अंदर ही म का अलग-अलग
चीजें होती हैं। यहां पे ये आपको अलग-अलग
ऑप्शंस होते हैं यहां पे। अब जो ये ऑप्शंस
है फिलहाल यहां पे अभी ब्लॉक्ड है क्योंकि
अभी ये ऑप्शंस हम यूज़ नहीं करने वाले हैं।
तो अभी सिर्फ डैशबोर्ड पे ये अलर्ट का
आपको मिला है यहां पे। एंड इस तरीके से
डिटेक्शन बाय टैक्टिक्स आता है जिसमें
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा एग्जीक्यूशन
कितने हुए हैं। अ टोटल एग्जीकशंस आपने इस
पे क्लिक किया वो एग्जीकशंस वाले कॉलन हट
जाते हैं। उसके बाद डिफेंस इवेशन का आप
देखेंगे जैसे एग्जीकशंस रहने दो तो डिफेंस
एवीज़ अगर एग्जीक्यूशन इसको रहने देते हैं।
डिफेंस एज़ अगर देखते हैं तो वो आपका हट
जाएगा। तो ये बिल्कुल रिमूव हो जाएगा।
मुझे सिर्फ डिफेंस एज़ देखना है तो बाकी सब
पे क्लिक कर दोगे तो बाकी सारे जो है डेटा
हट जाएंगे। और सिर्फ डिफेंस इवेज वाले जो
डेटा है वो आपके इडीआर के अंदर में आपको
शो होने लगेंगे ओवर द टाइम पीरियड कि ये
लास्ट रिफ्रेश रिफ्रेश होता रहता है तो
ओवर द टाइम पीरियड आपको दिखेगा कि इतने
सारे डिफेंस इवज़ंस जो हैं वो आपके हुए
हैं। तो ये आप देख सकते हैं। उसी तरीके से
अगर आपको देखना है कि कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
सर्वर्स कितने हैं तो बाकी सबको वो कर दो।
तो कमांड एंड कंट्रोल जो सर्वर्स हैं सी
टू सी सर्वर्स जो इस्टैब्लिश हुए हैं वो
सारे आपको दिख जाएंगे। अगर दो देखते हैं
आपको तो पर्सिस्टेंस एंड सी टू सी सर्वर
दो दिख रहे हैं आपको। इस तरीके से आपको यह
पूरा ओवरव्यू देता है आपका ईडीआर। तो
ईडीआर कुछ इस तरीके से सारा ऑपरेट करता
है। हम ईडीआर के अंदर बाकी जो ऑप्शंस हैं
इनको भी देखेंगे आने वाले क्लासेस में।
टेंशन आपको बिल्कुल नहीं लेना है। आपको
मैं इतना सिखा दूंगा कि आप ईडीआर, एसआईएम,
डैशबोर्ड इतना सीख के जाएंगे इन्हीं
क्लासेस से कि जब आप लाइव कंपनी के अंदर
जाएंगे तो आपको सब पता रहेगा। यू विल बी
नोइंग एवरीथिंग। आपको सब पता रहेगा कि हां
अरे हां ये ऑप्शन देखा है मैंने ये ऑप्शन
का क्या मतलब है किस तरीके से हम टैकल
करते हैं किस तरीके से ऑप्शंस को हम क्लिक
करते हैं क्या करते हैं एक्शन क्या लेते
हैं अलर्ट को कैसे डील करते हैं किस तरीके
से ट्रू पॉजिटिव फॉल्स पॉजिटिव कैटेगराइज
करते हैं किस तरीके से डिटेक्ट करते हैं
किस तरीके से बिहेव करते हैं हर चीज आपको
रिस्पोंड करते हैं हर चीज आपको पता रहेगा
तो टेंशन बिल्कुल नहीं लेना है यार तुम
बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहो
ठीक है सो दैट्स इट गाइस फॉर टुडे सेशन
एंड टुडे सेशन इज नाउ एंडिंग एंड एंड मजा
आ गया आज की क्लास में एंड काफी अच्छा था
आज का सेशन। आप लोग काफी एनर्जेटिक रह के
लास्ट तक टिके रहे हैं। इससे बड़ी बात कुछ
नहीं है। एंड इट वाज़ ग्रेट सेशन टुडे। सो
आई होप कि आप हां एक चीज करिएगा आप सभी
लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है कि जब भी आप सेशन
को देखना बंद कर देते हैं। जब जाते हुए
क्या कीजिएगा? जाते हुए बस आपको लाइक
ठोकते हुए जाना है। जितना लाइक ठोक सकते
हैं लाइक ठोक दीजिएगा। एंड उसके बाद
जाइएगा। दूसरी चीज वीडियो को शेयर जरूर
कीजिएगा। मैं आपसे बार-बार बार-बार सभी से
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। इसका मतलब यह है कि
हमारे देखो वीडियो को शेयर करने से व्यूज
आएंगे। मुझे पता है। मैं उसके लिए आपको
बोल रहा हूं। ठीक है। आपको अगर मानना है
मानो। लेकिन वीडियो को शेयर करने से एक
चीज और होती है कि बहुत ऐसे लोग हैं जो उस
पर्टिकुलर वीडियो को या इस इन पर्टिकुलर
सीरीज तक नहीं पहुंच पा रहे हैं। उनको
नहीं पता है इन सीरीज के बारे में। दे
डोंट नो ऐसी सीरीज क्वालिटी सीरीज चल रही
है तो उनको बताओ ना उनको पता तो चलना
चाहिए एटलीस्ट दे शुड बी नोइंग अबाउट दिस
ना तो उनको शेयर करो शेयर आपके अंदर बहुत
पावर है यू ऑल आर वेरी पावरफुल कई लोग आप
में से Telegram ग्रुप्स चलाते हैं
WhatsApp ग्रुप्स चलाते हैं Facebook
ग्रुप्स चलाते हैं Instagram पेजेस हैं
Lindin प्रोफाइल्स हैं फॉलोअर्स हैं लोग
सब जगह जितने कर सकते हो शेयर करो लोगों
को इसके बारे में बताओ ताकि सब तक यह चीज
पहुंच जाए। अभी हम आने वाले टाइम में और
बहुत सारी क्लासेस, बहुत सी चीजें शुरू
करेंगे। सबके बारे में सबको बताया करो।
तभी तो यूनिवर्सिटी बनेगी ये हमारी
डिफ्रॉनिक्स यूनिवर्सिटी डिफ्रॉनिक्स
साइबर टेक यूनिवर्सिटी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
प्लस टेक्नोलॉजी यूनिवर्सिटी जहां सब
चीजें आपको एक बार आओ और डिफ्रॉनिक्स
यूनिवर्सिटी पेज इस YouTube चैनल से सब
कुछ मिल जाएगा। दैट्स इट।
ग्रेट। थैंक यू नितीश शाह। नितेश झा थैंक
यू वेरी मच नितीश झा
सर मायसेल्फ रचित त्यागी मुझे यह पूछना
पूछना है कि मेरी बीएससी सीएस 2024 में
कंप्लीट हुई थी। मैं फाइनेंसियल प्रॉब्लम
चलते सीएस डोमेन में
जॉब नहीं कर पाया एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी
आपके ही इस प्लेलिस्ट से देख देख के जॉइ
की ठीक है कोई बात नहीं है रचित नो इशज़
कंटिन्यू कीजिए आप इसके थ्रू घुसिए अंदर
इसके थ्रू आप एंटर कीजिए एंड एज एन एसोसी
क्या बात है अल्बोरेनी वेलकम
सर शाउट आउट शाउट आउट तो दूंगा बट नाम
क्या रखा है यार नाम ऐसा रखा है कि मैं
शाउट आउट कैसे दूं यार आलू मोटा भालू ये
कौन सा नाम है ये कौन सा शाउट आउट है आलू
मोटा भालू
नाम तो सही रखो ताकि नाम बोलूं मैं यार वन
डे सर बनेगी यूनिवर्सिटी मेहनत कभी जाया
नहीं होती बिल्कुल साइबर जैन थैंक यू वेरी
मच बडी वन डे वी विल मेक एन यूनिवर्सिटी
जहां पे या तो फ्री एजुकेशन होगी या तो
सबसे ज्यादा अफोर्डेबल एजुकेशन होगी इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी टेक्नोलॉजी एंड रिलेटेड
डोमस यही एक उम्मीद है देखते हैं व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग देयर इन इंडिया
और हम अभी बहुत हम अभी यह भी प्लान कर रहे
हैं टू स्टार्ट आवर
ब्रांड जो हमारा अभी धीरे-धीरे बन रहा है
आई विल नॉट से ब्रांड बट हम सोच रहे हैं
इसके फ्रेंचाइजी जो है स्टार्ट करने का
यूएई गल्फ कंट्रीज में टू एक्सपेंड
डेफ्रोनिक्स स्टार्टिंग फ्रॉम यूएई यूएई
इज़ अ सच अ ब्यूटीफुल कंट्री एंड वी आर
थिंकिंग टू स्टार्ट देयर आल्सो सो देखते
हैं हम कांटेक्ट करेंगे। अगर कोई
इंटरेस्टेड होगा वहां यूएई का डिफ्रॉनिक्स
को वहां पे रन करने के लिए तो हम वहां के
लिए भी जाएंगे। सो अभी बहुत कुछ प्लांड
है। देयर आर थिंग्स प्लंड बट मैं आपके लिए
हम कंटेंट लेकर आएंगे। आपके लिए हम
ट्रेनिंग्स एंड नॉलेजेबल कंटेंट लेकर
आएंगे जो क्वालिटी कंटेंट होगी। एंड यू
विल कीप गेटिंग दिस कंटेंट्स फ्रॉम आवर
साइड। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। चलिए। सो यहां
टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट देख लेते हैं गाइस। आई
वंस अगेन द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट कंटेन्स ऑल द
पीपल जो जनरली होते हैं हमेशा। सो ये
लिस्ट है इनकी। आप सब भी यहां पे देख सकते
हैं।
यू कैन सी द लिस्ट एंड कई लोगों को मैं अब
नाम से यहां पे जान चुका हूं क्योंकि मैं
बार-बार इनको देखता हूं तो आईडिया लग चुका
है। एंड दिस इज द लिस्ट यू कैन सी हियर।
राइट? ओके।
थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस। एंड आप लोग अपना
टाइम देते हैं। उसके बदले मैं आई होप कि
आपको बेस्ट ऑफ़ द बेस्ट डिलीवर कर पाता
हूं। एंड आपकी टाइम जो है वो जस्टिफाई हो
पाती है। सो थैंक्स अ लॉट। जाते-जाते लाइक
ठोक देना, सब्सक्राइब मार देना, शेयर कर
देना वीडियो को। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में बहुत ही जल्दी। ठीक है?
गुड नाइट। बाय-ब। टेक केयर।